thank you
man is a javascript-based software stack
for creating Dynamic web pages and
online applications one application can
be deployed in one language for both
server side and client-side execution
because all components of the merge
stack supports JavaScript programming
hello everyone and welcome to Simply
learns YouTube channel I hope you guys
are doing well today we will be taking
you through the months tactful course
this month's tactful course is designed
to help you understand the most widely
used concepts of mongodb react.js
express.js and node.js in an exciting
manner in this full course you will
learn about mongodb how to install and
use the database after we will also
learn about node in express.js in detail
and then react by the end of this course
you will be able to understand and
deploy the month stack before we begin
let me tell you guys that we have
regular updates on programming videos so
if you are a programmer or you want to
learn something new then consider
getting subscribed to our YouTube
channel and press the Bell icon to never
miss any update from Simply learn
so without further Ado let's begin and
see what's in it for you
first we will see what is mongodb after
that we will see the comparison between
mongodb and MySQL moving ahead we will
see what is expressed JS it get and post
method after that we will see what is
middleware in Express JS moving ahead we
will see how to connect client-side to
the server side after that we will see
what is react.js features and Industrial
trends of react.js and then we'll see
how to install node.js on a Windows
machine moving ahead we'll see what is
node.js npm how to build node.js rest
API using node.js and then last we will
see how to connect node.js to mongodb
so let's begin
so what exactly is mongodb
it is a document oriented nosql database
it was initially released in August 27
2009.
mongodb replaces the concept of rows of
conventional relational data models with
something called documents it offers
developers the flexibility to work with
evolving data models since its document
based mongodb allows embedded documents
arrays and represents complex
hierarchical relationships using a
single record it is also schema free
which means that the keys defined in the
document are not fixed as a result
massive data migrations can be ruled out
but you must be wondering when there's
something like SQL why is nosql or
mongodb used there are a few reasons why
mongodb is widely used
first up is flexibility mongodb's notion
of documents that can contain
sub-documents nested in complex
hierarchies is really expressive and
flexible
flexible query model a user can
selectively index some part of a
document or a query based on attribute
values regular expressions or ranges
next up is native aggregation native
aggregation allows its users to extract
and transform data from mongodb and
either load them in a new format or
export it from mongodb to other data
sources it makes it extremely compatible
lastly as mentioned earlier the schema
free model now applications get the
power and responsibility to interpret
different properties in different ways
now that you know what mongodb is and
why exactly it's used let's have a look
at the characteristics of mongodb
firstly it's a general purpose database
now mongodb can serve heterogeneous
loads and multiple purposes within an
application
again it has a flexible schema design
document oriented approaches with
non-defined attributes that can be
modified on the Fly is a key contrast
between mongodb and any other relational
database
next up is scalability and load
balancing it's built to scale both
vertically but most importantly
horizontally using sharding an architect
can share load between different
instances and Achieve both read and
write scalability
when it comes to load balancing this
happens automatically and transparently
to the user by the sharp balancer
again we have aggregation framework now
mongodb offers an extract transform and
load framework that eliminates the need
for complex data Pipelines
native replication now data will get
replicated across a replica set without
complicated setup
security features both authentication
and authorization are taken into account
in mongodb
next up is Json now Json is widely used
across the web for front-end and API
communication and as such it's easier
when the database is also compatible
with the same protocol
lastly we have mapreduce now again
mapreduce is an excellent tool to build
data pipelines and mongodb uses
mapreduce readily now let's quickly have
a look at the working of mongodb
data is stored in documents with the
help of key value pairs now the data is
stored in the bson format at the back
end mongodb converts Json data into a
binary format known as bson
mongodb also makes provision for nested
data now all of these documents are
stored in a collection these collections
hold multiple documents and since
mongodb is schema less the documents in
one collection need not be similar now
again these collections are stored in
the entire mongodb database as mentioned
earlier mongodb makes provision for
nested data this makes fetching of data
extremely efficient when compared to
other databases now you must be
wondering where exactly mongodb can be
applied or used so let me help you with
that several areas of Technologies use
mongodb as their dbms currently some of
them are Internet of Things mobile
applications real-time analysis
personalization catalog management and
content management
now all said and done let's look at some
of the companies that use mongodb
currently
companies like Toyota sap AstraZeneca
Adobe verison Cisco Barclays and Google
among others readily deploy mongodb as
their database management system in this
video I'm gonna help you install and set
up mongodb on your Windows system
you will have to navigate to the
official mongodb website
and here you can see
software
so go ahead and click on community
server under software
and you can see that the current version
is 4.4.4 and the platform is Windows and
make sure that the package is MSI all
right now go ahead and press download
so this could take a while
all right so once it's downloaded
go ahead and install it
now since it's already installed on my
system uh the installation process will
be different but you just need to follow
the steps there and finally install it
so once you're done with the
installation you can go to your C drive
and here you can click on program files
and you can see that mongodb is
installed and inside of it you have the
server folder and then you have the 4.4
folder and then you have the bin folder
right so here you have the application
that is your [ __ ] and the mongod
applications both are executable files
now the [ __ ] D file or the application
is the daemin process now this is the
background process that makes sure you
retrieve the data from the database
access the data so it does all the
background tasks so after the
installation now you need to create a
path to this file by doing this you
don't have to always go to the bin
folder and then execute the file you can
directly execute the file on your
command prompt right so for that let's
just
go to our environment variables
but before that let's just uh
copy this path
right
and here under the user variable section
click on path and say edit
and go ahead and just paste it right
I've already pasted mine so just go
ahead and paste it and click on OK
and
say okay
right so now you've created the path
successfully now let's head to our
Command Prompt and run the [ __ ] file so
here you can just directly type [ __ ]
since the path has already been created
so just go ahead and say [ __ ]
[Music]
and here you can see that your [ __ ]
server has been generated
and with this you know that you're in
mongodb has been successfully installed
and your server is up and running right
so just for confirmation let's see if
there are any databases and how much
space they've occupied so you can right
now just type show DBS
and when you click on it it says admin
config and localhost and all of it is
zero so with that you have successfully
installed mongodb on your system and
it's up and running
all right in this particular tutorial
here we will be learning what mongodb is
all about and their advantages and some
practical demonstrations so let's get
started now
so here in mogodb we would like to
discuss about what is a mobile DB so as
we know the mongodb is known to be
called a traditional
document based database okay which
stores the data in a document
okay nosql means it doesn't say is like
no to SQL instead it says not only SQL
that means it is not only SQL but it is
supporting the other approaches too
okay so the document based when you talk
about it actually represents the typical
hierarchical relationship using the
single records that means how the
records are related with each other so
that's how exactly it represents and it
is a pure schema free environment so
that you really do not need to have
schema before you go and develop this
program so it is a pure schema less
involvement due to that it is giving you
far more better flexibility when you
talk about completely unorganized
environment
so what is nosql so the huge idea about
a nosql so it is completely into the
non-relational database like tradition
if you see any non-relational database
you talk about a typical nosql uh it's
purely into the document base here nosql
does not use any tables like in rows and
columns a traditional rdpps approach if
you see there they are using a complete
table structure like they talk about
columns they talk about rows and are all
about
so here in nosql it stores the
relationship data in the documents so
the different type of nosql databases
are available like you talk about called
document based you talk about key value
base you talk about white column based
and glass based different options are
available for the nosql but the one
which we are using it mongodb it is a
purely document based database
now here we would like to go ahead with
some demonstrations like talking about
like how modif installation works and
the other aspects foreign
so now we're gonna start working on the
first option called mongodb installation
okay see mongodb installation is very
simple if you open our website and go
for
this website name called
mongodb download
if you talk about your mobile DB
download you're gonna see the official
website called mongodb Community
download is available
when you click here
so you can see it is taking the current
version to 4.4.6
Mac OS and by default detected my
platform however you can select depends
on which platform you have it and after
that you will be clicking on this
download
okay so it'll get ready for if you are
from Windows
I would say in this Windows you can
select appropriate option like two
options are available you can talk about
MSI or talk about zip my recommendation
is you can stick to the zip power
portion because it won't start any
mongodb Services behind the scene
that is really helpful because you
really do not want more video to be
there running unnecessary even if it is
not required my situation is to stick to
the zip file so here once the mongodb is
there so you will be seeing that two
files available inside of mongodb folder
inside the bin so once you download the
zip you will find two different type of
files are available let me mention those
so inside the bin folder you will see
two files one is called mongod
okay the other file which is available
called Momo
mongod is to basically start the mongod
server and the mobile is actually the
client which will connect with the
bombodi clear so if you are in
Windows environment so once your Insight
is bin folder of your zip file you will
get the mongodb so you have to double
click on this it will start a new
command prompt
so you do not need to do anything
further just minimize this command
prompt and go inside the bin folder
again and click on the another binary
file called MoGo so it will get start as
a client
okay since I'm using the MacBook here
the concept is little different about
how mongodb can be used
okay so this is just a basic way of how
the move is being used into your code
okay everyone so now as we are in the
Macbook so here to start mode we have a
very special way to start with so here
I'll start with my terminal and here I
would like to paste one very simple
command to start my mongodb database
that is called mongod
and after that you have to say hyphen
iPhone DB path it is a place where your
database will be starting and one more
important thing I forgot to mention like
memory would not start automatically
inside your
Windows machine unless inside your C
drive you have to create a new folder
name called data and under this you have
to create a new folder in equal DB
because automatically when the mode
starts it looks inside the C drive data
inside a DB folder there your all
records will get stored so do not forgot
whenever you're trying to use the mongod
so you must make have you must have this
particular fold structure in place in
your local machine otherwise this is not
gonna start every time you start your
mongodb without this
location it automatically terminates So
to avoid those make sure that you have
this data DP folder ready with you
however you can also change the location
of this particular folder structure for
which we will discuss it little later on
but as of now we can see I'm giving my
location that is called hyphen haven't
DB path slash data DB I hit enter you
can see now my mobile DB is starting now
and since it's stuck so I have to start
the new terminal now
from so here I open the another tab
and type [ __ ]
and the multi-type mode now you can see
it is now connected with my mongodb and
now it is ready
that's the first thing you need to
remember
okay now to check
which are the databases are available to
you so you can just type show DBS
so it will show you the number of
databases which are already there inside
your existing
newly installed mongodb
but you can go back and create new
database too here you can see some
databases are already present however
you go back and create the new databases
into your system
and to create this database
we have very simple option available
here name call
use
simply DB
if I say use simplydb it automatically
creates this database and take you
inside let's see now you can see you say
you simply DB it automatically creates
though it is not there but automatically
takes you in while creating those
okay so that means your current database
name called simplydb
so if you are not sure which database
you are in we can just type DBS
or DB
and it will show you that your current
database is simply DB
that's it for your database is set and
we are all good to go ahead with our
next level development
hello everybody and welcome back in a
previous videos you have seen like how
to create a database and how to identify
whether my database is there or not so
if you remember previously we have
created our database using use keyword
so if I just see my databases which we
have created is last time so how we can
check this out we can say
show
space DBS
okay so you can see we have a got
database list but we do not have any
database which we have created last time
is registered here the quite surprising
because when we have created our
database it should be listed here but it
is not let's do one more time I'm saying
use
uh asset DB
and I'm saying switch to sldb now when I
say once again show DBS
so I still don't see my database is
listed here there is a reason the reason
is according to the momodb rule unless
we have minimum one
record or collection is stored inside my
mongodb it really can't show in the list
now I want to tell you about a few
important things
now
here when we talk about called mongodb
in this mongodb compared to the
relational database here the table which
is actually in rdbms it is called here
it is called
collection
okay
DB is still called DB here
okay that means the database will be
still called database but row what you
use this word in a traditional rdbm is
here it is known as chord document
if you remember I told you like it is a
document based database so here every
single record what you try to insert it
is not called
a typical row it is instead called a
document so every table is called
collection and every single row it is
called
document that's what exactly the
difference is
okay
now here once it is ready we will go
ahead and talk about our next feature
now
well we have to basically go and create
a new collection okay so what you can
say DB Dot
create
collection and here I can pass my
collection name I can say
demo
collection so once it is done
I can see it is collection is created in
typical language I can say the table is
created and now when I try to see same
show DBS
foreign
is now listed
okay that's how exactly it works so the
very simplest way of how we use in my
code
well in our previous examples we have
seen like how we can create a collection
and we can give the name and I can see
the details are listed when I say show
DBS but there's a again another
alternative option available where you
can just do that without even saying DB
dot create collection
well
if I want to create a collection I
really don't need this particular
functionality called create collection I
can directly use this statement name
called DB Dot
DB dot SL
udent
dot insert and here we would like to add
the property like a name and here we can
say
admin
now what does that meaning is when you
say DB dot SL student dot insert
I'm gonna hit enter you can see this
uninserted one and surprisingly when you
try to say
press enter you will see this SL student
is not a collection which we have
created earlier
so what this line does this line not
only create the collection for you but
also add a record inside with this
property called name because that is a
mongodb and mongodb is always following
the Json based structure and due to that
it goes with the key and value pairs
so DB is a predefined keyword SL student
is a collection name insert is a command
through which you are trying to insert
the record
now to check how many collections are
there
okay so we have one property call show
collections when I say show collections
I can list down those number of
collections or else I can set tables in
a typical rdbms language which are there
added in my system
so as a student in which I can see the
record is inserted so if I want to
confirm I can simply say
DB Dot SL
udent DOT fine find is a function
through which I can list out those
number of Records which are added I say
find and you can see that the records
are
received at the same time when I say DB
dot the name call Demo collection
okay
db.democollection dot find
I'll find no record reason because this
collection was created but there was no
record which was inserted in
but you will see when I
write this command called SL
student.insert it not only create a new
collection for me but also insert the
record into my table also called a
collection
that's where exactly it is giving you
the advantage when you want the
collections to be created along with the
data this is the way how you can really
do this
clear but
whenever you talk about DB dot create
collection many people always think
about what is the significance of having
this DB dot create collection
look DB dot create collection is having
its own significance we never recommend
this technique
okay to create a collection because when
you create a collection you always bring
some restrictions some terminology which
missed out whenever you talk about this
line
so having this DB dot create collection
you can also offer some
additional capping which is not possible
when you use TP Dot
collection input is research so you
might be thinking what those cappings
you're talking about let me try to brief
you when I say DB Dot
create
collection and here we are providing the
first name call support student
okay when I say student
so after this student additional
parameters what we can pass is this when
I say
capped colon
true
what do we say cap cool and true so you
are enabling the capping after that the
next parameter I'm gonna pass that is
normal skull size
in this size we are providing the size
suppose I am saying 5 to
4 and also we are saying two double
eight zero that is the size of 5 MB and
here we are giving call Max colon
five what exactly that meaning is see
the meaning is very simple whenever we
try to bring this great collection
option so capping through means you are
enabling the capping so what does that
meaning is it is trying to say in this
particular collection name called
student
maximum number of
documents
can be either five or less than five
clear and the collective size of
documents cannot be increased to more
than 5 MB that means you're trying to
say either by adding the total number of
five records the collective size of five
document will reach to 5 MB okay or else
the maximum number of five documents can
be is stored so whichever fills earlier
you may have a total number of four
documents which are pretty heavy and
they
reach to the size 5 MB and beyond that
the next document won't be added or else
you can have the five documents which
has not yet even reached so any option
will help you to achieve this
so that's where exactly you can offer
the capping but this is only possible
when the user is trying to say DB dot
create collection this option is not
possible when you're trying to use this
so that's the benefit of having this
db.create collection and this is what we
always recommend
well now we would like to talk about our
next feature here inside the same
mongodb so we now know how to create a
collection how to create a database and
how to switch from one database to
another database
now we will tell you like how to insert
a document so far we have already seen
how to insert a document inside the
mongodb now we would like to also show
you how we can insert the documents
using multiple techniques
so remember one thing
MoGo TV comes with two different type of
documents
one is called relational document and
second is called embedded document
mostly while working with mongodb we
always recommend you to use embedded
documents because that helps you to
scale up your application without any
hurdle
okay the embedded documents means what
that means the
uh I would say the parent record as well
as the child records both stores in the
same location
fine so how exactly that is let's take a
look about this example
here we would like to insert some
records by saying DB Dot
student I do not have a student
collection or I'm just telling you DB
dot student
Dot
insert
here we would like to add some records
what I'm trying to say the registration
number
registration number I'm just saying
uh one two three four you can give
anything now the next one we will talk
about call name
this name we can say
student one
followed by the next one I'm talking
about which course a student has
registered so we can say
course inside this course we would like
to say the course name let's say
course name we are giving the course
name called
MCA
okay followed by another property called
duration
okay I'm giving this duration is called
three
years like that
after that this curly braces is closing
that means see the idea is like you see
the course is an embedded document
because from course you have about few
more properties like in course name and
duration
I am closing this and starting the
another property and that is called
address
okay
sorry let me remove from here and from
address and address we can say one more
curly basis
and inside this address we can say City
giving the name called what
Bangalore
the another one we are using that is
called state
[Music]
um
let me remove this state
colon
ke
okay and the third property you are
using that is what is called country
here is saying IE which is called India
so it is closing here
okay and it is closing here so the inner
document and how to document both are
closed hit enter and now you can see the
records are inserted one thing you might
notice
the course
and the address these two are embedded
documents and they do not have any
primary key of its own instead the
course and address both are directly
dependent on
the student object
or the student database so
I will say student have the registration
number
five
and the primary key so the primary key
will be associated with the most outer
document and the inner documents are
directly
associated associated with them and now
when I try to say DB Dot
student
dot find
you can see now the records are
fetched
I can understand many of you are
thinking every time
while adding the record we do not add
any object ID
and here you might have observed and
there also your option then what exactly
that ID is now let me brief you this ID
is nothing but a unique primary key your
mongodb has offered you
that means mongodb says whichever data
you are inserting it so by default with
every single document
mogodb will associate this by default
property called underscore ID which you
can't even ignore
however you can overwrite
I haven't provided any
underscore ID is a property because this
is a predefined property associated with
every single mongodb document if you
want to override it you can overwrite
from this value to any value because if
you do not pass any value
this value will be automatically
provided that is a typical hexadecimal
value however if you want to override it
you can override the value of underscore
ID but you can't change the key name
let's try with some
another record so same record if I try
to add
let's go
I'm using call
student2 and here I'm saying one two
three four five here if I want to
override it I can just say underscore ID
colon I can get the value called what
one zero one
this you need to remember for I'm
overriding this value with 1 0 1 now
adding it now records are added now let
me call find now you see this time the
records when I fetched so in this record
the first record contains a default
underscore ID in a second record it is
the one which I have provided
and remember one thing in mongodb you
really can't offer any property other
than underscore ID as a primary key
here there is no concept of having the
cons like a composite key which you used
to do in Tradition rdbms here you have
only underscore ID and this is the only
property which you can override it else
by default the new value will be given
to you so this is the first way of how
the insert document has been done we'll
be telling you the another ways where
the other documents are also added Okay
so
in the previous examples you have seen
like how we can add the records but I
also tell you there is another
alternative options are available if you
want to insert the records in a bulk
that option is also possible in mongodb
how we can do let's try to understand
here
here we would like to use one very
simple concept for one
my
EMP equal to now starting with
a typical object like this and after
that I will adding this and within this
I'm adding the first property called EMP
ID
foreign
one
after this okay now you can see it is
not understanding because that is a
challenge when we talk about called uh
you know the logical part
because you go with multiple lines it is
not supporting however you have to
follow the same lines now amp id1 and we
just give the second property called EMP
name
so
amp ID just
remove this I just say EMP ID and I say
amp
Name colon
admin
okay adding it here
so
first record here again I'm adding
another one I will call
amp ID column two
okay and now
colon
manager
okay again
column three
and
colon
Cuba
added
okay and this curly process is closing
after this
your square bracket is also closing and
once it is done it will come down and
say DB
Dot
new amp
dot insert
and here you pass the name of the object
called my AFB
and you can see now it is telling you n
inserted 3 that is known called bulk
insert we are inserting multiple records
in a single shot
see how easy it is for you
okay now you simply use DB dot The
Collection name is what your new AP
dot find
and you can see now all three records
are inserted with its default object ID
okay so that is a really nice idea to
have
the ID to be provided
okay remember this statement
so you understood finally how we can
add the records in a bulk going forward
we will also talk about which is related
to your update as well as delete in your
upcoming demos okay but here that is the
first thing which you realize it how we
can perform those kind of operations in
very very simple and straightforward
manner okay everyone so now we have got
three records with us and in case if I
am planning to perform update on any of
my records how will I do this now so we
have a predefined functions available
name called update function let's see
how this update function can really work
so we use this statement name called DB
dot what is my collection name which is
known as call a new EMP new EMP
okay dot
update
okay so what I will do I will say TP dot
new EMP Dot
update here
okay now when we talk about call update
we have a
statement available
okay what is that that is called
empid name so we say wherever the EMP ID
is this I want to change what the name
how can I do this now very simple uh
to perform this what I would like to do
now I want to basically add few more
records to give you some more better
idea
uh you can see now here we have a call
admin ID name
so I just do one thing I just change the
IDS
uh one two three I just say four
I said five
message six
okay and I
call this
again the three records are inserted now
let me try to call find now we have
total number of
six records are available where
admin is repeated manager is repeated QA
is repeated
now let me try to update the record
okay now I want to say DB Dot
new EMP
Dot
update here I would like to perform the
property like and what
uh name as a EMP name
amp Name colon if I say admin
okay
so I just close that and I use
another curly braces with dollar
set that means you want to set the new
value here we are giving
EMP name
okay what I want to do I say wherever
the name is admin change to what
foreign
that name I want to change it
closes close this
and run
now you can see it is saying and match
to one
and the records fields are updated like
this let me check
well here I will see uh the value called
admin new is updated but I have one more
admin called admin it is not changed and
there is something which you need to
notice
what you need to notice is notice is
like when you try to perform update so
what mongodb does it starts from the top
find the first record
change the value or modify the value and
come out from the loop it doesn't carry
forward its search process for the next
level of results and that is something
which is
I really want to do that so in case if
you are planning to change those values
multiple times so what you need to do
let's take a look here in the similar
example here we have a called name admin
second property we will call manager
let's try to say
the managers are repeated twice we just
want to change to
new underscore
manager and I want to update multiple
values what I will do here
I will put comma and say
multi
colon true
okay saying multicolon true that you
want to say hey I want to update
multiple
search or multiple repetitions hit enter
this time you can say it is saying and
match to and modify 2 that means two
records found and two records are
modified let's check
there we go we have got new manager is
updated in both the location
that's something which is really awesome
because this is how you try to perform
the multiple changes
well in our previous examples you see
like how we can perform the update part
but we have a one more beautiful feature
available inside the mongodb and that is
called how exactly we can perform absurd
clear let's talk about absurd upset is a
combinations of update and insert let me
try to show you one magic here
here
when we talk about called update part
you see now
here we are trying to say
uh
this point
yeah you see about multi-true we have
used
now here
this multi-true
is we're trying to update but let's talk
about something called manager 2.
enter now you can see it is saying no
records formed
clear now no records formed
but there's one concept available in
call absurd absurd means if I try to
perform up certain means if the records
are not available it will insert the
record
I want to show you one simple example
now here we are using multi-truth
okay so as I can see we're using
something called name and we're
performing this update part
so in this update part we are using this
dollar set new manager so here rather
than using multi-truth
we are saying
obstacle
when I say up search rule so what
happened now they say and matched 0 and
up inserted 2 and modified with ID test
that means when I try to call this find
function you will be seeing now we have
a god
the another record has been added are we
clear now
as a new record
so upsa does what upset says like if the
records are found
I will update it if it is not I will
insert it that means if I try to call
the same thing manage it to
why it is added as a new manager now if
I just try to say
uh
not manage it to I will call QA
q a and here we're saying EMP equal to
new
underscore QA
and now you can see it is saying n
matched one and I've sorted 0 and
modified one so it is clearly telling
you like hey I did not find any
uh inserted part but yes I matched one
record I found one record and the one
record is updated now that is very very
beneficial feature when you really want
to perform absurd so that is a insert
very important feature that depends on
the requirement if you want to add you
can certainly add this so the way we
have tried to add this upserted part we
can also try to perform the delete part
also
okay so mongodb also helps you to
perform the delete part and how you'll
be trying to add it now let's try to
understand here in my code if I were to
perform any delete path I have this
statement name called DB
dot the option we are using it that is
an also collection name EMP
sorry
dot we have option name for remove
then this remove we would like to offer
the property
okay and what we're talking about now
here let's try to add the ID here or the
name which you would like to import so I
want to say like EMP name admin new so
we just say
p
name
okay
and then
scoreboard
admin name
okay EMP name admin name when I say
remove
we can see it is record removing the
first record
so you can see now the records are
removed
fine because there is only
one admin is available
okay now in a similar way if I try to
remove
the property call a new underscore
manager new underscore
management hit enter now you can see the
three records are removed so it's not
like update which removes only one sorry
update only one record it can also
eliminate more than one records at the
same time
that's the benefit of remove so now you
can see we have already implemented some
records as I seen earlier like we have
performed the delete part now
when I try to say DB
Dot
new EMP dot find
three records are available with me
three four and six
now when it comes to C in third part we
have seen update part we have seen
delete part we have seen now it's time
to basically fetch the records
so find function we've already seen But
in find function we also have some
conditions so called queries so in case
if you want to limit the number of
Records into your application you can
also do that let's see DB
Dot
a new EMP
Dot
find
clear now so in fine you can also
pick up the specific records too like
when I'm saying dot find and here we can
just say name
colon
admins
sorry
here to put curly braces
it says there is no record with a name
called admin
because it is the EMP name not a name so
let me change back to
now I can say it finds one record so
like that you can also apply a condition
okay enter your code now in a similar
line if you really don't want to offer
any condition
okay but you want to limit the number of
Records to be shown so you have this
function available name call
limit
2 2 means only two records now you can
see though I have three records but it
is only showing me two records because I
have limit those number of Records into
my code
also we can perform sorting in case if
you want to perform the Sorting in
ascending and descending order that also
you can also do so here rather than
saying limit
with this put this option name called
sort and in this sort on which property
you want to sort it that also you can
mention so we can just say EMP name
okay and using ascending button or
descending order so you can just say
um minus one well you got descending
order
hit
now I can see it is showing the
descending order now if I just say
minus 1 if you just say 1 that is
showing you in an ascending order so you
can pick up the specific property we
have on which you can tell it should be
either on descending order or ascending
order so that option really works very
fine
okay
so that's like how you can perform the
queries but remember one thing you can
also
search the records based on the embedded
columns too because if you see in a
previous records we have some records
added okay that is
let me try to say show
collections
our call SL student
and student
okay DB Dot
Dot
find
okay
you can see we have records which are
embedded records now if you want to
search the records based on their
embedded properties like I am talking
about address this is about property
name called City
fine so if you would like to pick up
those records these are also possible
so how you can do this very simple so
you say TV DOT
student Dot
find
okay so inside is fine you can provide
the specific properties like my
outermost property name is called what
address so we are using this option
called
address dot dot city so we say City
are we clear colon I'm giving the city
name called what Bangalore
okay let me close this
and that's it
okay so we have to start passing
another curly places here hit enter and
you can see now I find two records
because both the records belong to what
Bangalore so I'm getting this
City Bangalore with me
that's really awesome like you can also
pass the city accordingly
a part of that we also have
the other details also okay in which you
can have the conditions based on less
than greater than or whatever values you
would like to make it is available and
possible
okay so that's how the conditions are
satisfied
so suppose if you would like to pick the
users
I'll be clear where the range which you
would like to consider so those are also
possible like you can see we have this
property name called what amp ID3 and 6.
I just want to pick up only those
records whose ID is greater than what
two so what I can say DB
dot new EMP okay dot find
and inside this file we can say
the property okay so what's property
we're using empid we are saying EMP ID
here colon here we'll be using dollar GT
GC stands for what greater than colon
we're giving the value called what one
why close this
run we can see your received three
records three four and six
in case if I just look forward for
higher than 5
you will see only one record so greater
than
let's call GT
okay
same option if I just say LT
you can see we have found
two records so less than greater than
okay so that's how exactly you offer it
okay and also you can provide the
condition so called limit as I can say
find EMP ID the way we provide it so
here I will not use
listed
okay instead I'll be providing another
property let me show you what
so here in empid whatever we have taken
so let me try to take the property call
file and here we'll be providing EMP
ID and then
we're using another curly braces and
we're using Dollar in is very important
property Dollar in Colon here you
provide the details I'm saying uh inside
so the property is three four six we are
saying 3
comma 6.
close this
and you can see we got two records
which matched with three and six that's
the benefit of having
this okay everyone so in our previous
example we have already seen lot many
activities this time we are trying to
offer you something very interesting
feature and that is known is called
working with indexing see mongodb is one
of the most popular tool
and one of the reason why it is very
popular because it is having the
facility of having indexing now what
exactly the index does so friends main
job of having this index is to basically
give you the concept of like how uh one
particular uh document which is huge
document in case if you would like to
perform any sort of indexing inside this
how you will be applying this
so to apply indexing into my code let's
try to understand why index is really
required without indexing and with
indexing how you'll be making a
difference into the code
so to make it happen we would like to
insert some records to confirm
okay so what I will do is in Step number
one
previous records if I see I have got
four six three four one depends on what
earlier records we had it so we had a
call
new EMP
so DB dot new EMP
dot fight
so we have total number of three records
are available so it's okay we can have
this three records with me now let me
try to apply indexing without indexing
if I want to find a result what outcome
I'm gonna receive so to know about how
much time it gonna be taking if if I
have a got large number of records with
me I'll be using this statement name
called DB
dot the name is called New EMP
Dot
explain and here I will be using one
predefined functionality called
execution starts
execution starts
okay now here after the execution starts
you'll be using Dot
find we'll be using the first property
here
okay and
what user would like to find it that you
need to basically offer it so we are
giving the name called EMP name
colon with the name call
QA
okay let's close
okay now when I pressed hit enter
execution stats is a predefined
functionalities which will tell me
when the query was executed what exactly
the query plan was hit enter and now you
can see a lot of details
are available with me
like you can see
power query winning plan and everything
one thing you need to Remember by
default
here when I try to run it says and
return one
Advance or need time total everything it
is showing me but one important thing
which you will see here
is
total number of documents is scanned
so it is telling me total number of
document examined is 3.
clear now
and return one that means one result is
returned and the total number of
documents examines three in order to
find this record
so imagine a use case here
when I say total number of documents
examine 3 in case if I ever got millions
of records with me that means to search
the record it will examine all the
Millions number of Records to search the
result which certainly gonna be taking
huge amount of time
and that's where exactly when you try to
search the record
fine when you have no indexing is
available
okay so you need to understand one
important thing is
by default index is applied on your
underscore ID DB Dot
new EMP
um
yeah DB dot newmp dot
when I say DB dot new emp.getindex is a
predefined function it tells me like hey
by default index is applied or
underscore ID
that's the fact because by default index
is applied on underscore ID not on the
other properties
so I need to identify which of the
properties are required to be get
indexes mongodb advantages it is
supporting multi-column indexes and
that's what exactly we would like to see
so let's see in our next demo now we
will try to apply indexing on our own
property
okay so to apply the index what we need
to do we have to say DB
Dot
certainly we will be talking about
called collection name call
um new EMP
Dot
create index
here you have to pass two things number
one
on which property you would like to
apply okay and it has to be ascending or
descending
so I am trying to apply on
EMP
and I want the index to be applied on
ascending order
okay so here
colon 1.
hit enter you can see now it is telling
me like uh
number of indexes before 1 and number of
indexes after two that means earlier
index was available only on one
particular property now it is applied on
two properties if you want you can check
now you can see there's another property
is added called EMP underscore
now if I try to execute a similar query
which I executed earlier
now you'll be seeing there's a different
statistics all together
here if I see
in my code
see it will tell you total document
examined one see now earlier the number
of document examined were 3 but since
this index is applied notice telling me
the total number of document examined is
one so performance is certainly improved
so to search your document it won't be
searching the complete
collections
okay rather it will search what only
that particular column in which it is
actually applied for so that's the
benefit in fact I would say when you
will be using these kind of indexes into
your code
okay so hope we all are clear and
understood about this concept so let's
go ahead and get the simply minted into
our system
well this is the first way of how the
index can be applied so you can also
apply index on multiple properties
clear so that we will show you one by
one how it is
okay everybody so we have already seen
in our previous example how we have
applied indexes in our existing mongodb
application
so it is also a possibilities where we
want to also apply the index on other
number of properties too as you can see
in our existing database
okay an existing collection my
collection name is new EMP which
contains two different properties one is
called amp ID in second called EMP name
just now we have applied index on our
EMP name but in case if I want to apply
index on EMP ID I'll be using the same
technique okay let's try to apply index
on the same
so first of all get indexes I'm having
this index applied on two different
property now we would like to say DB
dot create
index and here in this DB dot create
index we can just
I will say DB dot collection name so our
collection name is called New EMP new
EMP
dot create index first parameter is
certainly the name of which property we
are applying so here we are saying EMP
ID
and in this EMP ID we will just offer it
has to be sending or descending let me
decide descending order
so we're seeing
-1
okay now let's press enter and check the
status okay now you can see earlier
indexes which we have created that was
two and now it turns to three so it is
very clear that index is improving now
let's check this out
uh DB Dot
newmp.getindexes now we have a total
number of three indexes are available
so you can apply index of n number of
columns if you want
okay at the same time the way we have
created the index in case if I want to
drop an index so we can also drop so
what we can do DB dot new EMP
dot drop index
drop
index
and in this drop index we have to
provide
which particular index we would like to
draw
remember this point in case if you're
planning to drop any sort of index so
you need to provide which index so you
should have that particular index name
okay so here we are providing my index
name so it should not be uh I would say
the traditional name called EMP ID no it
has to be EMP ID underscore minus 1 or
EMP name underscore one so this should
be the name I'm saying EMP
use if you try this
you see it is saying index not found
with the EMP name because internally it
maintains with this name
let's try this out we say EMP name
underscore one let's try
and now you can see new index was 3 okay
1.
okay
now you can see we have a call empid and
underscore ID
so now we have
only two indexes left there's no EMP
name anymore this is how exactly you can
drop the indexes so it is very simple
and straightforward way of how
in mongodb you can perform your
activities hello everybody and welcome
back
in a previous examples of mobodb you
might have considered
we have used lot many operations in our
last video we have seen how to utilize
indexing into our code now in our next
journey of our mongodb we will see how
aggregation Works see in mogodb
aggregation plays a vital role and
aggregation comes with so many handy
functions with mongodb which will help
you to perform
and to apply some very simple code
Snippets into your ongoing
uh I would say the requirement which can
make your query so much seamless now we
will see how this aggregation really
works and to work on an aggregation we
have taken some default database name
called aggregate DB and here we have a
call student as a by default collection
in which we have some set of records are
already added
now if I just want to apply aggregation
now I would like to tell you about what
exactly the aggregation is see ideally
when you talk about call aggregation
okay so aggregation is nothing but a
call aggregate like rdbms if you see
typical aggregation there so the Unix
command like you talk about shell
pipeline means the possibility to
execute an operation on some input and
use that output as an input for the next
command
that means the output of one particular
execution becomes an input for others
so mongodb also supports same kind of
concept in aggregation framework there's
so many type of functionalities are
available which we will see one by one
into our next code
okay now here we want to confirm about a
few important things now here let me try
to bring some of the important well
known
I would say the functionalities of our
aggregation framework first we use a
term name called dollar project
the project is basically designed for
select
specific
fields Donald project is designed to
select what a specific fields from a
collection we used to talk about called
what
dollars match
the match is responsible
to filter out the operations
are we clear now it is designed to
filtering out the operations
you talk about dollar group
talk about caller dollar group so it
does the actual aggregation
fine we talk about call Dollar sort
okay it basically sort the document okay
like that there's so many operations
that are available which you will see
one by one in our aggregation Behavior
now my first example the one which I
want to execute I have a call student
record with me which contains a student
name look at the section
and the marks and the subject on which
subject the person or the student
disappeared now here my first
requirement is we want to filter
data based on a Section 8 because
students belong to different sections as
you can see now it is they belong to the
different section section A B C D so I
just want to filter the data based on a
section A
okay so for filter out I would like to
use dollar match let's see how it works
so I just would like to filter out only
those students who belong to the section
A
so how we would like to use it now I
will say DB Dot
student Dot
aggregate
and inside this we would like to use
this
square brackets and then curly braces
and then use
dollar
match
with this I would like to use another
curly braces
and I say
section
a
okay and I close this close this close
the square bracket close this
okay so DB dot student dot aggregate
aggregate should be always associate
match is now the aggregate functionality
section a hit enter and you can see now
it lists down all those students who
belong to the section 8.
okay very simple and straightforward
example
now we would like to use the second
example so we want to find out all the
records where this section is a and we
are using and operator Max is greater
than 80 there are so many students who
have a different marks like 1790 and
whatever
so we want to use both the conditions
together so how are you going to be
using this now remember not only the
section A but also marks were greater
than 80. so similar thing we have a call
match
okay after this match we are starting
this curly braces
okay so after this match we would like
to bring and
reset all
and and again colon
again we are starting this call bracket
now
okay we talk about what
section A
number one and after this the first
curly braces we would like to use marks
we say
marks colon and once again
I would like to start curly braces and
here we use
dollar GT that is called what a greater
than colon
80.
okay all are closed so you see like here
we have got this square bracket in round
brackets
so
what else is left
so we have a call 80 we are using
another curly braces needs to be closed
here and then
square bracket
okay and followed by again curly braces
green curly braces
again square bracket okay round brackets
okay
let's see where it is going wrong
so we're using this DB dot
student.aggregate we'll use this
yeah square bracket then curling braces
then we use dollar match
okay after the dollar match
we are using another curly braces and we
have a call and operator
after this and we have a call
risk now square bracket then curly
braces section A
outer section is getting closed we are
using another curly braces marks colon
dollar GT
okay and we are using what colon
80. after that we are closing this
and using two more curly which is called
bracket in this
okay so this where exactly you can
utilize that so DB dot student dot
Aggregate and like this it will be able
to get it now okay so in a previous
example I was the only missing point was
after this
uh this dollar match we didn't apply
this curly braces
that was only missing point which was
there and now we have applied another
code is giving me this outcome and I
have only one user who's scoring greater
than 80. well that was the first thing
which we have it now
along with this I would like to go ahead
and talk about few more things now I
just would like to bring selective
Fields not all the fields like as you
can see we have a call student name
section marks everything I'm getting it
so I really don't want to bring all the
properties from this document I would
like to selectively take specific
property so
let's talk about how we can use this so
we'll be using project you remember
about project is responsible to select a
specific record
so I just use this statement name called
DB Dot
student okay dot
I click it we're using it now after that
square bracket
then curly braces now we are trying to
say dollar
project
what you would like to use dollar
project and colon we are trying to use
student name
okay colon
okay remember one thing one means I want
to zero means I don't want so whichever
property will be enabling it by giving
the one as a digit that means it is
it is expected to be displayed so I'm
saying one
comma I'm saying section
colon 1 okay and I'm also
looking forward for marks
colon one
that's it so now
you can see now I am once again picking
up only those like student section and
marks now if I go back and remove some
properties like I only want
student and section you can see I have
only students and sections are used
here if I just use this statement name
call
underscore ID column 0.
now you can see only
the names and sections are visible ID is
not because I really don't want ID by
default ID is shown but if I says 0 that
means the ID will not be visible here so
like that you can select
The Columns or the properties
accordingly that was the one way now
another thing I would like to use
what if you want to find out the student
name section and marks from student once
again we want to find out this total
name section and marks from the student
collection where the section is a
okay so here it will be the combinations
of match as well as the project
how we can use this let's take a look
towards my implementation
if you see the previous one what we have
used here
you remember about we have used this
statement called aggregate match
okay so now we would like to go back and
utilize
after this total match
this is a curly basis I'm giving
section
colon
a
foreign
a and after this I'll close this
okay and close this again
I'm opening it up by using this option
call
project dollar
project we are picking up the project
right now and here with this colon
symbol we can use again and say
student name
foreign
Name colon we are using one
comma
section colon 1
and
1.
Max colon 1 and now
closing this
now I can see I got those so the
requirement was
we want to find out the student name
section and marks from student
collection with the section is a so you
are not only using the match
okay but also using what the selective
details like this you can implement it
okay that's where exactly the projection
really works so projection gives you lot
many opportunities which you can utilize
it for your own and also it comes with
lot many predefined functions like in
some AVG and all so let's talk about
those functionalities too
so this is the first thing which we have
seen aggregations are taken place now in
case if you would like to perform the
group like if I want to find out a total
marks
Group by
okay section like each and every section
I would like to confirm the total marks
in every section then how will I
basically do that
so let's try to get this example also
so here
let me try to
go back
and we will not be using match here
because I would like to use the group
part
so
after this curly braces we want to use
dollars
group
okay let's go Group by rdbm is how you
use it here we use this curly braces
again here we are passing this
underscore ID
okay you have to provide underscore ID
in a group because you cannot skip it
that part you need to be always remember
you really can't skip dollar ID whenever
you're trying to talk about code group
this is a compulsory field you need to
have it after that
Now using this
section
in this section
we are saying dollar
section
because we would like to make it on a
section basis
after this
closing and here we are using what
total marks
colon here curly braces
again
uh dollar
sum
okay colon on which we have I want to
use it marks so I can say dollar marks
naming convention is very important
because it is a JavaScript so it is a
case sensitive
okay then
and you can see now section wide I'm
able to get all the marks isn't this an
amazing that's where exactly the
aggregations are playing very important
role while retrieving such kind of
Records
so hope you are clear about how we
utilize this together
so in a previous example we got it like
how we are basically taking this marks
in my application
fine so we are clear about how we are
picking that up but what in case if I
would like to take a marks for the
specific section
so it is also possible so we'll be using
the same group but only thing is what
will be bringing the match between
because here we are trying to get the
all the section marks but if you would
like to bring it only for the specific
section we know it very well what we
need to do so here
before I talk about called dollar group
we can use one more curly braces here
okay so we can use this option called
dollar match
okay and here we are using this
uh option called section A
sorry
here in dollar match we are giving this
call
section
here we're giving
so closing this
closing this
followed by
the other areas like in group which you
want to start now
so you can start with this curly braces
hit enter and you can see now only the
specific section we are able to receive
the records
and that's very simple now
okay so that's where exactly you would
like to perform and there's another
option like in case if you would like to
perform at an average suppose if you
want to fetch the count of student in
each section and total marks and average
marks as well is so total marks as well
as the average marks you want to get it
so how are you able to take it now
so it is very simple as you have seen
earlier also into our code how you have
taken called group underscore ID section
talking about section
total marks with the sum we are also
using this after that we can also use
the average
okay so
this is we have taken group underscore
ID sum
so here onwards we will start
so when we say sum marks after that we
can just put curly braces
and we can just use count
okay and after this we'll be using this
column
curly basis and use
dollar
sub
okay
colon one
okay and after that I'll put
comma here and we use
average
and inside this average I will use
in curly braces we can say
dollar AVG
okay colon of what
dollar
marks
very simple
so curly process is closed
okay so total how many three curly
braces will be closed
one square bracket and all brackets and
now you can see you got the average
markings in each and every section so
just imagine how easy it is for you to
deal with the aggregations so
aggregation seems to be very very simple
approach provided by mobo TV that really
create a difference of how the
aggregation changes the way how you
react to
okay everybody so after going through uh
the idea of like how we can utilize
the concept of
aggregation it's time to talk about like
how when it works with mogodb mobile DB
is properly known for
I will say for replication that is
called high availability and that
feature comes by default with mongodb
you really don't need to install any
software for this because it is a
built-in feature for the mongodb so when
you download that it comes along with
this so no additional uh configuration
setup is really required when it comes
to the mongodb part okay so let's get
started and talk about how momodb can
offer the replication see the ID behind
the application is what the ID behind
the application is like you are
replicating it
okay
so we talk about course application you
are replicating your data to wait the
multiple child so here in Mobile DB we
have one concept available
okay that is known as called master
okay and
slaves
okay Master is one and there will be
multiple sleeves okay so these slaves
where your records are actually stored
and this is a master which will be
responsible to replicate the data to all
its Childs when the request comes due to
that in case I have one particular
node fails so automatically the data
will be taken from the other nodes
that's the beauty of having this master
and node slave process so to make this
possible we have a very simple option
available
Atlas so there we can go and get our
cluster ready so here we start with the
concept name called [ __ ]
DB Atlas
let's search for mobile DB Atlas and
here I see mongodb Atlas database as a
service see this is a free tool it's the
cloud environment where you really don't
need to install mobile DB in your local
machine it is a cloud-based mongodb
support which is free to use with a
limited amount of space but yes for the
testing purpose it is the best suitable
so I can start with the start free or
else I can say the login here
okay from there onwards I can go ahead
now it is getting ready
now this is a place from where you can
start working on your cluster see as
I've told you like initially when you
will be working on this
mobile DB it will ask you to create a
cluster
initially
okay since I already have a cluster with
me
okay so I really don't need to create it
and as a free tier it will not allow me
to have more than one cluster setup
ready
so if I say create a new cluster
okay and I say by default AWS
okay another very close to all this
notification AWS you can select any
other cloud provider and uh
8GB Ram Cloud backup cluster name you
can see now it is taking me
0.54 per hour reason being because I
already have a cluster with me hence
more than one cluster is not allowed in
a free TI cluster so I have to cancel
this but
you can go and create a cluster the way
it was offered there so if you want to
create you can just go ahead and do
nothing just select by default AWS
select your location okay give the name
of the cluster you want to give anything
you can give it here otherwise let it be
the by default name cluster when say
create cluster it will take a while
minimum two to three minutes depends on
the availability it creates a cluster
for you and your cluster once it is
ready it looks like that
Okay so
here in this application you have to go
back and understand what is there any
questions when I click on cluster zero
you can see now here we have a got three
nodes available one is called primary
node which is called Master as I
suggested earlier
and no view called slaves automatically
when the Clusters are created inside
this mongodb by default it will be three
node cluster where the one will be the
primary and two will be secondary
based on your package whichever you have
taken it you can increase the number of
nodes later on but as a free I am gonna
get or I will be receiving total number
of three nodes available here
so records whichever will be stored it
will get stored automatically in both
the nodes
secondary notes and from the primary I
can insert the record in secondaries I
can read the records remember you can't
insert records into the secondaries you
can only insert a record only in your
Prime music or secondaries are not
allowed
to insert
so this is your replica set okay these
are the nodes which are available to you
so when you click on this primary here
you will see
it is telling you know whatever no data
available no data available nothing is
there because I haven't stored any
records as such so I just go back to my
cluster
so initially I would like to go back and
create few things now okay I would like
to go back and set up few initial things
at a time of creating the cluster
because when you cluster is created
clear now so in that point of time no
setting is configured you have to do few
settings now first setting is you have
to put it and remember the steps First
Step will be your network access so in
network access you have to go and you
have to say add IP address and in this
add IP address you have to select this
option
from which location you would like to
accept
only those IP addresses will be
whitelisted otherwise what you can do
you can see here in my options I have
given 0.0.0 that means all IP addresses
are
acceptable so all IP addresses are used
okay so this you have to enable it
otherwise you won't be able to get
this network access from any third party
locations
next you have to talk about call
database access which is required for
you to create a new user there are
already some new users are created but
it is recommended that you to go and
create a new users here
okay so you can go back and add a new
user so by default it is username and
password is given so you can go back and
create a new user when I say add user
you can give the username as well as the
password as per your own convenience so
new user I'm going to create it that is
known is called SL okay user
and here we're giving call
admin
one two three so SL user admin123
remember this will be the username and
password I'm saying add user
new user is automatically added as a
user every one two three
so
once you have provided this network
access database access
next you have to create a new data
so what you need to do when you go back
to your
statement okay network access database
access it will ask you like you want to
create a new database so I just go back
to my project zero there will be on an
option equal collections
you have to go back and create a new
collection here
now it is retrieving the list of
databases
now you can see there are already some
collections are there DB is one of the
database which is there
demo DB is there not many databases are
there so you can go back and create some
new database and connect through
so if I just create database I already
have a simple learn DB with me user app
is already when collections are created
so creating a database in correction is
very easy if I give you the quick demo I
say create database
give the collection name call SL demo
okay and give the username call
EMP
specialty employee like say create
now you can see SL demo create it is
there with me so there is no record
right now and once it is there ready so
remember asset demo and employee I'll go
back to my uh
code again project zero
and from here I can say connect
because I want to connect it so to
connect it from because your mongodb is
already there so you want to connect it
through so to connect it through here
very simple option available you can
just click on this
correct option multiple options are
there through [ __ ] share connect your
third party application of the mongodb
compass so since I already have a [ __ ]
shirt with me so Mac OS I have this Mac
OS with me so you can just use this line
okay so if you have a window you can
select your window since I have this Mac
OS I'm selecting this line but I need to
replace with this
you can see this username
okay and you have to give the username
here I will I'll selected this I'll open
my terminal
okay and this is I'm just closing this
I'm opening up
other terminal here
since I want to connect to the [ __ ]
shell now
so what I need to do here in this
I'll just paste that the command which I
have right now
username is
you remember I told you
do you call
some users which you have already
created
let's check
here
SL user
I say
Excel user I hit enter it lasts me the
password so I've given the password
admin
and now you can see it is connecting
with me to this particular
see
now see it is connecting me to this a
particular replica set you can see in a
logs it is telling you very clearly
okay saying that it is a username 4.2
and you can see it is correcting with
your sharp cluster the cluster which is
created and this is where exactly I have
it with me
so I'm connecting with this environment
so primary is there if I just want to go
back and say
show
collections
so I can go back and create a new
collection here
okay so it's up to you now by default
collection which is your employee so I
can say DB Dot
employee Dot
insert
and now here we can just add
name
okay
now you can see some exception is raised
so
you understand
foreign
cluster so if I just go back and
go back to my project zero where we have
got
collections
here you will be getting
the
SL demo
employee
loading the documents
so it takes time to get this but this is
where exactly you see the records will
be stored
okay so that's where exactly it works
fine for all of you
so we have this
record okay so when I say
show collection so we have a call
employee when I say TV DOT
employee Dot
find
so I can see we have got new collection
name called
this is added right now
okay so like this you have got the first
connection established and the records
has been inserted in this particular
tutorial we will help you to connect
your mongodb
with the front end it is called python
as we know it very well about the
popularity of python in last recent
years it is growing like anything so we
thought why not to offer you this
connectivity where you can have the
mongodb
not in a local environment but in a
cloud environment so here we will tell
you how to create the momodb complete
environment of cluster in your cloud and
we can have this connectivity with our
python which is running local to my
system if I show you what few important
things
one by one
so why python mongodb we understand
mongodb is one of the most important
database which is so called document
based database available in market and
it is fantastic phenomenal in terms of
speed and the reliability
it is purely called nosql database okay
and helps you to go schema less
now python is one of the most commonly
user-friendly programming language for
creating a complete web-based framework
so it offers you huge amount of
libraries with flexibility of connecting
wide variety of applications
so we would like to give you the idea of
like how Python and mongodb works
together
okay so you can use both the
products together to develop
different varieties of applications
which can suit
to different type of ideas now here we
have one of the very very popular tool
available name called Pi [ __ ] so Pi
[ __ ] is actually the python Library
which is a kind of a driver through
which you will be able to connect with
your mongodb and perform basic
operations whichever you expect
okay so let's go ahead and start working
on those demos okay
so we will start with
creating a mongodb environment with
cluster in one of the very very popular
tool that is known as called mongodb
Atlas so we'll be opening our website
and go here and talk about call
mongodb Atlas
I search for mongodb Atlas that is
basically the momodb they called
database as a service I'll be selecting
the first option
and go to the start free because it's
going to offer you by default some 500
MB of free space I say sign up with
Google
going ahead and selecting this
okay I say accept and say submit
okay so it is starting up now
It'll ask you about a few things I would
rather say to you select skip
and continue
well it'll ask you about which
environment you would like to take so I
like to take this shared cluster I say
create cluster now here it will take a
while to get yourself ready for you can
see it is offering the sandbox of having
five lb of free space
and this mongodb
no backup that is the by default cluster
name you can give the name of the
cluster if you want but Let It Be by
default cluster theorem saying create
cluster
so my cluster is being ready so it will
take a while to get your cluster set up
so just wait till the timer cluster is
getting ready so I'll tell you what this
cluster is going to give you by default
to child and one parent so called a one
master and two
a child nodes where your cluster will
get ready
so you really don't need to set up any
kind of cluster in your local
environment and that is the best
environment I would suggest for most of
your development where your time reduce
there will be no software requirement
because sometimes version 2 version
changes
and you can get all the benefits of
clusters
so we're just waiting till the time the
cluster is getting ready so once the
cluster is ready you will be seeing some
options where
will help you to create the Clusters in
your upcoming demos
so friends your cluster is now ready
you can see now in this cluster you have
got this
environment so in this environment you
will see there are some options they
have given you one by one build up your
cluster create a first database user add
an IP address multiple options they're
telling you now so how to set up so the
first build of the cluster which we have
anyways done next is called create your
first database user will select this
so it will highlight this area now you
can say like database access
and I'm going to create a first new
database user and new database user
given the username for admin let's keep
very simple username and password admin
one two three so admin admin123 yeah
same and say add user
now you can see the user is created now
let's go back to the next option it's
telling me the network access now go
here and say sorry
now see add IP address
and I'll see allow access from anywhere
so that I can take it from anywhere I
say confirm
now it is telling me about the progress
I select this
tell me about which type of collections
you want
okay so I select this
and inside this I'll be selecting this
call collections
okay and uh it's getting
ready
so it is dealing with some options
well two options that will give you load
sample data set add my own data I'll say
add my own data give the database name
SL demo give the collection name EMP or
employee
remember database name SL demo or I can
better give the name called sldb
sldb and employee I say create
that is getting ready
okay so my database and table is ready
that's it so I think
we are all set
with this environment
okay well once it is ready your
collection is also ready I'll go back
and click on my
project zero
and here
yeah so once it is there then I'll be
clicking on this option called
connect
now it will give me the multiple options
how to connect so it will say correct
say the [ __ ] shell or it will say
connect to the application correct using
[ __ ] compass
I'll select
the python
python version 3.11 or later so
certainly I'll be using those version
only
okay and in this I'm having this
so I will be using this to connect with
my backend
so that's how exactly you have
the setup of mongodb cluster driven so
we are all ready now with our
setup
cluster we have already created earlier
you remember about we have taken python
3.11 or later so here if I just group I
can check I have a god
3.8.5 which is Python 3 version which is
available so you can select based on
whichever we have it let's see 3.11 or
later we can say three point
six or later so there'll be no much
difference if I just see even if I just
talk about 0.4 there is some change but
here 3.64 later it is same so I have a
3.8.5
Okay so
I can use the same option so here in my
vscore editor I am using for my
development so here's a simple demo.pi I
have used welcome to check if it is
working fine so yes it is working fine
I'll start working with my first program
with mongodb so I just go back and say
uh demo
py or I can say uh
p y
demo dot poi
okay and here if I want to go back and
start working on the development
remember one thing we need first
dependency called Pi [ __ ]
okay what I need Pi mang [ __ ] and for
this we have already installed this
dependency here sometime back this is
how you get installed
okay so we have this statement name
called what pip installed by momongo
that is the first dependency which you
need to download in order to work with
this
okay so that's what we have taken that's
installed by [ __ ] so if you just see
you can go back and start developing
this statement
okay so let's go back and start working
on this step number one you need to
always say import
number one the one dependence which
you've installed is called by [ __ ]
so as you can just say pymon go
that is the dependency we have recently
imported
from
okay let me go back and search from next
point so import buy [ __ ]
from
here we are saying Pi [ __ ]
okay Pi [ __ ]
and we're also saying import
ant
that's the first thing you need to
remember
okay after that we would like to go back
and use the cluster so we say cluster
equal to
[ __ ] client and here I'll be passing
the complete values the one which we
have taken
so this complete line
I just take it
go back
and here
I'm pasting it
now here I have to basically replace
this password with admin123
okay and we are all set
okay now
once it is ready we can go ahead and
Define DB equal to
cluster
and provide which database you're
talking about
okay so you remember about we had a
database which was available to us that
is known as call sldb so I can just use
the same sldp there and accordingly I
can use which collection I am correcting
it to so accordingly I can go back and
insert a record okay everybody so I can
see I have got this
file with me going forward I have to
tell see this is what exactly the
connection URL you've received now if
you define which database you're working
on let me say DP equal to
cluster and we have to provide n
double quotes the database name called
sltp if you remember we have used this
after that we have to mention which
collection it was so
collection
equal to DB and here we just give the
name call employee
proposable collection name
so once it is ready then I have to
basically perform some insert operation
so I just say post
okay it's just a name equal to and here
we just provide the properties
like I would say name so do you know it
is a Json based database so I can just
use the name I say
armor and once again you can just say
email
and
see
another email.com
that's it so this is just the data which
I have now I want to insert so I can
certainly say collection dot because I
want to insert only one record you can
see I have one functions coming up
collections.insert1 and plus
post
is in parameter now we are all done
let's try to run this
so I'll be running this with Python 3 by
mode demo Dot py
editor
no it's done let's confirm here into my
code I will just go back and check here
inside my
applications I can just go back to my
collections
and in employee
yeah there we go we have got some
records coming up here
okay so these records are nothing but
the one which we have recently inserted
in our application
okay so fantastic so first example is
working perfectly fine how we can have
the records coming from the python and
insert it there like that I can have as
many number of Records I can add it so
how we can basically add if I want to
add more than one records
let's see this now here in increase if I
want to add more than one records so I
can just use compost one if I copy this
URL and paste it below and I say post to
I say I'm a G and email I might want to
at the redmill.com and rather let's say
insert one I can use insert many and
inside this I'll be using this square
brackets and pass
post
post one or not
posture that's it
okay so let's change the little name
because it's already there let's insert
yep records are inserted let me verify
once again
by refreshing it
but now we have a total number of three
records are available
yeah there we go so regards are added
perfect so like this you can have as
many number of Records you can basically
add it in a similar one The Way We have
basically used this I can also perform
the search part too
okay so in case if you want to perform
the search part we have a very simple
statement available with us what I'll go
here
the way we have added this so in this
I'll just
these records which are added inside my
application I would not execute this
rather
I would like to go back and say
no they are basically commented now and
uh
in fact I would like to use this also
okay I'll go here and find results
equal to
same collection
dot find if I want to find a name we can
just use
curly braces
name
colon
number two
okay so let me say print
and parts
results
okay let's run this
okay so it will print what the results
for me
okay so it is just printing what the
cursor object for me saying like hey
this is what the record is available to
me we can also change in case if you do
not think the correct result is coming
up we can also go back and
we can use a alternative option that is
called for
okay so what we can do let's take a look
here
we can use for
which is for vacancy result
okay in
methods and print this result
that could be one option through which
you can get the details with you
okay so what you can do you can run this
code again
so I forgot about this semicolon here
or
printed check
well that was my
requirement was so I'm having this let's
try to run this
when I got my result and this is what
the detail which I have available to me
so very simple how you can basically
find a record on how you can basically
retrieve the records at the same time if
you want to have the specific field
rather than all the fields so here in my
code in this result
okay you can just put the square bracket
and tell which field you really want it
now suppose if you just want ID or else
if you want a name you can basically
pick that up
okay so if I just want that ID
like only ID is printed that's it
okay everyone so you have seen like in
my previous code how we were basically
trying to fetch all the records we were
using this fine now in a similar light
you can also have the option available
because see when we used to talk about
confine it gets me a lot many records
fine and because of that we were using
this Loop but in case if you want to
fetch the individual records
I'll be clear so in such cases you
really do not want to use file
you can just use find one so what you
can do is rather than using find I can
also use one more option called
find one and for which
I can come back just to note this all
yeah so here in this case rather than
using this file I can use file
underscore you can see this option
called find one
here we talk about
which are the properties you'd want to
skip and which are the properties you
want so I can just use this option
called underscore
idle
okay cool
zero okay I just removed this
underscore ID 0 and here I just print
what results
that's it let's run
foreign
so that will try to fetch some of the
records for you because if you do not
have that ID which you've overrated it
will certainly not found that depends on
what you would like to take so if I just
say
is having some issues but no problem but
you know it very well how it basically
takes
now in a similar line we would like to
also perform one more activity to talk
about delete so for which what I will do
is this I just want to uncomment it
foreign
s here so here I want to add the ID by
my own with name so we already have this
name
email I have it I would like to use
underscore ID
okay
so
we have this property underscore ID
colon
one zero one
okay
comma like this
copy the same
using it here
and this time
I'm using one zero two
name and everything
it will be taken let me say
user one
here we try to say it's user 2.
okay so collections dot many result five
one I'm just deleting it all
and let's try to execute it first
okay so it's executed going back
okay so I have some records with ID 101
and one zero two
now here
I just delete this and perform some
actions here here we say results
equal to
collection Dot
delete filler options are available
delete one and delete many it totally
depends on what you really want
okay so if I just talk about call delete
one it will be only deleting one record
delete many means where are the matching
records are available you delete it
fine so I'm just using this option
called delete many
okay wherever the property names are
much cause quite possible names
sometimes match or whatever it is first
did delete many so the option is up to
you now how you want so the selected
name you have to offer it
whether you want to match it with the
name or whether you want to match it
with the email or whatever it is so that
will be offering it but there's also one
option available where you would like to
delete everything
are we clear so if you're planning to
delete it everything what you can do you
can just leave it as a blank and try to
run this
so collection
dot delete underscore remaining
let's check
great all records are deleted
so as I've told you earlier also so
delete many means what it will delete
all the records whichever I present in
your code now
clear in a similar one if I want to
perform insert if you remember about we
have an option called what
insert menu and here
you would like to pass
post one
post Loop let's execute
so it'll add
the records inside this
okay and next time what I want to
perform after adding this record I would
like to perform the update part
okay so what I really wanted my update
let's take a look update means certain
properties I'm looking forward to pick
it updated
okay so in case if I want to check
whether record has to be updated about
first go and check
whether the record does exist or not
yeah we have two names user one and user
two let's go back and update bar
here
I just say collections
okay dot
update one
update you can see update one here very
simple functionality here you will go
and tell which ID would like to perform
an update so I say underscore ID
column
which side you want to consider I'm
saying 101
okay and what else so I just use another
curriculum basis and I say
sorry dollar
set
and after this
I use this colon use the curly braces
the name
okay and use whatever you want to use it
so suppose this is the user one I'm
saying use it one two three
okay let's see
it is loading and you can see the record
user123 is updated
perfect so
your code is absolutely working fine so
we talk about either insert you talk
about what update you talk about
anything it works so insert update 1
delete 1 insert one as the name suggests
they'd be taking care about inserting
operating and deleting one one records
but the moment you use many they'll be
performing multiple records so this is a
very simple way like how the python will
connect with your mongodb in this video
we're going to learn about the
differences between MySQL and mongodb
now I'm sure you must have heard about
these database Management systems but do
you exactly know what set them apart
don't worry I'll help you in this video
first let's look at what exactly is
mongodb
now as you all know mongodb is an open
source document oriented nosql database
it is document based which means that
the data stored is represented in a
hierarchical relationship using a single
record
and also mongodb is schema free which
means there's no set schema to Define
how the data is being stored in the
database this causes lesser data
migrations but what exactly is MySQL
then
now MySQL is an open source relational
database management system unlike
mongodb which is document oriented MySQL
is a relational database system now this
uses something called as a structured
query language and this is used to
access data which is stored in the form
of rows and columns now as mentioned
earlier data here is stored in the form
of tables with rows and columns and each
data field comes with an index
representing the data in the table
and SQL is developed and maintained by
Oracle
so then what exactly sets them apart so
in the coming section we look at some of
the differences between MySQL and
mongodb depending on certain features
first up is the data structure
now MySQL requires you to Define your
tables and columns before you can store
anything and every row in a table must
have the same columns
in mongodb you just drop the data in
these documents also the data and the
mongodb database is stored in a binary
format called as bson
next up we have schema now as discussed
earlier MySQL requires a set schema to
define the tables in the database now
the database administrator is requested
to define a schema which defines how the
different tables are being stored in the
database now this schema is crucial in
case of MySQL on the other hand mongodb
doesn't require a prior definition of a
schema
next up is languages
MySQL uses the structured query language
to perform actions on the database it is
used to retrieve data add data update
create a new data set Etc in case of
mongodb it supports a Json query
language to work with data next up is
foreign keys now MySQL supports the
usage of foreign Keys now if you don't
know what exactly a foreign key is then
SQL uses foreign keys to link one table
to another now these foreign Keys make
data retrieval easy especially when
there are multiple tables interlinked
with one another in case of mongodb
there's no support for foreign keys
next up is replication now MySQL
supports the Master Slave and the master
master application in this setup data
set from one master database server can
be copied to other servers
in case of mongodb
it uses something called as sharding now
sharding allows partitioning of data
across multiple servers using a Shard
key don't worry if you're not able to
understand these Concepts well in the
coming videos we'll explain these
Concepts in detail
next up is scalability now SQL database
can be scaled vertically while mongodb
can be scaled both vertically and
horizontally now horizontal scaling
means scaling by adding more machines to
your pool of resources while vertical
scaling refers to scaling by adding more
power like for example CPU or Ram moving
ahead let's look at performance now
MySQL is optimized for high performance
joins across multiple tables while
mongodb is optimized for write
performance
talking about Community Support some of
the popular GitHub repositories on MySQL
currently are MySQL JS MySQL and then
there's MySQL server and at the time of
writing there were about 222
000 repositories on GitHub with 7
million commits for MySQL in case of
mongodb a few popular GitHub
repositories are mongodb [ __ ] and
Doctrine mongodb and at the time of
writing there were about 177 000
repositories with about 923 000 comments
according to Google Trends MySQL is
largely used compared to mongodb
so now the question arises which one
should you choose
well if your application requires
multi-row transactions like for example
in accounting system then a relational
database would be more ideal
but if you're using mongodb then it is
more suitable for real-time analytics
content management Internet of Things
mobile applications and so on also MySQL
is a great choice if you have structured
data and need a traditional relational
database
in case of mongodb it is an ideal choice
if you have an unstructured set of data
so you could pick your choice and if
you're partial towards one dbms let us
know in the comment section below as to
why you like that particular dbms
node.js is a file JavaScript runtime
environment but it does not support
request handling functions HTTP methods
or serving files so express.js comes
into the picture Express makes the
node.js code easier as Express provides
a wide range of features to develop both
web and mobile applications it is used
to build single page multi-page and
hybrid page web applications as Express
is written in JavaScript it is very easy
to understand for the developers who
know JavaScript until now Express is the
most popular framework of node.js
you must have heard about mean stag in
web development right where e stands for
express.js
it is a back-end part of main stack it
manages routing HTTP methods sessions
error handling Etc
let's see what express.js is
express.js is a node.js framework
designed to build apis web applications
cross platform mobile apps quickly and
easily it is very high performance fast
lightweight and unopeniated that is
there is no structural way to write a
Code Express does not force you to write
a code in a fixed manner
express.js is used as a server-side
scripting language
let's see the need for express.js but
before that let me give you an example
if you have to write a rest API using
the core modules of node.js and the same
using the framework express.js you will
realize that with the help of express it
will take 5 to 10 times less code and
time
that was the reason behind creating
express.js framework for node.js
express.js is time efficient fast money
efficient very easy to learn and
asynchronous let's see the features of
express.js
for server-side development with the
features of node.js XP saves a lot of
time middleware middleware is a request
Handler that has access to the
application's request response cycle
routing this refers to how an
application's endpoints URLs respond to
client requests
templating
it provides templating engines to build
Dynamic content on the web pages by
creating HTML templates on the server
debugging Express makes it easier as it
identifies the exact part where bugs are
let's see the advantages of express.js
Express is unopeniated and we can
customize it and use it as per our needs
as it is written in JavaScript a single
language is used for front-end back-end
development
Express is fast to link it with
databases like MySQL mongodb Etc
let's see the disadvantages the
disadvantage of express.js is that there
is no structural way to organize things
sometimes the code becomes
non-understandable
there are so many issues with callbacks
the error messages that will come are
very challenging to understand
now we'll see the companies that are
using express.js the major companies are
IBM Uber eBay PayPal essential Fox
Sports Netflix LinkedIn as per the
nlib.com there are more than 34 300
companies that are using express.js
now I think you guys have a brief idea
about Express as it is a lightweight
framework that gives functionalities to
make node.js easy
express.js is trending so much because
it is helping so many developers to save
their time it is so awesome that most of
the companies are moving towards it
if you know JavaScript and node.js the
framework explains what you should know
to strengthen your coding skills
now here
you'll find downloads
you can download node from here
and install it but if you find any
difficulties downloading node.js you can
click on the link in the right corner to
see how to download node.js
now let's see the version for node to
verify here I am using visual studio
code you can go and search it and simply
download vs code
after opening your Visual Studio code
will look like this
here
you will find a terminal click on it
the terminal window will open
here we will write node
hyphen B
this will show us the latest version of
node.js
now we need to update the npm which is
node packet manager this bundle consists
of all the repositories and packages
required for development purposes to do
that npm install npm globally
NVM install
VM hyphen
globally
this will download all the npm packages
globally now let's create Express for
that first we need to create a separate
folder where we will keep all the
modules and files of express.js
let's claim this TLS
you can open the terminal by clicking on
the shortcut also by pressing Ctrl and
backtrack that will open the terminal
for you
let's make a folder mkdir
this is a command that is used to create
a folder on the terminal then we will
write our file name I will write Express
by
simply learn
enter
here you can see the file name expressed
by simply learn has been created
you can also click here
and enter your file name
m.js
press enter
as you can see a new file has been
created
now we need to install a package manager
that is npm
we will write a npm command open your
terminal again
write a command
npm
in it
enter
enter version enter description and
description you can write Express
tutorial
bye
simply on enter
repository if you have your git
repository you can add yours enter
enter author
relearn
license enter
press yes
after this
you can see npm created a Json file
now we will finally install express.js
we will write npm
install
Express
enter
now as you can see our Express is
installed in our system
let's open the app.js that we have
created earlier
now we will create a express application
with the help of Express functions that
we can do by requiring the express
modules let's create a first program
first
constant
Express
require
Express
in this line we are requiring the
express module
const
a name equals to function
Express
dot get
to get the file
request response
to get the request and the response
of the user
actually
we will need to pass callback function
here
let's write
response send
this message will be shown
in the server welcome
to
welcome to Simply learn
now here
we will write a port number where the
message will be shown to us add dot
lesson
4000 you can write anything
here also we are passing the Callback
function
and soul
DOT log in control log we will see the
message in the console
listening to Port
number
four thousand
close this line
save this
let's run it open your terminal new
terminal
now to run this file
we need to go to the express
folder
CD
Express
by simply learn
we are now in a simply learn folder
now the easiest way is to write the file
name write node
space the file name app.js
enter
now you can see it is printing our
message listening to Port 4000 now we
will see a message on the server
open your Chrome
type localhost 4000
press enter and here we go a message is
successfully displayed welcome to Simply
learn
get in post method are the standard HTTP
request used to create traced apis
get in post methods are used to send and
receive significant amount of data
the client sends a request in the form
of Json file and with the help of HTTP
requests which are get post and other
methods it will go to the server and
then the server sends back the response
to the client in the form of a message
to tell what happened to the request
that was sent to the server
now
Express G is get method
get is a method that is used to request
data from the server but mainly this
method is used to read data
to handle get request in Express is
pretty straightforward
get requests are to be cached and
remains in the browser history and
that's why the get method is not used
for sensitive data
to get the data we add parameters in the
URL and get data in response get method
is more efficient and popular than the
post method
now we'll see express.js post method
post method is used to create new or to
edit already existing data this method
is used to communicate with large amount
of data
the post method is secure because the
data is passed in a request body and not
visible in the URL and the user is not
able to bookmark it mostly we use get
method only but when we want to send a
sensitive data we use post method
now we will see how to get the post and
get methods work
now open your Visual Studio code
I have already installed node and
express if you haven't installed it then
you can click on the right corner of
this video to get the setup done
coming back to express get and post
methods
now what I have done here is I have
created a basic express.js app
const app require Express this will
install all our Express modules
now first we will write our gate method
so let's start
first we will write get method
then we will initialize how it will be
called well write get
this OS
create a consonant request parameters
requests and response
then we'll write the fat Arrow function
this
we will send a response
server
hello
this it is
full
get
request
let's I have not initialized the
brackets
let's see what I have not done oh
God to write this
now let's just save this file
we will run this file open your terminal
and write node
Dot
and
I think I have done something wrong
let's again open the Domino
right node
Dot so it is showing server is
successfully running on Port 4000.
now we'll open our Chrome and write
localhost
enter
as I have told you earlier this needs a
parameter so we'll initialize here
get request
hello this is successful get request
so a request method is working fine
now
we'll go back to the post method and see
how it Rose
app dot post
request
foreign
just like this only
just
post
hello
this is
full
post
first
he now will run save this first and then
run it in the terminal
yes node
it's already running out four thousand
we have to write this so first copy from
here only
open your terminal and here we can write
post request enter
so what you can see here is it can't get
post request
for this to see we need to have the
postman I'm using Postman here
I will write post method
and here I will write the
localhost 4000 and the post request
method then we'll press send
okay
head
in the body part
we will see hello this is successful
post request
how this is working is because post
method is secure and data is passed in
the request body and it cannot be
fetched in the URL
what is middleware middleware is a
request Handler that has access to the
applications request response cycle it
is a function that contains the request
subjects response object and the next
middleware function
middleware can also send the response to
the server before the request
the next middleware function is commonly
donated by the variable named next
simply middleware is a function that can
only be applied using routers with the
help of middleware we can access and
modify requests and response
now we will see what are the functions
of middleware
middleware can execute any code
it can make changes to the request
response objects
middleware can also end the request
response cycle
it can call the next middleware function
in the stack
we use these functions to modify our
middleware to perform many tasks like if
you want to block our site from some
country or if you want to check the
authentication of a user
Etc choose from over 300 in-demand
skills and get access to 1000 plus hours
of video content for free visit skillup
by simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
now we are going to create a simple
middleware
we can create a middleware in a router
file but the best way is to create a
middleware file separately and then use
it creating and using middleware is very
easy
now we first need to create a basic
express application but before that you
must have all the app packages to run
Express
you can take the help of our video what
is express.js the link will be in the
description
you need to install npm Express to run
this so coming back to our application
first we need
const
express application so we'll write
constant
Express
required
Express
so we'll write constant app
is equals to express
function
now to get the data we'll write app Dot
get
request
response
response
function
right response send
welcome to
simpler
now all we'll copy paste this
to get the home page the better way it's
too late
copy pasted
okay
here we'll write the extension of the
next page
home will say
and welcome to this villains
this is a very basic middleware
application we are going to create
list
home page
now we'll make it listen to some Port so
we'll write
add Dot listen
to Port will say report
four thousand
again that Arrow function
control
log
right listening
this message will be prompting to us on
the control determinant
so we'll close these brackets
foreign
open your terminal
first we need to go to this folder CD
Express
by
run
enter
now we'll write
file name
app called enter
so it's showing
listening to Port 4000
now we'll open our Chrome
local server
type localhost 4000 and
so it is successfully showing us welcome
to Simply learn now we'll go to the next
page we have written their home
enter
so it's successfully showing welcome to
Simply learns homepage
now
we'll create a middleware go back to
that file
we'll write
strength
required filter
request you can write anything here
request object
spawn subject
and next
in the fat Arrow function
the right
console log
okay
we have written request
we'll use this
by writing
app dot use
foreign
now
we haven't
called our next parameter in Express
framework next is a function
what we'll do is we'll call it in the
bottom of our middleware
we will write next
question
save this file
again we'll open a new terminal
where we'll go to the start folder
Express
by simply done
enter
like node the file name I have got here
enter
and now I'll open our file go to the
home
right localhost 4000 enter
where it is printing welcome to Simply
learn we'll go to the home page
slash
okay welcome to Simply learns homepage
with this we have successfully reached
the end of this video
npm which is called as node package
manager is node.js built in package
manager by default and express.js is a
framework of node.js which is fully
built in JavaScript
it was first made and available for use
in January 12 2010.
let's move on to what is npm
let's take async as an example and VM is
incredibly easy to use and all you need
to do is to type npm install async to
install the desired module in the
current directory under node module
folder you may use neat function on them
as they use build-ins once installed in
your node modules folder
the biggest software registry in the
world is npm there are more than 80 lakh
code packages in the registry to share
software open source developers utilize
npm npm is often used by businesses to
control private growth
all of the node.js packages and modules
are managed through npm which also
includes the npm command line client
along with the installation of node.js
it is added to the system npm is used to
install the necessary modules and
packages in the node project
moving ahead let's see what is a package
in node.js a package includes every file
required for a module
you can add module in a JavaScript
libraries to your project
now let's see the functions of node
package manager which is npm
online node.js packages modules
repositories can be searched on
node.js.org
use a command line tool to manage
node.js packages dependencies Version
Control and installation
now let's see how to install npm
to install node package manager we have
to install node.js for that you have to
download node.js and install it in your
system
now we will see the version of node.js
go to terminal new terminal
and search here
for
node hyphen V which is denoted as
version enter and this is my version of
node
now we will verify the npm version to do
that we have to run a command
write npm hyphen hyphen version
and you can clearly see my npm version
is 8.5.3
now we will see how we can install node
modules using npm this is a very simple
Syntax for that we just have to write
npm install and that module name
now we will install the famous web
framework module of node.js we will
simply write a command
npm
install
Express
this is a very simple command you can
write in your console or terminal and
then press enter
you can clearly see
the express is installed in our system
what is error handling
array handling is a process in which
express catches and processes the error
that occurs synchronously and
asynchronously
Express comes with its own default error
handlers simply in error handling the
tasks are to identify errors report them
to the users and then develop some
recovery strategies and Implement them
to handle the errors
this whole process should not slow the
overall processing time of the program
now
how does error handling Works in
express.js
express.js comes in with a built-in
error Handler this default error
handling middleware function is added at
the end of the middleware function stack
it automatically catches all errors in
router handlers and allow developers to
extend router handling functionalities
by middleware function error handling in
Express is done using middleware this
middleware is defined in the same way as
other middleware functions the error
handling functions have four arguments
error request response and next
we have next function method that
matches us to the next middleware
Handler in middleware
in error handling we have the next error
method this function skips all
middleware and matches us to the next
error Handler for the router now let's
set up our error and Link with Express
open your Visual Studio code choose from
over 300 in demand skills and get access
to 1000 plus hours of video content for
free visit skillup by simply learn click
on the link in the description to know
more first we will create a new
directory
for that
open your Domino
new terminal
let's try it
make directory
now I will enter the directory name I
will write
simply learn
or you can also write
error
press enter
you can see the errored and Link
directory has been created it's empty
let's go inside that CD
PDR handling
now we are in the middle link folder
now let's create a new project here
we'll write npm
in it
hash
by
so as you can see
the Json file has been created in the
error handling folder
now
we will install couple of packages here
okay
first we will install Express right npm
install
Express
now we will also install Morgan
which locks the request
uh after that we'll also install HTTP
errors
errors this package makes it very easy
to check the status code
and then last
we will install node dot EnV
press enter
this will take couple of seconds
now in the dependencies
you can see dot EnV Express HTTP errors
and Morgan
now I will create a file in this error
handling folder
right app dot JS enter
now let's install node bond which helps
us not to reset our file again and again
for that we'll write in that
npm
install
is minus sign save
Lord command
enter
this will also take couple of seconds
now
here you can see
the node one has been successfully
installed
now open your package.json file
here
in packet.json file
you can see here
this line
I will rewrite this
you can also remove it let's write
script
and in this
I will write
note mon
tab dot JS yes
save this file by pressing Ctrl s
yes
now open the file app.js
here we will be importing some packages
in node.js we use require function right
so we'll write const
Express
required
and
Express
here we need Express packages
now we will be needing Morgan
we will write const
ant
required
then
what are you doing
now like this we will need HTTP packages
const
error
create
error
required
history DB
editors
we also need dot EnV packages to import
our environment variables for that we
will simply write required
choir
tactic
Dot
EnV
Dot
and fake
for this command we need a EnV file we
will create a file
dot EMV
entor
and here we have our EnV file where we
can have our environment variables
first we want a port for this
application so we will write the port
good
three thousand
save this file
now again go back to the app.js file
here
first we will be initializing our app
we'll write cons
tab
Express function
now we will start the application for
this we will write
const
port
to which it will be called process
dot EMB Dot
port
3000
now we'll make our application listen to
Port 3000 we will write
tab Dot listen
port number
port
it will call the port number
and here
we will call the Callback function
header function
and here we will make a block statement
for this we'll write console
DOT log
vector
server
I mean
on
port
installer sign
and
hold
now let me start the application before
that we'll save this file
now to start the application we'll write
npm
start
enter
here it is showing error let's find out
okay
here
I have wrote script
here we need to write start
save this file
and now clear this screen
enter npm
so as you can see it is successfully
running in the port 3000 rest API are
the standard way to send and receive
data for web services
client sends a request which goes to the
rest API then to the database
to get or put the data after that it
will come back to the rest API and then
to the client
using an API is just like using a
website in a browser but instead
clicking on the buttons we write code to
request data from the server
it is very flexible and can handle
multiple types of requests
restful API is very popular and very
commonly used to create apis for
web-based applications
what is express.js
express.js is a node.js framework
designed to build apis web applications
and cross platform mobile applications
it is used as a server-side scripting
language
express.js is high performance fast
lightweight and unopeniated
we'll see what is rest API but before
that what is rest and what is API
rest means representational State
transfer rest is a popular architecture
which is used to create web services
Now API is a application programming
interface it is a code that allows two
software programs to communicate with
each other
rest API is a software that allows two
applications to communicate with each
other with the help of internet and
various devices now
we will see the HTTP request types first
one is get it is used to request data
from the server but mainly this method
is used to read data
next one is pack it is used to update
the data or to change or replace it next
is post
method is used to create new or to edit
already existing data
after that it is delete
delete method is used to delete the data
completely from the server
now we will see the complete
architecture of HTTP request type in
this client sends a request in the form
of Json file
and with the help of HTTP request which
are get patch post and delayed it will
go to the server
and then sends back the response to the
client in the form of message
to tell what happened to the request
and now we will create a simple restful
API from scratch
choose from over 300 in-demand skills
and get access to 1 000 Plus hours of
video content for free visit skillup by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
first you need to open your editor for
this I'm using vs code
for this
you need to open your folder
created one folder in the
C drive
foreign
you need to have node.js installed
first open your terminal by clicking on
Terminal New terminal
first we'll write npm
in it
hyphen White
press enter
this will create a Json file
for us
now let's install express.js
for that
will write in pm
install
Express
press enter
installing express.js
this will add
all the dependencies
for now we have only one Express
installed
we need a file here
to write our code
so we'll create a file called index
dot Js
enter
in this file we will write all our code
open index.js Js
first we'll write const app
where
Express
in this line we have imported the
Express package
which itself is a function
so we'll write parentheses here
to initialize it
now
we will write
foreign
this will call a variable
which is 4000
I will write app dot let's see
till now our API hasn't defined any
endpoints
this app Dot listen tells the server to
listen on specific Port which we have
defined already as a variable
4000.
now
in app Dot listen we will write a second
argument as call back to tell us the API
is working or not
then we'll write
port
comma
we'll write the Callback function here
function
come on soul
Dot log
text
it's
running
on http
closed
localhost
all this time
and
port
which will come under curly brightness
now we can run this app by writing the
command on a terminal
so save this file
terminal
now we'll write the command to run this
file
index node
file name index Dot
Js
so it's successfully showing us it's
running on HTTP port
four thousand
Oaks
Chrome or anything
I'm using Chrome here I'll write
localhost
4000
enter
closed enter
can't get
now
if you open this URL you will see
this message can't get this is because
we don't have any API endpoints as of
now
but express.js is still responsing with
error message
you can add an API and call it
every application consists of front-end
backend and the database together they
form full start and in this video we
will be talking about react and
express.js
react was created by meta and it is used
to make web application responsive
express.js is unoppediated and it is
used to make apis Express is maintained
by node.js
let's see what is react.js
react is a JavaScript library which is
used to build mobile and web
applications fast and Interactive it is
an open source reusable components based
front-end library of JavaScript
basically with the help of react we can
create a client-side application or user
interface
it is a combination of HTML and
JavaScript
let's see the features of react.js
first jsx
reduce Intex extension of JavaScript
with the help of react.js we can use the
extension to see how the UI should look
like
virtual document object model Dom it
defines how documentary exists and
manipulated in the web page
performance there are several ways to
speed up your regular act application by
using virtual Dom
one with data binding information Flows
In One Direction a react receive
information through arguments and pass
it by returning values
react goes beyond simple UI and has many
extensions for complete application
support extended with flux and Redux
among others
debugging it is a small browser
extension to make debugging easier and
faster let's see what is express.js
Express the node.js framework designed
to build apis web applications closed
platform mobile apps quickly and easily
it is very high performance past
lightweight and unopeniated express.js
is used as a server-side scripting
language
let's see the features of express.js
first fast server side development with
the features of node.js Express saves a
lot of time
middleware middleware is a request
Handler that has access to the
application request response cycle
routing
this refers to how an application's
endpoint URLs respond to client requests
templating
it provides templating engines to build
Dynamic content on the web pages by
creating HTML templates on the server
debugging Express makes it easier as it
identifies the exact part where bugs are
now we'll see how to connect client-side
to the server side first we need to
create a folder I have created a folder
named react Express
let's see
go to your save file
here I have created react Express folder
now we will be using a text editor in
this video I will be using visual studio
code let's open it
then we will add all the npm packages
and create a react application called
client
open Terminal
new terminal
let's write some command
npx
it
react
line
enter
this will take some time
until then just wait
yes so it's downloaded
now as you can see the client folder has
been created
with all the npm files
in this client folder you will see all
the npm files known modules
Json file also
yeah
now
we'll go to this folder
CD client
now to get this application running type
npm
start
enter
this command will start and compile this
application now it has opened a web page
localhost 3000
this is the first client-side
application startup page
this will be now working as a client
now let's create a backend application
for that first
clean this terminal
let's open a new terminal
type
npx
Express
engine
data
folder name
press enter
okay
now this will take some time to install
press yes why
as you can see a API folder has been
created
now we'll go to that API folder see the
API in the
now we are in the API folder
let's install
the packages in pm
install
press enter
this will again download all the
packages
so npm has installed all the packages
required to run this as you can see in
the packages.json file there are all the
repositories and files that I used
now let's terminate this terminal
terminal
now let's go to the client folder
CD
client
press enter
now we are in the client folder
npm
this command will start and compile this
application
now we'll see the standard express
application that has got installed we'll
again go to the terminal
delete this terminal
create a new terminal
and this will go to the API folder
npm start
let me start the terminal
press enter
now
will go to the Chrome
localhost 3000 very fresh
you will see the standard express
application that has got installed
for this typescript typestrip is an
object oriented programming language it
is a strongly typed superset of
JavaScript and all the code of
typescript is compiled with JavaScript
only
it is developed and maintained by
Microsoft
typescript was created to develop large
applications
it is mainly used to simplify the
JavaScript code so that it can be read
and debug easily
what is node J
no change is an open source cross
platform JavaScript runtime environment
and it runs on a web application outside
the client browser node.js is used by
the developers to build server-side web
application
notice is perfect for data intensive
applications since it uses an
asynchronous event driven model
what is X Plus Js
express.js is a node.js framework
designed to build apis web applications
cross-platform mobile apps quickly and
easily
XYZ is unopeniated
it is high performance fast lightweight
framework of node.js express.js makes
the node.js code easy as it is used as a
server-side scripting language
now we'll see how to set up node with
Express and typescript open your Visual
Studio code
new folder which I have created in the C
drive typescript
it's an empty folder I'll show you
open the terminal
I'll show you if it is empty LS
both folder is empty
now
we'll make a project inside it
will simply write npm
in it iPhone y for all the default
values
press enter
so you have seen the package.json file
has been installed in this package
it is clearance
now the first thing you need to install
is typescript type npm
at the end
to D
this will install the typescript
dependencies
now I will install two more dependencies
please write npm
I
this telephone node
I will also install nodemon
enter
this will install all the dependencies
there will be need in this project
let's clear the screen
now
now we have to install Express
npm
install Express
let's wait for a couple of seconds the
npm express has been created
open the package or Json file here you
see
all the dev dependencies
Express
Norman and TS node
has been successfully installed
now we need to create a project inside
this folder for that we need to write
npx
see it okay hyphen in it
wait for a couple of seconds here we go
here the screen
now we'll execute npx
ESC hyphen
and it
so it has already been here
you can see
yeah
now we will be creating a source folder
for that
right mkdir
C
enter this would be containing all our
typescript files here
you can see it's empty
let's create a file here
Dot
everything we will going to write is
inside this file only
so your setup for typescript will
Express in node is ready
you can write anything here
the first thing you need is node.js
let's see I have created one for me you
can create it by just entering a command
make directory in the terminal
and entering your folder name it can be
ABC or something you need and like this
it will be created but I don't need it
so I'm going to delete it
and this
I will open the terminal again
I'll write a command
npm
in it
what
this will create a Json file for us
like as you can see here
the Json file has been created here
clear the screen
now we will install express.js in this
folder for that write a command npm
install
Express
and press enter this will install
express.js for us
you can also see here in the
dependencies
Express has been successfully installed
and all the other modules are here
so let's clear this screen now
now we will create a server file here
let's name it app.js
here we'll write all our code
so let's create a simple Express folder
right
const
Express
require
keyword
all over
modules will be here
in this we are requiring express.js
now we will also be meeting
quote
processes
dot EnV
dot old number that we'll gonna write
here
I'm using port number 3000 you can write
anything
this will be a code number now
create an app
Express function
you have created an instance for express
now we'll create
to make it listen to our code
let's write app Dot listen
port number it will read by its own
a data function
foreign
but we are gonna see batik
server
started at http
localhost
dollar sign
to get the data of the port
and we'll write the code it will fetch
the number of the port
here it goes
now we have created a front end of this
I repeat now we will create a front end
of this registration form so let's
create it
first here
create a folder
public
in this folder
let's create two files index
dot HTML
and
uh
second one will name as style.css
now in the index folder
we'll write all our front-end code so
open
index.html page
right dog and enter this will create a
HTML template for you
in the title
yes
will write
registration
form
now in the body part
will write
heading for this
H1
right heading we'll just
get here the action will be class
distribution
heading so we can style it afterwards
heading
now we'll create a form
function
okay
glass will be formed
now we'll create an input types first
we'll create input type will be
text
to write first name
same
this folder
this username will become inside the
text box this first name
[Music]
now we'll create few more like this for
password
last name age number
let's copy this input
[Music]
first one will be first name second one
will be
last name
so we'll write the email
for this
this look good
it will write that email
will write password
placeholder
will write
it will be empty so no one will see our
password this will be an empty
let's start it here
and we'll write
in the placeholder password
let's go to another one
and let's create a first name last name
email password and let's create one more
that will be a
h
for this we have to write here
number
and then if you don't need name I guess
let's write this here
page
it is folder what will you see inside
the box in the front end
let's create a submit button
type of the button will this submit
so we can
give its time in
spired
[Music]
summary
so our form is ready
uh yeah
we'll write require here so
one will be left empty
this will help us to
to require every field because
everything is important
we cannot make it empty so we are
writing required
so
our HTML page is ready
here let's see how it looks on this HTML
page
yeah
a registration form look like this
let me show you what require is doing
as you can see please fill out this
field this is what required function do
submit
is
now coming back to vs code
will write some CSS code for styling
here we will write
padding for the page
will be zero
we don't have to write percent
margin
will also write 0 for the overall page
now we'll go to the
body part
so the
height will be 100
pH
weight will be
100 BH
this place I will be
legs
in the direction of the flex will be
bottom
but
then just if I content will be in Center
alignment
items enter
this is how we will
write a body part
coming to the
form of the speech
from
right
everything will be a single copy this
paste it here
I don't want the height of the form this
much
it could be that let's create a 40.
40 percent
width will be 100 only
this place legs will be here
direction or this will be column only
justify contents
let's see in the
drawer code
let's make it not Center
let's make it as
this let's make it space between
you can style it as your own
as you want
heading
this play will be in line block
foreign
Page look
more clean
perform
okay
input
foreign
[Music]
and put it okay
now we'll go to
let's do something with the button
button
it will be
nice
padding will be
10 percent from this
and 25
the other side
yes
so
let's say the color for this
e
ffort
color will look like this
it's not an issue
is in
the summit button
uh
the Border
box
this will look cool
brown color
of the summit button will be flat
and the text which is inside it will be
White
so it looks clean as a
registration form
oh
it's done
you can also
save this file go to the file
a registration form looked like this
isn't it cool uh let's make this a
little up
The Heading part will
the operating for 40 smooth
students
here this is cloud go to the form and
see yeah it looks good now
let's see everything is working fine
yeah
coming back to our vs code
now
so our front part is ready if there will
be any changes we'll do it later now
coming back to our backend part
of the registration form we'll make our
first API routes
here
that's right
dot get
on
request
response
data function
let's write here the response that the
form will send
we will write the directory name
of this HTML file
it's right here
third premium
because
public
x dot HTML
save it
coming back to our
68 post method also here
foreign
post
and response
foreign
here in this part it will face the data
in the body of the HTML page
now
let's create an API middleware
that
to use
Trace dot Json
computation here we are accepting the
data in Json format
after this we will use it again
I've got use
Express
dot URL encoded
function
this is basically to decode the data
sent through HTML form
dot again
this will Express
dot we will write static
charting function will be public folder
public
this will use the public folder for us
now
we'll save this file first
open your HTML file
and write in the form part
itions
here
[Music]
will declare the file name app.js
com
class form
and we'll write method which will be
post here
everything looks
good we forgot to write inverted commas
here
save this file
now open the terminal
and write node
app dot Js
press enter
so our code is running fine let's open
it
yeah
everything looks fine
let's go ahead and begin with what is
react react as a JavaScript library used
to build fast and interactive user
interfaces for both web and mobile
applications now one thing that makes
react extremely powerful is the fact
that it's open source any user can
access its source code modify it and
enhance it in a typical model view
controller architecture react defines
the view part of the application it is
also responsible for how the app looks
and feels fun fact react was built by
Jordan walkie an engineer at Facebook
now let's go ahead and see how react
Works in real time consider a typical
web application say Instagram the entire
UI of the web page is divided into
several components we have the search
component a profile description
component stories component and a post
list component these components make the
code easier to debug and always remain
discrete components also make
development and maintenance of web
applications faster as multiple
developers can work simultaneously on
different components of the same web app
education now let's see why react is so
popular these days the ACT helps in
creation of dynamic web applications it
also provides performance enhancements
now there are several performance
enhancements like virtual Dom and
one-way data binding we'll learn about
these topics a little later in the video
react uses reusable components now this
helps decrease the development time
react involves unidirectional flow of
data react also has a small learning
curve compared to other Frameworks like
angular react is much easier to learn
react can also be used for mobile
applications react recently released an
extension called react native that is
used for developing mobile applications
that are cross-compatible it also has
dedicated tools for easy debugging now
let's dive in to the features of react
first let's understand jsx jsx is a
syntax extension to JavaScript using jsx
we can add HTML to the Javascript file
all coding in react is done using jsx it
also helps in making the the code easier
to understand and debug ultimately jsx
is a combination of JavaScript and HTML
now let's consider a small example cons
simple here is a JavaScript notation H1
tags indicate HTML again the semicolon
indicates JavaScript note that the
semicolon is not mandatory however it's
a good practice to include it moving on
the next feature is virtual dom dom dom
which is an acronym for data object
model actually defines how documents are
accessed and manipulated in a web page
it represents the entire structure of
the web page in the form of a tree
now let's see how this actually works
react creates a virtual Dom that is the
exact copy of the real Dom traditionally
whenever something changes in the web
application all objects in the real Dom
are updated this makes it extremely slow
let's see how react counters this now
consider two objects whose states have
been changed react now compares the
virtual Dom with the virtual Dom
snapshot that was taken right before the
update by comparing the new virtual Dom
with the pre-update version react
figures out exactly which virtual Dom
objects have changed now react only
updates those objects on the virtual Dom
this makes a big difference when it
comes to speed coming to the next
feature performance react uses virtual
Dom as discussed earlier virtual Dom
impacts the speed of the web
applications we also took an example of
Instagram and learned how multiple
components can affect the development
time they help improve performance
drastically the next feature is one-way
data binding this this means information
Flows In Only One Direction One Way data
binding is specifically used when
information is displayed and not updated
remember that the components of react
are functional in nature that is they
receive information through arguments
and pass information via their return
values the next important feature is
extensions react has many extensions
that we can use to create full-fledged
front-end applications it provides
server-side rendering which means that
the application is rendered on the
server rather than in the browser react
native which is a react extension is
used for developing mobile applications
there are many other extensions that
react provides for every scenario in web
development now let's look at a few of
them react native lets you build mobile
applications using only JavaScript a
react native app is a real mobile
application and not just a web
application running on your mobile
devices thousands of applications like
Facebook Instagram Pinterest Skype use
react native the next popular react
extension is flux flux is the
application architecture that Facebook
uses flux implements a unidirectional
flow which makes it easier to understand
what actually is going on now let's see
how it works when we trigger an action
the dispatcher will get notified the
dispatcher receives actions and
dispatches them to the stores a store is
what holds the data of an application
stores will register with the
application's dispatcher so that they
can receive actions data from stores is
displayed in views actions define the
internal API of your application they
capture how anything might interact with
your application the last feature of
react is debugging react applications
are easy to debug thanks to the large
and active developer Community you can
practically debug react calls within
your browser now notice the small react
extension icon at the top right corner
this developer tool allows the user to
inspect the code and also easily debug
it moving on let's learn about the
building blocks of react components
state date and props are the essential
Concepts that one should know before
implementing react they are the
foundation on which react is built now
what exactly are react components
components are the building blocks of
any react application react divides the
user interface into multiple components
wherein each component defines how a
particular element is viewed in the
application react components remain
discrete and are processed independently
another feature is reusability
components can be reused multiple times
across the application this reduces the
development time consider the following
code snippet a component is implemented
as a JavaScript class having some State
and a render method state is the data
which we want the component to render
the render method is responsible for how
the UI looks and feels to the user the
next concept is state state of a
component is an object that holds some
data this data influences the output of
a component every time the state of an
object changes the component is
re-rendered onto the screen now let's
see what props are props are short for
properties allow us to pass arguments or
data to components properties help make
confidence more Dynamic it is important
to Define all the properties their types
and their default value props are passed
to components in a way similar to that
of HTML tag attributes now consider the
following code Snippets this shows
exactly how properties are passed to
components also detailed illustrations
on components props and state will be
shown in the upcoming videos so stay
tuned for that moving on let's go
through some of the things that you
should know before you can actually
start working on react you should be
familiar with programming Concepts like
functions objects arrays and classes one
should also have a basic knowledge of
JavaScript and a familiarity with HTML
don't worry if you feel like you're not
good at them once you start working on
them you'll get a good hang of it
finally let's go through the impact of
react on the I.T industry and get
insights into the salaries of react
developers statistics show that react
developers earn way more than other web
developers according to pay scale the
average salary for a react developer in
the United States is a whopping 91 000
US Dollars the average salary for a
react developer in India is 7.25 lakhs
per annum over the recent years react
has gained immense popularity and is
being adopted by many companies
according to the data by Google Trends
riyak has had a better growth scale
compared to other Frameworks like
angular and view statistics show that
front-end developers have wholeheartedly
adopted this lightweight framework
foregoing other available options if you
are scared and have a knack for
front-end development react can help you
gain fantastic career opportunities
lastly talking about a few companies
that use react emotionally we have
Facebook Instagram Netflix Dropbox
WhatsApp among others in today's video
we'll be learning all about react
insulation on windows so without further
Ado let's get started to set up the
react development environment we need
two things installed node and the text
editor of your choice so let's begin by
installing node.js we can head to the
official node.js website save download
node.js so here you can see the windows
installer depending on your system you
can either download the 32-bit version
or the 64-bit version so I'm going to go
ahead and click on the 64-bit version
since it's already installed on my
system I'm not again installing node you
can follow the installation guidelines
and download it once you're done with
node installation you can go ahead and
download a text editor of your choice so
I'd suggest vs code so let's head to the
vs code page say download PS code click
on the first link and download the
64-bit version for Windows once you're
done with the installation of both node
and your text editor you can start
creating your first react application so
for that let's create a folder I'm
creating it on my desktop while you can
create it in any of your drives let's
call it first react now open your
command prompt now you can type in the
path for the folder that you just
created so say CD
users
first react now go ahead and type in the
command npm install
hyphen G create react app okay so this
command installs all the necessary
react.js modules now to check if the
version is correctly installed you can
type in create
react app version so you can see the
version here now let's continue and
develop your react application type in
the command create react app
and you can give a name to your
application so I say my app now this
should take a couple of minutes okay
once you've successfully created our
application they say to begin by typing
the following commands so let's do that
c CD my app and npm start this should
typically start your application and
here we go all right you can also open
your application in the text editor that
you've downloaded so let's go ahead and
open vs code vs code file open folder go
to your desktop or the drive that you've
saved your folder in first react my app
and I say select folder so as you can
see all your modules have been imported
you can click on app.js and start
editing in today's video we'll be
learning all about the most basic
infrastructure of react.js or components
without delay let's begin and look at
what's in store for us so we'll be
touching on topics like what are
components types of components nesting
components higher order and pure
components and a brief description about
component life cycle all right to begin
with what exactly are components
components are the building blocks of a
react application wherein each component
represents a part of the user interface
now to make it more understandable
consider the Facebook home page the
entire UI can be broken down into
several elements say we have the
credentials component the sign up
component the image component and the
logo component notice that each
component adds something to how the home
page looks alright reusability is one of
the saline features of react components
one component can be reused several
times across the application and this
improves the development speed
components can also be nested one
component can internally consist of
several other components in its minimal
form a component must Define a render
method that specifies how exactly the
application looks and feels a component
can also receive properties from its
parent components also you'll get a
better understanding of all of these
when we start working Hands-On so don't
worry so moving on let's look at the
different types of components first we
have the stateless functional components
and then we have the stateful class
components now functional components are
typical JavaScript functions that return
HTML now they can be contained in a DOT
JS or a DOT jsx file coming to class
components these are regular ESX classes
however it's mandatory that they contain
a render method that in turn returns
HTML they can also be contained in dot
JX or a DOT jsx file okay then let's go
ahead and build our first react
application using components all right
so I've opened my text editor that is vs
code to build my application Also I
suggest you watch the react installation
on Windows video to help you get started
the video briefly explains how to
install node and how to start building
your first react application in my case
I've opened a folder called react
component tutorial and here in my source
folder I have app.js now app.js is the
main component that gets rendered to the
Dom let me show you that here in
index.js you pass app.js which is a
component that gets rendered to the
reactor so app.js consists of several
other components that can be nested so
as you can see app.js is a functional
component and before moving on let me
get rid of all the unnecessary code so
let me delete all of this
and return
an H1 tag that says hello welcome to
Sibley let me save it and if you look at
the browser you'll have hello welcome to
Centrelink now let's go ahead and
display another message say H1 this
video is about components let me save it
and let me check the browser it gives
you an error so jsx uses a conventional
rule which states that all HTML tags
have to be enclosed within a div tag so
for example I say div and I enclose it
so let me save and check my browser
again here you go so multiple HTML tags
have to be enclosed within the div tag
moving on let's create a first
functional component to do that I'll
first create a folder in my source
folder say components within that I'll
create a file say functional component
dot JS all right so the first thing we
have to do is import react so I say
import react from yeah the general
Syntax for a functional component
involves the keyword function and say
functional component now you say return
an H1 tag or I've already used H1 tags
so I'll say paragraph I say this is a
functional component all right before
explaining to you how these components
are exported and imported let me show
you the general Syntax for a class
component so I create another file say
class component dot JS I again import
react from react the general notation is
using the class keyword followed by the
name of the class extending from the
base class react.component so going
ahead I say class class component
extends react dot component now the key
feature of a class component is the
usage of a render method so I say render
within braces I say return a paragraph
tag saying this is the class component
or
so moving on let's see how these
components can be nested into the main
component that is app.js components can
be nested into the main component using
Import and Export keywords so as the
name suggests export feature is used to
export a particular file or a module and
import is used to import a particular
file or module into the current existing
module so we have two different types of
exports you have default export and just
export or named export so a default
export is used to export just one object
be it a function a class a variable from
the file and there can only be one
default export per file and when you're
importing it you can specify the address
and use the word import before it so let
me show you how it works let's go back
to our editor and then functional
component and here I say export default
and the name of the functional component
that is functional com so let me save
this and going back to my app.js I say
import name of the functional component
that is functional com from and I pass
the path this components slash
functional component also let me get rid
of these unnecessary files here now
let's define functional component in our
app.js component so here I say
functional comp let's compile it and
check our browser here it says this is a
functional component moving on to my
class component it's the same syntax
here as well let's say export default
name of my component and in my app.js I
import it import class comp From the
Path and again I'll have to Define it in
my return method I save so let me
compile it and check my browser it says
this is the class component one unique
feature of default export is that I can
rename the file while I'm importing it
so for example I can rename it as say FC
and while I'm defining it I'll have to
make sure I use the same naming
conventions so I say FC again and when I
check it it says this is the functional
component there is literally no
difference the next type of export is
the named export or just export so a
named export can be used to export
multiple objects be it functions class
Etc from a file now there can be several
named exports from a single file one
hack is that while you're importing it
cannot be renamed so let me show you how
this works okay so let's create another
class in our class component so I'll
just copy paste this let me give it
another name say class comp 1 and then
message that I want to display is hey
I'm another class all right so when I'm
exporting it I don't want default so let
me take it off and say export here all
right in my app.js while importing it I
want to import both the classes so I'll
include them within curly braces here I
say class com comma class comp one and
then again I Define it here class comp
one let's compile it and run it and here
we go here you can see hey I'm another
class so we've successfully exported
both the classes from the class
component and imported it back in our
app.js component one advantage of using
named export is the fact that I can
choose to import the classes that I want
to now say for example I do not want to
import class component here so let me
take it off and here let me comment us
now let's compile and see hey I'm
another class the second class got
imported while the first class I was
defined earlier is not imported here all
right so next up we have higher order
and pure competence now I won't get into
the nitty gritties of it because they're
Advanced topics but to give you a brief
Insight higher order components are
basically functions that take in a
component and return a new component the
whole ideology behind higher order
components is to facilitate the
reusability of component logic okay so
let's see how this works let's go back
to our code editor let's create a
component in our components folder let's
call the component
click dot JS all right so here we define
a class I use this snippet rce here we
go we get the entire format using the
small snippet rce and here I'm going to
make use of a button now see I use the
tab button and I'll say clicked one time
every time the user clicks on the button
the value gets incremented so for this
I'm going to use a variable say count
and I'm going to use the concept of
States so let's go ahead and Define our
variable count and initialize it to zero
so for that I'm going to use another
snippet called R const and here this dot
State equals my variable count
initializing it to 0. so let's define
the count variable in a render method so
I say const count equals this dot state
so every time we click on the button the
count value has to get incremented right
so we make use of an event called on
click closed captioning not available
[Music]
state DOT count plus one okay and here
we say count times all right so once
this is done let's import our component
in app.js so here again I say import
click from components here and let's
define it here so let's check our
browser every time we click on the
button the value gets incremented all
right so let's go ahead and create
another component say counter.js wherein
every time the user hovers the mouse on
the button the count value increases so
let's go ahead and do that I say
counter dot JS I'm again going to use
the snippet rce to create a class
component and here in my div tag I
Define a button and say incremented to
for now I say x so now let's go ahead
and add the event save button on Mouse
enter I'm gonna call the method this dot
increment count okay so once you're done
with that let's go ahead and Define the
increment count method I'm going to copy
the same code that I've mentioned in my
click.js so I say copy this all right so
one changes that I'll change the name of
the method and call it increment count
again let's define the count in our
render method so I say const count
equals this dot State and here I change
X to count now let's go ahead and import
it in our app.js so I say import counter
from
components and counter and let's define
it here all right let's save it and
let's run the code okay so as you can
see you see another button here
incremented to zero and every time I
move my cursor on the button it
increments mind you I'm not clicking I'm
just hovering my mouse okay to learn how
higher order components work we'll have
to pass counter.js and click.js as
parameters to give birth to an entire
new component so for that let's go ahead
and create another component for our SOC
let's call it higher order dot JS okay
so I say import react from react after
that I say const updated component
equals original component that's going
to be an arrow function again and within
curly braces I Define my class that is
class say new component extends react
dot component inside let's define find a
render method that Returns the original
component with a modification that is I
want to type the user I want to append
the user before the actual message is
displayed all right so let's go ahead
and close the tag and return new
component and let's export this say
export default updated component now we
import higher order.js in our counter.js
and click.js and pass these components
as parameters so let's do that let's go
to our counter.js and here I say import
updated component from dot slash higher
order component and here while exporting
I say updated com and pass this as my
parameter let's do the same to click.js
here I import data.com from higher order
component and here I pass this as a
parameter now here in a higher order
component we've defined a property name
and initialized it to the user so we'll
have to include this in our other
components that's counter and click so
let's do that and here right before
incremented 2 I say this dot props dot
knee let me save it let me do the same
thing here and save this dot props dot
name so if you go back to our browser
here you can see it says the user
clicked zero times and the user
incremented to zero okay so this
basically shows how react Implements
reusability of components moving on our
next topic is pure components now
another way to create class component is
by extending pure component from react
pure component avoids unnecessary
re-renders now how does it do it it does
not implement the should component
update method now you learn about this
method a little later in the video now
this method enables re-rendering of
components to the Dom but if you are
component on the other hand ensures a
shallow comparison of states and props
and checks if a re-render is actually
necessary only then does it render to
the Dom a react component can be
considered pure if it renders the same
output for the same state and props so
let's take an example to explain pure
components so let's go back to our vs
code and create two component classes
one for a regular component and the
other for a pure component I am using
this example I'll show you exactly how
pure component is more helpful okay so
let's create a pure component.js file I
say pure com
dot JS so here I'm going to use a
snippet rpce that is going to create a
pure component class let me get rid of
this export and here in my div tag I'll
display the text say I'm the pure
component all right now let's go ahead
and create a regular component I may
call it
reload of component.js and here I'm
going to use the snippet rce and the
message that I want to display is I'm
the regular component so to draw a
comparison between the regular component
and the pr component let's create a
parent component for the two so let me
create one here I'll call it parent
component.js and this is again going to
be a regular class component and here I
display the message I am the parent
component to change the state of the
component we're going to make use of a
Constructor so let's use the snippet or
const and here let me create
name you can give anything and I say
simply learn now we make use of the
component did Mount lifecycle method to
set a time interval now don't worry
about this we're going to learn about it
a little later in the video so moving
ahead I'm going to make use of the
method and say component did Mount and
here I say set interval the first
argument is going to be an arrow
function and the second will be the time
interval and I'm going to be setting it
to 3 seconds now within the arrow
function I'll make use of the set State
function to set the state of my property
however I do not change the name I keep
it simply on itself moving on let's
import pure component and the regular
component into our parent component and
then pass name as a property so to do
that first import pure com from Pure
component and then I say import regular
com from regular com.js and here let's
say regular com name equals this dot
state DOT name and I say pure component
name equals this dot state DOT me now
let's include the property name in both
our regular and pure confidence so to do
that let's just save this Dot drop dot
name and here I again say this dot prop
dot name and finally let's import parent
component into our app.js component so
here I say import parent come from okay
and here let me Define parent.com
so now if you look at the browser we
have I'm the parent I am regular
component simply learn and I'm the pure
component simply gone we've got the
result as expected now to check if the
pure compound is actually re-rendering
or not let's include simple console.log
statements so here I say CLG snippet and
here I say
your component render and in my regular
component I do the same thing I say
console.log regular component
render now let's do the same in our
parent component as well here I'd say
parent
component render all right so let's go
back to our browser and inspect it in
our console first the parent component
gets rendered then the regular component
and then the pure component after that
for every three seconds only the parent
component and the regular component is
rendered for the same state and prop the
pure component is not re-rendered so in
conclusion pure components optimize
react codes and also improves
performance so coming to the last topic
component life cycle so basically
component life cycle explains the stages
the component goes through the entire
life cycle of a component can be divided
into three parts we have mounting
updation and unmounting so the first
thing that gets invoked in the life
cycle is component will mount it is
invoked right before the initial
rendering occurs then we have the
rendering method now once a component is
inserted into the Dom component did
Mount gets involved coming to the next
phase we have updation when a complaint
receives props component will receive
props gets invoked set state is called
when the state of the property changes
so every time there is a change react
decides whether the next component State
Should trigger a re-render or not to do
that should component update method is
called component will update is invoked
right before re-rendering after
re-rendering component did update is
called that makes updates to the Dom and
the last phase is unmounted component
will unmount method does all the
necessary cleanup and erases all the
allocated memory and Cycles
in our previous video we learned about
react.js components in detail and now
moving ahead let's learn about another
striking feature of react.js called
props props short for properties allow
the user to pass arguments or data to
components a pairing component can pass
additional information to its children
using props properties help make
components more Dynamic props are passed
to components in the ways similar to
that of HTML track attributes now we'll
look at this a little later in the video
props in a component are read only and
cannot be changed one thing to remember
is that props are sent by the parent to
the children components hence the
children components cannot make any
changes to these props now that we've
learned about props in brief let's go
ahead and create our application using
props if you're new to this tutorial I
suggest you go to the react installation
and react competence video on our
channel so back in my code editor that
is vs code I've opened a folder called
react props and now I'm going to create
a component a class component and I'll
call it class drops dot JS so let's
create the class component I give rce
the snippet and here I display a message
saying an H1 tag basically
[Music]
all right
now let me get rid of export here and
import it in my app.js main component
here I say import
class props
all right now we Define the class
component in a render method
[Music]
all right
now if we go back to the browser you see
Hello Learners welcome to Simply
learning now let's say we want to
individually welcome every student
instead of retyping the message for
everybody we can pass their names as
props now let's see how to do that now
we pass the name as a property from the
main component that is apt.js to the
child component and render this onto the
browser so let's do that so here while
I'm defining my child component I say
name
I save it and here in my child component
instead of learners
I say I use a keyword this
dot crops dot name
let me save it and if you look at the
browser we'll have hello learner1
welcome to Simply learn now let's go
ahead and welcome learner 2 and learner3
so I again say class props name equals
learner 2.
all right so if we save and look at the
browser we'll have all the three
Learners displayed on the browser we can
also pass multiple props to the child
component now say for example we want to
welcome the student from a particular
place so we say welcome learner1 from
Place X so I can hear Define another
property say place
[Music]
and say place
similarly I can do it for the rest too
say Place y
now let's go back to our class props.js
component and here say hello learner one
from this dot props dot place
let me save it and if you look at the
browser now we have hello learner one
from Place X Place Y and play Z we can
also display whatever we want between
the opening and closing tags when
invoking a component now this is
facilitated using props.children
reserved keyword now let me explain to
you how it's done with an example here
let's split the self and closing tag
into
an opening and a closing tag and in
between them let me display a message
within the paragraph tag let me say
and in my child component after my H1
tag
let me use a paragraph tag and here
let's use the reserved keyword this dot
props top children
so let's save it
and now if you look at the browser you
can here see the message displayed child
component so prop stop children can be
used when components do not know about
their children ahead of time this is
commonly seen in components like sidebar
and dialog that represent generic boxes
so let's go ahead and create a button
tag and check again
so here I'll split it and add a button
tag
and say click
and let's check our browser
here we go we get the output as expected
all right we saw the usage of props for
class components similarly we can use it
for functional components so let's go
ahead and create a functional component
let me call it
I say import react from react
and then I say function
function props
and here I return an H3 tag
I'll say this is functional component
[Music]
and I'll return another H3 tag saying
hello learner
so let me save this
and let's export it export default
function props
and import it in our app.js again import
function problem
[Music]
function problem
and here in our render method let's
define it
let me call function prop
name
let me give learner 4.
and
place
say a
so let me close it and back in our
functional component instead of learner
I save
props dot name
let me save it now if you look at our
browser it gives us an error it says
props is not defined so let's go back to
our code editor and pass props here
to a functional component also let me
Define hello frop start name
from
props dot place
let me enclose it within the div tag
here
[Music]
let me save it and now if you look at a
browser here we go we get the output as
expected
so let's begin and learn what exactly is
a state in react typically a state is an
object that stores the values of
properties belonging to a component now
these values can change over a period of
time either via user interactions or
network changes and the state helps
facilitate this functionality every time
the state changes react re-renders the
component to the browser the state is
initialized in the Constructor a state
can also store multiple properties a
method called set state is used to
update the value of the state object now
this function performs a shallow merge
on the new and the previous state
conventionally a shallow merge ensures
that the previous state values are
overwritten by the new state values
moving on in our previous video we
learned about props and although props
and state dictate and control the
behavior of a component they have
significant differences so let's go
ahead and draw a comparison between the
two firstly props in a component are
used to pass data and event handlers to
its children while State on the other
hand is used to store the data that has
to be rendered on the web page props are
immutable once said by the parent they
cannot be changed State holds volatile
data and can be changed over time props
can be used in functional and class
components while state is restricted to
class components props are set by the
parent component while a state is
generally updated by event handlers now
that we've learned all about State let's
go ahead and build an application to see
the working of State alright so in my
code editor that is vs code I've created
my application say State and here in my
source folder I have my app.js file now
here I'm going to get rid of all the
unnecessary code that I'm not going to
be using Also I suggest you go through
the react installation on Windows video
to help you get started with creating
your first application so let's create
our class component say class app
extends react top component inside I
have a random method that returns an
HTML tag let's display a message welcome
let's follow the jsx conventions and
enclose all the HTML tags within the div
tag so I say div
class name equals app we also have to
import the app.css file import
app.css and so we save it and if you
look at the browser we have welcome now
let's beautify our code to do that let's
add some styling so here in my app.js
class component I say Styles equals and
I say font style and I set it to say
bold and I say color save till and here
in my H1 tag I say style equals this dot
Styles so let me save it and if you look
at the browser now we have welcome in
teal and it's bold now let's go ahead
and create a class component to
understand state so first I create a
folder and I call it components and
inside this folder I create a class
component and I call it newcomp dot JS
and I use the snippet rce to create the
class component to give you an insight
into what we're doing today we'll
display a message asking the user to
subscribe to Simply on once the user
clicks on the Subscribe button we
instruct them to click on the Bell icon
and finally we display a thank you
message now to do all of this we're
going to make use of state and as
mentioned earlier we initialize the
state object in a Constructor so let's
use the snippet R const to create a
Constructor now in the state object we
initialize a property let's call it
message and we display a message saying
subscribe to Simply learn that's save it
and here in our render method let's say
class name
for this app and let's create an H3 tag
and within the tag I display the message
so I say this dot state DOT message
let's save it and now let's import it in
our app.js component so I'll get rid of
export here and here I say
import new com from components and
newcom and let's define it here and say
new so we save it and look at the
browser it says subscribe to Simply
learn all right again to make our code
look more presentable let's add in
Styles so I'll just copy the same styles
that I've added here and I'll paste them
here and instead of bold I make it
italic and I change the color to say
purple and again in my H3 tag I Define
style and initialize it with this dot
Styles so let me save it and now if you
look at the browser it's in italic and
it's in purple
okay so moving ahead let's create a
button that reads subscribe and once the
user clicks on it the button should read
subscribed and the message displayed
above should instruct the user to click
on the Bell icon to do that let's first
create a button the message that I want
the button to read is subscribe however
this message gets changed once the user
clicks on the button so instead of
explicitly mentioning subscribe here I
create a prop I say sub and I say
subscribe here and back in my render
method I say this dot state DOT sub so
let's save it and if you look at the
browser now you have a button which
displays a message subscribe now once
the user clicks on the button the
message displayed should change to click
on the Bell icon to never miss an update
so let's create an event handler for
that so here button on click I call
another method and let's call the method
button change okay so this method should
update the state and change the message
and sub values to do that we make use of
a set State method now a state can be
updated in response to event handlers
server responses or prop changes now all
the updation can be done using the set
State method now this is the general
syntax used by the method we'll however
look at this further in the demo now the
set State method conventionally enques
all the updates made to the component
State and instructs react to re-render
the component and its children with the
updated State now let's go back to our
code editor and look at the working of
this method now here I Define the arrow
function button change if you are not
familiar with arrow functions I suggest
you read up on them and this is the
general syntax and here I say this dot
set State and inside I change my message
to hit the Bell icon to never miss an
update and myself sub-value changes to
subscribed let's save this and now if
you look at the browser when we click on
the Subscribe button the message changes
to hit the Bell icon to never miss an
update so moving ahead let's use a Bell
icon so that the user can click on it
once he clicks on the image the image
changes and a thank you message appears
on the screen so for that I have two
images I have Bell a and Bell B so I
drag and drop both the images in my
components folder alright now let's
import these images into our newcom.js
file here I say import Bell a from Bell
a DOT PNG and again I say import Bell B
from Bell B dot PNG all right let me
save it to display the image on the
screen we make use of the image tag now
this tag has two attributes one is the
source attribute that specifies the URL
and the other is the alt attribute that
specifies an alternate text for the
image so here in my component I say I
make use of a paragraph tag that will
help display the image in the next line
and then I use the image tag now since
my image changes once it's clicked I
have to define a property and pass the
event handler click that will update the
image so here before specifying The
Source let's go back to our state and
Define another
property that is image URL and let's set
it to Bell a since that is the image
that I want to display first let me save
it and here in my image tag I say Source
equals this dot state DOT image URL and
then we have the alt tag and I do not
want to display any message so I leave
it as it is now let's save it and if we
look at the browser we have a bell
displayed however now let's change the
dimensions of the bell I do not want
such a huge bell so back in my vs code I
Define style with width say 30 pixels
and a height with again 30 pixels let me
save this and now if you look at the
browser we have a smaller icon so once
the user clicks on this image the image
changes and the message displayed here
gets updated to do that we'll have to
Define an event so let's go back to our
vs code and here in my image tag let's
say on click click and Define a method
say this dot image change and now we
Define this method here as the image
change I make use of an arrow function
again and again I use the set State
method I update the image so I say image
URL is now set to Bell B and the message
is updated to thank you happy learning
so let's save this now and if we look at
the browser we see the image and once
clicked on it the image gets updated and
the message changes so finally Let me
refresh the browser once and show the
full execution Let me refresh following
the instructions let's click on the
Subscribe button and now it says hit the
Bell icon and once I do that the image
updates and the message changes
so let's start with creating a simple
demo on react.js and we are going to
create a simple application that will
connect to an online music streaming
service called Spotify and we will call
our application Music app so let's get
started the first step is to first get
the node.js platform and server
installed to do that let me go to Google
and let's just type node.js and here is
the website node.js.org there are two
versions available the LTS which is the
stable version and the current will
prefer the stable so we'll click on that
and you can see we have an option which
is called save file the moment this file
is saved to the disk we just need to
double click on it and keep clicking on
the next button to get it installed on
our system and we also have a
documentation available here so which
explains most of the features of the
node platform and there are binaries
available for for different os's Mac
Windows Etc so you can select the right
witness 32-bit 64-bit and the right OS
and then go ahead and download the
specific version that suits your
platform and you can see here that there
are different there are also help files
available that will allow you to go
through the installation documents for
node.js installation on Linux Etc so to
start with uh I'm opening up the command
prompt and here is where we're going to
call the node package manager using the
node package manager which is
pre-installed with your standard node.js
installation we will initialize our
react application so we would say react
Dash app and we want to now go and
create an application called music app
in this folder so as a prerequisite for
the demo all we need to do is install
node.js from node.j js.org the official
website just download it and install it
and that's when you open the command
prompt you fire npm which stands for
node package manager in it for
initialize react hash app is a standard
keyword to initialize and create a
skeletal structure of a react.js
application and the name of the app is
music app so we'll hit enter we'll give
this some time and you can see it's
started downloading the core react.js
libraries and it is attempting to create
uh our application so it's installing
all the prerequisite packages and
scripts that are required initialize and
create a new react.js application called
music app now once this application is
created all we would require is an
online editor so you could use an
offline or a non-premise editor as well
so any editor of your choice it could be
atom or Sublime Text or webstorm and for
this demo we're going to use Visual
Studio code which is a free editor
available by Microsoft and you can just
Google for visual studio code again uh
this is not Visual Studio professional
Edition Etc that we use for building our
c-sharp or MBC based applications this
is a lightweight editor for building
JavaScript based full Step full
applications so so while this installs
let's go and take a look at Visual
Studio code so this is the visual studio
code editor and this is the editor that
we've installed directly downloaded from
Visual Studio code.com and installed it
and all we need to do is open up this
folder that would be created with all
the prerequisite files in it we just say
file open folder and we would open that
folder within our Visual Studio code
editor so we'll give it a while until
that application gets generated and once
it's created we will again implement the
component based design and architecture
and the data flow between the components
and we also look at connecting to a live
data source which is a Json set of
characters that we would consume which
is a restful service the set of music
tracks exposed as a restful API endpoint
by Spotify which is a premium streaming
service we will connect to that and we
will look at accessing some of the music
tracks on that website Okay so we've got
the application created here so let's
minimize this and we'll open up our
editor all we've got to say is file and
open folder and let me go to the
react.js demo folder so this is the
music app that got created and that's
exactly what we're going to open up here
so we'll navigate to that folder it's
called music app we'll select it and
have it opened in our application so you
can see here we've got a node modules
folder this has all of the pre-installed
packages that make up the react.js
library we've got a folder called public
which will have the index.html file
that's the root file that will launch so
this is the single page application that
we typically create in react you have a
single page which on which we're going
to load multiple components so that's
the index.html and then we could go and
create a folder structure currently if I
open the source folder we can see a
single app.js file and that basically is
the file that has the source code in
JavaScript for a single component which
we are interested in adding on to our
page as of now so we just have one
component which is the default root
component that's the app component and
it has its corresponding CSS file and
then we've got the a public folder with
the index.html file which is going to be
the root HTML file that launches uh when
we run our application so let's uh go
right up here and let's add add a link
to an additional file so I'm going to
link to another style sheet okay so we
say relationship is equal to style sheet
and the type is going to be text and CSS
and we will reference a file called
reset dot CSS and this is a file that
we'll look at adding up later on it
doesn't exist at this point in time so
we will connect this and that's purely
for styling purposes uh so that we can
have all of our CSS Styles defined there
next thing I'll right click on the
public folder we'll create a new file
we'll name this file as reset dot CSS so
that's going to be the CSS file that
will have all of the CSS styling that
we're going to apply and I'm going to
use a ready code snippet for the CSS
code so let me just uh so all I'll do is
so I'll just go and pick up a ready CSS
file that I can just go and use if you
look here I have a set of CSS files that
are created that we're just going to use
uh within our application and and that
will avoid us spending a lot of time on
The Styling so that we can focus on our
Core Concepts which is actually learning
how component based architecture works
and how do we set up components and have
data communication between them in react
so uh here is a file called
reset.css let me just fire up notepad
and I'll just open up this file copy of
the text here and I'm going to just
paste it within my reset.css and if you
look at the code very simple it's all
about styling so we've got article
assigned Etc all HTML5 tags setup is
display block so they take up the entire
bit of the page we've got some padding
margin and font size Etc defined we've
removed list styling for the unordered
and ordered list specifying the line
height for the body tag so basically uh
just dialing up tables and so nothing
nothing to do with react here it's just
about simple CSS that we've added up and
now we need to actually go in and dive
into create creation of the components
that we need so let's right click on the
source folder so I'll select the source
folder we'll right click there and
that's where we're going to create a new
folder which is called components okay
so this is the components folder now
that's going to hold all of the
components within it within the
components folder let me create another
new folder and I'm going to call it app
and this is exactly how we are expected
to structure all of the code that we
have now I already have a CSS and app.js
which are the root components that were
added by default and all I'm going to do
is I'm going to move them within this
folder called app okay so this is a
proper segregation of responsibility and
all of the code that deals with a
particular component is all added into
respective folders and this really
improves the maintainability of the
application uh going forward now we'll
need some images and I'm just going to
make use of some set of images that I've
downloaded from the web and here are the
set of images that I have so I'm just
going to copy all of them and we'll come
to a music app and we go into the
components and app folder and that's
where we're going to add all of the
files and you've seen all of those image
files getting added so these are just
icons and images we're going to use for
our music tracks inside our application
now let's move to the app.css file and
this is where we've actually got uh so
the app.css file is the file that's
going to style up the all of the style
rules that we add it into the root app
component and this is what we'll have to
revamp so I'll just get rid of this code
and we'll probably add something for the
body tag the HTML tag and the root
element let me say hash root and let's
set the height to a hundred percent
coming to all of the HTML across the
page we'll give it a font size of 10
pixels and the H1 elements let me give
it a padding of
0.77 and 0 let's set a background color
give it a background color I'll just
select some random color here that can
be applied then we'll set up the text
alignment which is going to be the
center of the page we'll set up the font
family the font family is and this is
part of sun serif what else do we add
let's add up the font size
1.88 and also the color so again these
are standard HTML and CSS elements so
nothing really that has to be done that
is specific to react here so again we
are bringing in the Highlight class so
there is a class called highlight that
we will create later in the HTML view of
this component and we'll set this to a
red RGB component so combination of 46
113 and 238. okay so that's uh pretty
much done let's move on and also add up
for the anchor tag let's add up some
text decoration and set it to none so
that the anchor tags don't come up with
those underlines and of course we'll
provide a color of hash here so a white
color there now coming to the H2 element
for the H2 element let's have a font
family and again I'm going to use so I'm
going to use the font family that we
defined here bracket and we change this
to probably
1.55 okay now coming to the app tag uh
let me just save this and create a copy
of it there was some content that I did
delete and I can simply go and make use
of it so I've just undone all of the
deletion so this is uh something that I
can't if I can use something I can just
probably use it from the tag below so
let me start with the height here and
let's say the height of the header is
100 of the app sorry not header padding
0 17 10
17 the background and I'm going to
change that to background URL so the
background URL or let's say the
background image we will have a URL
property okay and that URL is going to
be dot slash
vg1.jpg so that's the image that we've
added some in the previous step let's
also add background size so we'll add
background size and set it to cover I
also need a background position that we
press enter let's have background repeat
which is set to no repeat so that we
don't have the image in a grid format
and then I would need this so rid of it
let's take up the font family we'll
maintain the same font family let's use
Font weight the font weight is going to
be 500 and the color is going to be hash
so that's a white color then we come to
dot app dot release so that's going to
be another class that we are going to
use dot put app dash playlist is what we
we're going to name it and let me say
that the display should be flex flexible
display and we will justify the content
to leave spaces in between all right so
that finishes that bit and now uh let's
write up a media query for the
responsiveness of this page so this is
media for only screen and Max width is
going to be one zero two zero pixels
okay and the class name that we'll
provide later is obviously app playlist
so for this screen size we would align
all the items to the center and we
change the flex Direction okay so we
seem to be good with the CSS for the app
as of now and that's the app.css that we
created let me save everything okay
let's check for any kind of additional
so all three of Errors no errors now
things are good in the app CSS and it's
time to move to the next step of
building this application uh now we'll
have to go and add up the code for uh
the app.js file so let's dive into the
app.js file and this is where we will
actually need to go and add all of the
code that is required for the app
component so all the code that's
relevant to the app component we are
going to add up inside this specific
component itself which is going to be
obviously the app.js file so we have
skeletal code which is import importing
the react library and let me get rid of
the basic sample logo we'll have app.css
that's getting imported here uh besides
that a lot of other files that we'll
have to get in so let me import playlist
and this is these are the components
that we'll create as we go forward and
we're going to get this from the
playlist folder and the component the
file is going to be called playlist so
we'll add that then we'll have to go and
also import search bar so what we're
basically doing is we're going to split
this app into different components
there's going to be one component that
manages the playlist of all the tracks
one component will act as the search bar
so that's the search bar component that
we're going to add so searching for
tracks will be managed by this we'll
have another component that we create
that will get imported into the root app
component which is uh search results so
this is going to display the record set
with the set of results as an outcome of
the search criteria so search results
slash search results and finally we'll
go and import Spotify that's the Spotify
fi service from so we'll create a
utility folder which will hold the code
that connects us to Spotify so that's
what we are adding up next so all of the
Imports are done one component that
manages the search bar so that search
bar search results let me correct the
spellings there that search results
that's Spotify and playlist so that's
done now let's move on to the class that
we're going to create here so let's
create a class app that goes and extends
react dot component so that's going to
be a react.js component so that's a
Constructor we discussed about props or
properties and State Management and
that's what we are implementing we are
using the super keyword as a best
practice so that all the properties are
initialized in the Constructor and also
we pass the values of the chain to the
super class which is the root component
class now we're going to initialize a
variable called date that's going to
manage the state and we are interested
in tracking our search results so we'll
have multiple results so we'll show that
as an array the playlist would have
different names so we'll just call ours
new playlist that's the default name and
we will also store a list of tracks
which is going to be playlist tracks so
playlist tracks is going to be a list of
tracks and let's close this block okay
and this 2 is going to be initialized
within the Constructor so we'll add it
here and now we need to do The Binding
we discussed data binding so let's look
at creating a search variable which will
hold this dot search dot bind and bind
to the context of this very class so we
are passing this pointer then we'll
create another variable called at track
which to this dot add track dot Pine and
all this functionality is what we're
going to add going forward so right now
we're just setting up the bindings then
we'll have capability to remove a track
so we'll say remove track so remove
track equal to this dot remove track dot
point and let's fix that so and all of
this 2 is going to be initialized as
part of the Constructor so that's where
we're going to add it then we need to
update update the playlist name so we
need functionality that will help us to
update the name of the playlist so
functionally that helps us to update the
playlist name so let's start update
playlist name is equal to this dot
update playlist name dot bind and this
is the pointer that will pass I need to
save the playlist so this dot save
playlist equal to to restart safe
playlist dot find and pass this and then
I would also need to remove the track
that has been searched for from the
playlist so remove track search go to
this dot okay remove track search and
Dot find and finally one last function
that executes all of these which
probably will bind to find to this
context so all the Declarations are done
in the Constructor now we need to
provide the definitions for all the
methods that we actually have added here
so let me select this tab inside and
let's start with the search function so
we'll Define the search first it takes
some variable value that it searches on
and then I'm going to say Spotify dot
search I'm going to search for term dot
then and that's an observable so the
moment it the search returns a value it
it's going to call this callback
function and that's when we want to set
the state and we're going to set the
state for search results to whatever is
passed by the system so the search
results are going to be returned as a
callback and that's what we'll store as
an updated State now coming to the add
track method so let's roll up and we'll
say add track and this will take the
track to be added let's declare a
temporary variable called tracks equal
to this dot the current state of all the
tracks that are there in the playlist
now if tracks dot find I'm going to call
the find method so if we are able to
find which means that the track is
already there in the playlist then we
would not want to add it if it's not
there in the playlist that's when we
would want to go and edit the triple
equal to is any quality operator that
will check for both a batch value match
and a match on the data type as well
okay so if the track is already saved to
nothing if the track is not saved just
track the track ID because that is the
track that will uh have to be added if
it's not if it's already there then just
return if it's not there then we've got
to go to this variable called tracks
we'll use the JavaScript method called
push and we will push the current track
into this tracks array and then update
the state so we want to set the state of
the playlist tracks and this is how uh
your State Management that we discussed
in detail is actually being practically
implemented here okay so the track has
been added now let's talk about the
remove track so that's the remove track
function and that's the track that we
want to remove so let's let tracks equal
to this dot state DOT playlist track so
the set of current tracks that we have
and let's track search another temporary
variable equal to this dot the current
state of the search results then let's
take the tracks array equal to track
start filter so filter is of JavaScript
function that will again allow you to
remove a certain value create a
temporary variable called current track
use the Lambda operator and if the
current track dot ID is not equal to the
track dot ID which means this particular
track is not there in the list okay so
you need to remove that and again I have
a method called as unshift which will
actually get rid of the track in the
array and then we've got to so we'll
search whether that track is existing in
the tracks array if it is then we simply
want to remove it if not we do nothing
so we set the state we need to update
the state of the playlist because the
track has been removed so the playlist
tracks will have to be updated with this
tracks array okay then we go for remove
track search that's the next method that
also will take a track as a parameter
okay here we are going to say let tracks
which is another temporary variable
we'll give it this current state of
search results and then we are going to
say tracks equal to tracks dot filter
current track current track dot i t not
be equal to the track dot ID and then
this is where we would want to say this
dot set State and we'll pick up search
results and let's go and assign that to
track so that's the updated set of
tracks after making the change let's
remove this and correct it okay so
that's fine so the remove track is now
the remove tracker the remove track
search is now in place let's add the two
these functions which actually again
takes track as a parameter and here
we'll say this dot add track okay so it
adds the track and then it removes the
track from the search criteria so the
search component which is managing
searching of the tracks that will go and
remove it from there after adding the
new track so that's a combined operation
we want to execute then I've got update
playlist name which will take the name
of the track to update and press dot set
State the playlist name is what we need
to update with the name that is passed
to this function then we've got to save
playlists so here let me create a
constant variable constants are
variables whose values will not
frequently change we'll take all the
track Uris dot state DOT playlist tracks
will be dot map create a temporary
variable called track track dot URI so
we actually want to go and now save this
on uh Spotify so that's the reason we'll
access uh spotify's safe playlist method
this dot state DOT playlist name comma
track Uris and if that is successful we
then go and do a callback so that's the
Callback Anonymous function where we're
going to say this dot set date and the
playlist name that we want to create on
Spotify will be called new playlist so
that's the custom name that I want to
provide and the playlist tracks Define
that this closes here okay so that's for
the update on Spotify now here is where
the random method is going to return the
HTML now this HTML is the view and and
react simplifies this by having the
JavaScript and the HTML in the same file
so you can actually go and access the
variables you've declared in the script
directly in your HTML View and
synchronize and bind the data together
so it helps from a maintainability
perspective so even though everything is
in the same file it's well classified
and differentiated into different code
blocks so we'll add the anchor tag and
we'll say href is HTTP localhost so
that's the default server port on which
this application will run okay and we
want to give it a custom URL name of
music or file so the H1 terminates will
then say div class name equal to app
within that this is how we're going to
inject our search bar that's going to be
the search bar component injected here
and on search so that's the custom event
we will call a method called called
search so on search we just call we bind
to a method called this dot search then
we'll open up another div here we'll
have class name equal to app dash
playlist and if you remember that's
exactly the CSS class name that we refer
to in the CSS file we have another
component called search results
that we're going to inject here and
that's going to be search results here
search results will be equal to this dot
state DOT search results so that's how
we can actually go and bind so that's
simple data binding the component is
going to be displayed with the data
bound and if somebody says add if if I
click on the add button for search
results to these so it will add that new
track to the playlist by calling binding
to the 2DS function and it will remove
it from the search results text box then
we have another component called
playlist and here the playlist tracks
will be bound to this dot state DOT
playlist tracks okay so on the top if
you look here we started with defining
all the function declarations in the
Constructor then we provided the
function definitions okay that's how and
this that we passed refers to the
context of the current component itself
so whatever you put into the app
component or into the respective
component those values will be then
passed out here to these individual
functions okay so that's with the
playlist couple of things we'll have to
do is if somebody changes the name of
the track so on name change is going to
be another custom event where we'll have
to call this dot update playlist name
and we also have remove functionality so
to remove a track we would say equal to
this dot remove track on Save equal to
this dot save playlist okay so that's
done and we close this so we seem to be
pretty much on track the export app will
make this all of these functions
accessible across other components it's
very similar to the public access
specifiers Etc that you provide uh in
other programming languages so that's
done we've created our app component now
let's create another folder under
components and we've got to Define all
our various components here this folder
is going to be for the search bar so
we'll name it search bar We'll add two
files within it the search bar dot CSS
okay and another file that we'll need
here is search bar dot Js so that's in
terms of the search bar let's start with
the CSS file so we'll start with first
styling search bar we will say that the
display should be Flex Flex direction
should be column we want all the items
to be aligned at the center so let's
align item Center then we'll add a
padding so padding top is going to be
6.94 REM and margin bottom is going to
be
6.33 REI all right now let's add up for
the search bar so that's search bar
We'll add for the input element we want
the width to be 287 pixels the padding
to be
0.8880
the Border should be 1 pixel solid white
the Border radius will give a slight the
rounded Edge to give a web 3.0 look and
feel so we'll set up the Border radius
then we've got margin bottom so we've
got a potent margin that we want to add
up then we have color so let's add up
the color
c3f so that's the color black then let's
add text alignment of Center and let's
add up a font size of one REM okay so
that's how we've set this up let's add
the search bar input is going to be so
if someone focuses so focus is the got
Focus so if someone clicks inside so the
end user goes and clicks inside the text
box we change the outline To None okay
and so for the search bar we are
interested on input and if the input is
focused so that's the events that we are
looking for and then we would have a
button called search button so on the
search button the cursor will set it to
pointer so that's the cursor pointer the
width we set it to
8.11 REM the padding we are going to set
up to
0.77 REM and zero the Border radius will
set it to 54 pixels so we get a slightly
well defined search button with a nice
little border let's also add background
color hash 1
dp954 that gives me a color then I've
got my text alignment let's set that to
Center then we've got a font family
let's set up the font family to the same
standard font a t and it's a part of the
sense serif family then we'll set up the
font size to 0.833
RTM correct this and finally we will
need transition so all of these are
basic CSS properties so that will add a
slight transitional effect with a delay
of that many milliseconds so transition
background color we've provided what
else let me scroll up let's also provide
a border here so we'll remove in fact
let's remove the Border we would not
want a border on the button that would
look odd so I'll get rid of the border
and color will specify as per our
standard color that we've been using
okay so that's the color we've specified
and then I've got font weight of 500.
finally we'll take the search button and
on the search button we will register
for the hover event so if someone takes
their Mouse over the button that's the
hover event in that case if we hover
around the the pattern we would want the
background color to change so it will
appear to have a slight little glow
there a mouse pointer moves over the
button okay so that's the opacity and
the RGB combination so that completes uh
the CSS file for the search bar and we
obviously now need to go and get the
code in for our search bar component and
that's exactly what we are going to do
next so let's start with setting up the
code for the search bar first thing
let's go and import react from react
next thing we would want to do is import
the search bar dot CSS file then we
Define our class called search bar which
extends react dot component we Define
our Constructor and we go and
pass these parameters to the base class
we also Define the state we'll just need
one variable here which is the term to
search for in the search bar and then
let's say this dot will Define a
function called handle term change which
is going to be equal to this dot handle
handle term change dot find so that's
going to be the first function then a
function that will do the searching for
us which is this dot search so that's
the search function and we'll have it
bind to this then we've got this dot
handle enter so the moment we enter into
that search text box
handle enter dot find this so the
functions are ready now let's go for the
first one which is handle term change
we'll pass it a system defined keyword
of event this dot set State and for the
term we will use the event keyword we
will get the value that is there inside
that text box the moment the search term
the user is entered changes so the
search criteria changes we trap the
updated value then in the search
function we will update the local
property props dot on search okay so
we'll access the on search and pass it
the updated term and then we got the
handle enter on which uh we're also
going to pass the system Define event
keyword so if there's any data flowing
along with the event we are interested
in it in this case the data is the key
code that the user is pressing and if it
is 13 that indicates that's the asci key
code for the enter button so if we enter
is hit then the user is completed
entering the search criteria and we need
to start searching and that's where we
write our render method that's going to
render the HTML View and we return the
complete view here so that's the view
now that we want to return let's say
Tiff class name equal to search bar then
on the input text box we will use
placeholder equal to enter song album or
artist that you want to search for on
change on the on change event the moment
the term changes we connect that to
handle term change we already have an
function that manages that and the
moment keys are pressed and released so
on E up is where we would want to
connect to this dot handle and
yeah this is press bracket that I'll
have to
come here so in the render function uh
we're going to return a value I
shouldn't forget to export the search
bar okay so that's uh what I want to
export so we've exported that okay so at
the end of this uh what we've done is
we've written a random method we've
written our div tag here is where we'll
go and close the div tag we've added an
input and here is where I'm going to add
a button provide a class name called
search button and the moment the end
user clicks on the button we're going to
connect it to this dot search and we
close the button tag within the button
tag search so that completes the the
render function so in the render
function again let's run through all of
what we've written we started with
extending react.component we then added
a Constructor passing props to the super
class Constructor we created state we
set it to a value of term and null so
the state currently we defined as term
then we said handle term changes search
and handle enter should be functions
that we want to add then handle term
changes we defined search we defined and
handle enter we've also defined then we
used render render vset is going to
return to us the HTML that we've
specified okay we dumped all the HTML
that we want this component to return to
us
so on change and on key up are both two
functions that uh or two events that we
connected to where we called handle term
change and handle enter then we added a
button where we registered for the click
event and connected it to this dot
search so all the three functions uh
that we had actually written so two
things we've completed now uh in the app
class okay if you look at the app class
we've actually defined a set of
functions here that deal with the
playlist and adding applications Etc
adding tracks removing tracks
then we've created the search bar okay
so we saw that the search bar also we
have specified a set of functions and
all the functions that we defined we
have taken care to structure every
component separately so the search
component is doing something completely
different which is managing the search
bar we have the core the root app
component in which we have imported all
of the other set of JavaScript classes
uh that we are creating and that's how
the entire application is now structured
so and that's the core concept when
you're working with react where you
would actually have every separate block
of code or every separate functionality
handled in a different component
altogether so we've completed the search
bar component as well so two components
done and two components good to go so
we've got to start up on the next set of
component units that we will need to
build and the next component is the
track component that will manage
individual tracks so a new folder a new
file called track dot CSS and track dot
JS so that's going to manage the tracks
for us so let's start with DOT track we
would say display is flex
align items Center border bottom one
pixel solid
rgba 256
256
256 0.8 that's the opacity then let's
come to track action so we'll use all of
these classes when we write up the HTML
view We'll add a padding here of 0.5
we'll set up a font size of 1.05 set up
a transition color of
0.25 s order of 0 pixel and a background
color of
rgpa0000 color hash so that's the color
that we continue to use then we bring in
track another class track action and if
we hover over this class we want the GP
value use change to 265 to 65 265 5 is
the last parent so that's the hover uh
then we have track information so track
information is the next class that we're
dealing with We'll add the flex
parameter first display flex and then
Flex direction is going to be column
let's have justify content set up as
Center and let's have height as 180
pixel so that's uh track information
let's have another track information and
the H3 tags nested inside that for all
the H3 tags nested inside that we'll
need a margin bottom of
0.22 ramp finally let's have track
information and paragraph tag we'll have
of the font size of
0.83 REM and a font weight of 300 and a
color as well that we'll add so let's
add up a color here a gba 2 6 256
256
256 and 0.8 okay so that's uh that's in
terms of the CSS and let's move to the
track and we'll move into the Javascript
file so let's move into so let me take
what we added in the search bar I'll go
to the track.js
this will change to track dot CSS okay
the Constructor this will change to add
track so add track change this to add
track this is remove track change this
to remove track get rid of this and
that's going to be the add track
function and here we're going to say uh
this dot props so we'll modify this this
dot props dot on add this dot props dot
track and then we have the remove track
so that's going to be the remove track
function this function is not required
so this dot props dot on remove and this
is the track that we would want to go
and remove We'll add up another function
called render action in so this is going
to be a function that we are defining
called render action and in this we'll
just check if this dot props dot is
remove if this dot props dot is removal
so in that case we would want to return
so this is a view action method that we
are adding which is going to go and add
this button with a class called as track
action that we've already written the
CSS for and this button will actually
get added via this render action
function and this dot remove track is
what it's going to map to Let's close
this this is going to bind to this
specific function so that's uh the
closing button tag okay so the closing
button tag is what we've added there and
The Binding is what we have done to
desktop dot remove track and we will
terminate this here so now the render
action uh let's also have the return
here and we just add up the button and
this is going to add track so you can
look at how the component is completely
Dynamic uh in nature so we have two
buttons that are going to be added this
button with a hyphen is going to remove
the track this button uh with a plus
sign is going to add the track and you
can actually see how simply it was done
in a render action function so the
render action function actually helped
with checking that if uh on the value of
the props and if the user depending on
the action performed you will actually
be able to remove a track or add a track
from the existing playlist okay and then
uh the class name here is now going to
be track the class name for the
enclosing div inside it so let me get
rid of this the class name for the
enclosing tape here is going to be track
Dash information within it we'll add H3
we'll bind to this dot props dot track
dot name so the name of the track is
going to get bound here then in the
paragraph We will bind to this dot props
dot track dot artist and with some cap
this dot props dot track dot Hardware so
that's what we've data bound to and then
let me add an iframe an iframe allows us
to uh very easily inject some content
into the page within a small embedded
window The Source parameter of the frame
is going to be https
open Dot so here I'm connecting to the
Spotify stream spotify.com slash embed
slash track and close this so that's the
Spotify stream that we are going to
connect to and this dot props dot track
dot ID so that's the track ID the width
is going to be 300 the height parameter
this the height parameter is going to be
80 of the iframe and the frame order is
going to be zero and the allow
transparency so that's the opacity we'll
say true let's add allow encrypted media
so if Spotify has encrypted media that
also would be embedded here and we can
also have the title set to preview so
that's uh with the iframe okay at the
bottom is where we would want to so this
could be an empty element and we can
close it right around here so we
wouldn't need this part and then here
I'm just going to say this dot render
action so we call the render action
method uh which will actually give us
plus minus button to add and remove a
new element okay and that's uh what we
can actually go and add up there so
let's check now whether all that we've
done is good to go fine so everything
looks good uh in terms of the track
component now and we have all of the
functions in place it's now time to jump
into the next component that we would
require after the track component and
that's going to be the track list so
this is going to be a list component
that will comprise of a list of tracks
inside it so we'll create a new folder
called this try track list and that's
going to have track list CSS and it's
going to have track list dot JS so
that's the tracklist component now which
we're going to go ahead and use and the
CSS we don't need much so let's just say
track list and we just provide a width
of 100 okay that's all we'll need in the
CSS so let me add this in the CSS file
save this and come to the JS file now
which is going to have the tracklist
code that we will need to add up so here
again I'm going to say import react from
react we'd also want to import tracklist
dot CSS and we also want to go and get
track because this component is going to
be made up of a collection of tracks
individual tracks so we want to get this
from track slash track and we'll Define
class track list which is going to go
and extend react dot component we just
need the render method here because this
just needs to go it does not really have
any state of itself it simply goes and
returns a list of individual tracks so
this class name is going to be track
list and we'll bind to this dot props
dot tracks dot map create a temporary
variable and this will go and return the
track component which is going to bind
to individual track data the key is
going to be track dot ID so the key is
going to be track dot ID and on at on
adding a new track we want to bind to
this dot properties Dot and we already
have on at defined so that's what we
connect to we add up my base bracket
here okay and uh then we would also need
is removal equal to this dot props dot
is removal and click on remove will to
this dot prop start on remove so that's
for the track removal and so we've got
our track list uh oh yes we'll have to
go and also close the tip tag correctly
and also we'll need to go and Export so
we'll have to go and Export the track
list so we've got one more component
done which is track lists and let's move
on to the next component now so we've
got app which is root we've got the
search bar that takes care of entering
the search criteria we've got individual
tracks that are searched and returned
and we've got a track list that manages
a set of track records so the track is
more relevant to the playlist and then
we've got the search results also to
manage once we search for some set of
tracks so we'll add a new folder which
manages search results and this is going
to have search results dot CSS and it's
going to have search results dot JS okay
so we need a search results dot CSS and
JS and here in the CSS file we'll keep
it simple for the search results so
we'll say search results we'll set up
the width of 50
we'll set up the height of 950 pixels
we'll say overflow y is scroll we'll say
padding is
[Music]
0.88 REM background color will be rgba
95
23 23 0.7 and we will use the Box model
so we'll provide a shadow dropping
shadow of 0 4 pixels to pixels 2 pixels
hash and then uh let's add a scroll bar
so webkit and Moz are the constants
specific to Mozilla and chrome browsers
so they target certain animated features
Etc or properties
that are specific to those individual
browsers that's the reason we use those
constants and then we'll also add a
media query that if it goes with a Max
with one zero to zero pixels in that
case dot search results
width is 90 percent with a margin bottom
of 2 REM okay so forgot to add hyphen so
it's hyphen web hit scroll bar 0 pixel
width and we've set transparent
background so that's that's about it
with the CSS I need to get to the uh JS
file now let's move to the search
results uh JS file and that's where we
will now have to go and add up the
component code for search results and
let me take pick this up from track list
add it up here this would be search
results and we need the results will
return to us a list of tracks so we'll
have to get uh track list this will be
tracked list
and I'm just going to return class name
will also be search results so that's
the component and this is going to
export out search results so it's
accessible across other components then
we've got H2 with results let's go and
create
tracked list with a set of tracks and we
will bind it to this dot props dot
search results and on the on ADD we are
going to bind to this dot props dot on
ad so we already have that so that uh
basically completes search results and
that leaves us with the last component
which is going to manage the playlist
for us so we'll add up a new foods We'll
add up a new folder in components and
that's going to be playlist and within
that we will have a playlist dot CSS
and playlist dot JS so that's our
playlist component now that we're going
to work with and the playlist component
is uh Wheels first setup the CSS that we
will need to add up to the playlist and
I'm just going to pick that up from my
code snippet so that's my playlist and
let me get all of that CSS here so
that's uh just a CSS for the playlist
nothing to do with react again pure CSS
uh let me get uh into the JS file and
that's where we will need to go and add
all of our component code so again let
me go to the track.js the track list
rather let me get this and add it out
here we'll make some small changes this
is going to be playlist I need to import
the track list because the playlist is
going to contain a list of tracks this
is going to be playlist and
let me here this will be playlist and we
leave this for later okay let me also
get uh the Constructor in so we'll add
up the Constructor here and just one
function that we will need here which is
handle name change you know if I need to
change the name of the playlist so
handle name change and that's exactly
the function that we will need to write
code for so that's the event
and this dot props dot on name change
that's when we'll say event dot Target
dot value so we get the updated playlist
name coming to the render we now need
the input input is going to be on change
equal to this dot handle name change the
default value we have already provided
with a hard coded value which is new
playlist so that's the default value if
not provided then we'll just pick up the
default value then we've got uh track
list so track list is what I will add
the tracks I am going to bind to this
dot props dot playlist tracks
so we're going to bind this to playlist
tracks
and here we will say is removal equal to
true and on remove equal to we'll find
that to this dot props dot on remove
finally we'll need a button we will use
class name equal to playlist Dash save
that's what we've added in the CSS click
equal to this dot props dot on Save and
here we're going to say save to Spotify
so that's with the playlist and yes we
need to go and Export playlist and not
track list
now we'll need to uh do a quick lookup
in Spotify so let's go to this website
called
developer.spotify.com and when we once
we sign in uh and create an ID it takes
us to our dashboard uh that's where we
can create a sample application the name
of the application will be musical file
okay and we'll say that we are building
uh some kind of desktop app for example
for which we want to connect this to and
we'll also need to provide uh so we'll
say next refresh the dashboard so it's
uh asking me for a login so let me log
in once more so moment I log in that's
going to be description and I'll say
maybe this is why I need it I'll say no
not commercial integration agree with
the terms and conditions and we will say
submit
and that's the application that has got
created and now I can say edit settings
and the redirect URL here is what is
important so it should accept
connections from HTTP localhost 3000
that's the port on which we will host
our application okay and we'll say save
okay so that's uh now there's a client
ID that is generated here for my app
which is unique so I'll just copy that
up let me come up to my application
under the source folder I'm going to add
a new folder called util and under that
a new file called
spotify.js so we will start with adding
our code to the spotify.js file that
we've just created as a new file within
the newly created util folder the first
line of code is going to define a client
ID variable that equates to the client
ID that we will generate on Spotify so
this is going to be the Spotify
generated client ID which is a unique ID
Associated for the developer to connect
to the Spotify API and we will look at
the source of that as we go through the
demo the next variable that we create is
the redirect URL or let's call it
redirect URI and that will equate to
localhost colon 3000 which is the port
and we'll create another variable called
the access token let's also create
another constant variable called Spotify
and this will work like a function
expression so we'll equate it to a
function called get access token and we
will say if access token is true then
return the access token now let's
declare a constant variable called
access token match which will be equal
to window dot location dot h i F dot
match and we will say this is equal to
access token which will be equal to and
we will give a regex expression to do a
pattern match Ampersand so that we can
actually get into the URL and extract
the token information from that and
hence uh the pattern match is crucial
here another constant variable called
expires in match equal to window dot
location dot href dot match here we will
read the expiry information using
another regex expression from the URL
Ampersand asterisk so that's the second
constant variable we've created now we
will say if access token match and
expires in match in that case the access
token should be equal to access token
match of 1. then we create a variable
called expires in equal to we'll do a
Typecast to number and we will take the
first parameter from the expires in
match that's done then we will say
window dot set timeout and we are going
to say access token equal to comma
expires in multiplied by 1000 then we
will say window dot history dot push
State and we will say access token we'll
pass the second parameter as null the
last parameter AS Slash and close this
and we will return access token else
we will say const access URL equal to
https
accounts dot
spotify.com slash authorize
client underscore ID equal to Dollar
client ID Ampersand response type equal
to token Ampersand scope equal to
playlist Dash modify so we are actually
building the URL that will now get
generated so we'll say modified Dash
public and redirect
URL equal to Dollar redirect URI so we
have constructed the URL now that will
go out and get generated in the browser
and here we are going to say window dot
location equal to access URL then we'll
add the search criteria function which
accepts a term as a parameter to search
on here we will say constant access
token equal to Spotify dot get access
token so we get a reference to the same
access token return we call the fetch
function and we're going to pass https
API dot
spotify.com slash V1 slash search
question mark That's the query string
that we will add type equal to track and
Ampersand G equal to dollar and we will
pass the comma as the Header information
we will need to pass the authorization
where we will say that the pairer is
dollar access token dot then response
return response dot Json dot 10 so the
return of this function once it
completes we will then call the next
function so Json response and then we
will say return response dot Json after
that another 10 block so we'll now say
Json response and if not Json response
dot tracks in that case we will return
an empty array else we will return
jsonresponse dot tracks dot items Dot
and we will pass we'll create track as a
variable with a Lambda expression and
we'll create a temporary Json object
with ID and that's where we want to
associate track dot ID that was returned
as the search result the name is going
to be associated with track dot Name the
artist is going to be associated with
track dot artist of 0 dot name the album
is going to be track dot album dot name
and the URI we will equate track dot URI
so that completes this block will open
the next and we this will be the save
playlist which will take the name and
the track Uris and here we will check if
not name or not track Uris dot Len in
that case we simply return out of the
code and then we declare a constant
variable called access token which will
be equal to Spotify dot get access token
so we get a reference to the access
token we then declare headers
authorization pairer is going to be
taller access token and we create a user
ID and now we will return the fetch
result where we will pass https
API dot
45.com slash V1 slash me so that's the
URL comma headers will be the Header
information then we call the then
function declare response as a variable
use the Lambda expression and access
response dot Json question we use the
then block to declare Json response here
we say user ID equal to
jsonresponse dot ID and then we return
fetch https
API dot
spotify.com
V1 slash users slash taller of user ID
slash playlist so this is how we have
constructed the URLs manually here we
will say assign headers to the headers
variable we'll assign method as host so
the data is sent as part of the body and
not as part of the URL and as the body
we will say Json dot stringify to
convert this parameter name and then we
will generate a response variable to
response dot Json and then we'll create
Json response with the Lambda operation
will create a constant lay list ID which
is equal to
jsonresponse dot ID we will return fetch
https API dot spotify.com V1 users
dollar user ID slash playlist slash
taller again we are constructing the URL
so playlist ID will be replaced here
then we will say tracks and close this
comma and here again we will say headers
would equate to the headers variable be
constant headers and this close here
okay everything fixed now so here we're
going to say headers should equate to
headers and the method is going to be
post and the body is going to be Json
dot stringify Uris track Uris and we
close this we close this block we close
this block and we close this block so
that completes our code of course one
more thing we'll have to do which is
export this class out so export default
Spotify and that completes the code for
uh the Spotify dot JS which is part of
our utils class so let's move on now to
the next step so uh here is the client
ID that will have to exactly match so
I'll copy this client ID and provide it
here so that's the client ID that we
actually need and we could also store it
out here so that's the client ID and
that's the redirect URL that we've also
defined there and we just create an
access token if that access token is
true we return access token so the
access token is something that we are
going to do a match from uh the moment
we try and connect with this particular
URL and you can look here that this is
the access URL that we are trying to
connect with okay with the client ID and
host fixed with the redirect URL right
and then I've got a simple search
function which returns an observable so
we try to fetch data using the search
term that we provided okay we try to
fetch data using the search term
provided if we are successful we get a
response of the data and accordingly
we'll iterate over the Json response and
get a list of tracks out of it and do a
mapping of this Json object to the track
ID name artist information album name
Etc and here just like a data access
layer very similar to a data access
layer we've got a save function which
will save this data to Spotify as well
so I've got a save playlist and I've got
search so these are the two functions
which which will go and connect to the
Spotify service by using this client ID
and it will allow me to access that
information in terms of returning a
stream of Json data and will then allow
me to go ahead and push that Json data
into our application so now we'll
actually need to start up the
application so I'll go to the terminal
and rather let me go to view and bring
out the terminal so this is the
integrated terminal that's there in the
tool and it just opens partial from
which you can actually fire your
commands so I'm going to say node
package manager npm start to actually
start up this application so that's
going to do a full compile and
so we will fire this up give access so I
need to Grant access to that Port 3000
let's give it time to run and that's the
app now that uh you can actually see
here so this is uh the search bar that
we actually had okay then we had the
results we had the playlist now the
results is going to consist of a set of
tracks which are maintained by the track
list and then you can take individual
tracks with the plus and minus button
and add them into the playlist okay so
that's how uh it's typically going to
work okay so as you can view here I am
just going to search for an artist and
we'll click on the search button it goes
to Spotify tries to connect there and
says that I need to agree to the terms
and conditions and I've just agreed to
that so the very fact that it actually
uh gave us a confirmation link uh the
moment we try to connect and execute our
application uh that's proof enough that
it actually went and connect it to the
service there and tried to return a
value to us so this is what we did we
just added an artist we said search uh
and you can see now it's successfully
connected I've got a list of tracks
available from this artist and you can
see the plus buttons getting added on
the fly so that was the render action
these are uh buttons that got added onto
this list of tracks dynamically the
moment the search results returned a
value so I can click on this plus sign
and you can see that the track gets
added to the playlist okay as and when I
click here so I've added a couple of
tracks if I go back to my dashboard of
my music file application and that I've
created here in the developers portal of
Spotify on developers.spotify.com it's
blank so now I'm going to click on save
to Spotify okay and that clears the
playlist so let me come here and now
when I come out here we saw that it
actually got successfully connected out
here now I'll have to log in to so this
was the development app that we actually
created on the developers portal of
Spotify now we will go to
spotify.com so I'll just go to the
Spotify website and it says do you want
to launch the web player and all that so
let me click on that so it just launches
and can you see here this is the new
playlist that just got added right and
there were four songs that had actually
added to the playlist and you can see
here those four songs have got added out
here okay so I can go here and I can
delete this playlist and say I want to
delete it okay so there's no playlist
now I'll go back here I'll add two
tracks and I'll say save to Spotify so
that's how you actually saw that the new
playlist you can see the new playlist
has come back here okay and that's the
playlist the the playlist has got
generated again and that's the new
playlist that got created and we deleted
it but it still got created again and
that indicates the connectivity that we
successfully created with this react app
and the core concept of the react app
was breaking it down into components
which is the search component then we
created the track component we created
the track list to maintain a list of
tracks then we created the search
results which will generate a list of
results which further contains a track
list and this is the embedded iframe
which gave us the response which is
scrollable here and you can see that the
iframes we created allowed us to scroll
this with this embedded web page inside
the iframe container so with that uh I
hope we've been successful with
explaining the concept of component
based design and architecture with react
and how important it is to create
individual components and the benefit of
that being that you can isolate change
requests to a certain component you can
promote reusability wherever you want
the same feature to be element on the
page you can just inject that same
component and the same implementation
and the same features can be reused so
it promotes reusability it promotes
flexibility to change it isolates your
change request to single components
preventing the massive effort of
recompiling and retesting the entire
application as a whole
in this session we'll be comparing the
three Cutting Edge UI development
technologies that is reactive angular
and view we learn about the key
differences that make them so distinct
all of these technology Stacks have been
replacing pure server-side Technologies
and we've slowly progressed from
server-side applications to more
distributed applications where a part of
the job is done on the client side and a
part on the server side and now we've
transitioned to something on a single
page applications or spa and all of
these technologies that you see on your
screen right now are based purely on
JavaScript as a result their lightweight
and aren't dependent on any third-party
runtime tools so let's compare the three
Technologies and learn about the factors
that make them stand out so let's see
what's in it for you we learn about
their features use cases and where
they're applied their performance how
they handle data the languages they use
and their testing mechanisms we learn
about the dedicated user community that
backs these Technologies and finally
we'll see the growth curve first we'll
look into the saline features now react
is a front-end JavaScript library while
angular and view are JavaScript
Frameworks now although the terms
library and Frameworks are used
interchangeably they're significantly
different now Library G is a set of
classes or functions and the user is in
complete control to call them Frameworks
on the other hand are like models they
have limited choices and come with a
blueprint of their own and as a result
the user doesn't have much control so
JavaScript being an interpreted language
where code is executed line by line
makes all these tools very efficient
mainly because converting the code into
an intermediate code would require a
runtime environment and would definitely
encounter a delay now these are avoided
and as a result these tools are fast
moving on reactors used to develop
mobile and web applications and angular
is used for single page applications and
you can also develop hybrid applications
using the stack mainly because it's
purely based on CSS HTML JavaScript and
jQuery single page applications as the
name suggests are built using single
page now the entire page is broken down
into several components wherein each
component performs a specific task say
for example one component handles the
login the other one would display icons
and images and so on all these bits or
components are then put together to form
a single page application and moving on
react was developed and maintained by
Facebook while angular was built by
Google and view was developed by Avenue
and X Google employee now react
represents the view part of the MVC
framework and angular is a full-fledged
MVC framework in itself and view on the
other hand is focused on view and the
model layer of the MVC framework now
what exactly is the MVC framework now
MVC framework is an object oriented
design principle that mandates the
separation of control meaning one thing
can only do one thing so the model deals
with the entity classes the data and the
business logic while view deals with the
representation and the UI logic of the
application and the controller drives
the functionality of the two any changes
can be easily factored and isolated and
as a result testing becomes a whole lot
easier moving on now let's look at the
use cases from the business perspective
in terms of react we have top websites
like Facebook Instagram Netflix that use
react on the other hand we have angular
that is used by Nike HBO Forbes Sony and
view is commonly used by alibaba.com
grammarly 9gag and Adobe moving on we
have performance now performance is a
very crucial feature now the moment you
build an HTML View and render it into
the browser this view to the user is
basically just HTML tags however if you
look at the internal working the code is
actually converted into a balanced
restructure this B tree algorithm is
extremely fast so when the user makes
any changes to the UI the changes are
reflected immediately this is
facilitated by the B3 algorithm so as a
result the performance is improved so
how does react make use of this tool it
uses a virtual dom dom dom is an API
developed by w3c it stands for document
object model and defines how the
document is accessed and manipulated
related this Dom passer converts the
HTML code into an inverse balance tree
structure so react uses the virtual Dom
while angular uses the real Dom and view
uses the virtual Dom again now the
virtual Dom looks at the differences
between the current and the previous
HTML pages and only changes the parts
that need to be updated angular on the
other hand updates the entire tree
structure regardless of any changes made
or not and view again only updates the
ones that have changed since there is no
time spent on making unnecessary changes
to the entire tree react as extremely
fast on the other hand real Dom updation
is time consuming risky and Aero Pro Vue
also ensures faster and buff free
performance now let's talk about data
binding the core reason why we would use
single page applications now consider a
scenario where you log into an
e-commerce website as a user one then
you should be able to see the items in
your shopping cart while user 2 would be
seeing different items in their shopping
carts and so on so identifying the user
and retrieving data corresponding to
that specific user is facilitated using
the help of data binding data binding is
a process that allows an internet user
to manipulate web page elements using a
web browser now it is used in
interactive components such as
calculators tutorials Games Etc now
react supports one-way data binding
meaning you can take the data from The
View and push it to the model or vice
versa angular on the other hand uses a
two-way data binding while view also
uses a similar two-way data binding in
react every time the model State updates
The View changes accordingly however the
reverse is not true in case of angular
any changes made to the view are
immediately reflected in the model part
of the architecture view follows the
same principle now this hugely
influences the performance due to
one-way data binding react is modular
and fast improving the performance
angular's two-way data binding adversely
affects the performance and view on the
other hand performs according to the
input type moving on to scripting
languages react combines UI templates
and JavaScript logic resulting in a new
language called jsx so react only
requires a knowledge of JavaScript
angular uses templates again in HTML you
can also inject JavaScript code into
HTML using a clever implementation in
angular called directors so you can
create a class and then inject it into
HTML angular also does something better
you can also write code for an angular
application using a newer language
developed by Microsoft called typescript
it is a compiled language and is very
similar to Java and c-sharp in terms of
syntax now view again uses HTML based
template it uses HTML5 throughout for
the UI and the combination of JavaScript
for business logic all view templates
are valid HTML and can be passed by HTML
passwords let's move on to testing now
just as a framework or an API that is
developed by Facebook and is used to run
tests on react applications to ensure
that they are bug free now it is
embedded typically in every react
liability and requires zero
configuration now angular on the other
hand uses the Jasmine framework now this
framework allows various functionalities
to write different kinds of test cases
this also ensures that the application
is error free The View CLI or the
command line interpreter has built-in
options for unit testing with the help
of jest or MoCA now view typically has
single file components and hence these
components can be tested in isolation
this makes it modular and extremely fast
now let's talk about Community Support
since all these tools are open source
they have a large developer Community
there are a few popular GitHub
repositories for react such as react.js
101 react.js.org and so on you can raise
queries solve a few and connect with the
larger Community that's working on react
here are a few repositories for angular
view also has a few popular repositories
you can commit download third-party
plugins and also explore these tags even
deeper all of them surely have a very
happening community at the time of
writing there were about 1 million
repositories 5 million comets and 1
million issues with respect to react
here are the figures for angular and
here are the figures for view according
to npm stat over the past two years
there have been approximately 360
million react.js downloads there have
been around 38 million downloads for
angular and around 63 million downloads
for view now let's look at the future
scope learning a new technology always
comes with questions like what's in it
for me what's its growth potential how
far will it take me in my career and so
on so let's go ahead and see the growth
rate of react angular and view according
to Google Trends over the past 12 months
react has been on a way faster upper
trajectory than angular and view which
have considerably lost their momentum
now this indicates that react is growing
faster than the other two with respect
to popularity industry adoption and
Community Support welcome to this
session on how to connect react.js with
node.js and in this session we are
actually going to look at how do we
connect react.js with node.js so a very
warm welcome to this session on react.js
connectivity with node.js and in this
session we are going to focus on how do
we connect our react.js application with
the node.js platform so we are going to
dive into creating a Hands-On demo which
will have two parts to it we would have
the client application that we will
first create as a react application we
will then create an Express GS
application with node.js and we will
then try to connect both of those
applications together so express.js is a
rapid application development framework
that allows us to create a web
application very quickly on the node.js
platform and we'll use it to create a
custom API and then connect that
endpoint to the react.js client
application so let's dive into our demo
and let's start with creating our client
and node Express applications and see
how to set them up and then get them
connected to each other let's start with
our Hands-On demo and we will first go
to the node.js website node.js.org we
can download the LTS version which is
the stable version of node.js moment I
click on this it will prompt me for a
download it will download the MSI file
and then all I need to do is double
click on it keep clicking on the next
button and install that would install
node.js for us next we'll open our
editor you can use any editor of your
choice so I'm going to use an editor
called Visual Studio code and let's open
up the terminal here and I also have the
command prompt open where I've navigated
to a folder that I've created called
react.js demos now we'll invoke the npm
package manager which is invoked by the
command npx so npx will not only install
packages but also execute them once they
are installed so once they are
downloaded it will execute the package
and we will use npx to go and create a
react application called client so while
we give it time for the installation to
complete we can then open it within our
editor so we'll give it time so that the
installation completes
so the installation is completed and so
we've seen here that the installation is
now completed and let's go and open up
this project so I will say file and open
folder and let me pick up that folder
and we will open this application called
Clive so that's my client app let's fire
up the terminal so okay so that has
launched the terminal for us and here
all we need to do to fire up this
application and get it running is npm
start which will compile and start up
this application that is created let's
close this we'll go to the browser and
now let's say localhost 3000 so that
gives us a startup page the sample
default startup page for the first
client application uh and this is going
to work as a client we'll now go and try
to create the backend application which
is going to be another application that
we will set up and to create that the
let's say npx Express generator API okay
so this will create an express
application on node.js called API and
let's give it some time for installation
okay so that's done clear this screen
will come out here we'll open another
instance of the editor we'll say open
folder and that's the API application
we'll say select folder and the API
application is opened let's go to the
terminal now in the terminal we will
attempt to install all of the packages
that are required that would be logged
in the package.json file so the
package.json file here would be a listed
as so you can see we have a list of
packages that it uses and npm install
will go and install all of these
packages that were pre-listed here so
let me ensure it's executed correctly
and we'll fire that once more that's
done so npm install has installed all of
the packages required and click let me
terminate this run by pressing a Ctrl C
so this terminates the client
application that was executing and now
we will say npm start so that this
application executes and let's refresh
so that's the standard express
application now that has got installed
now let's go to the API application
we'll go into the bin folder and here
we'll have a file called www we will
change the default port number from 3000
to 9000 let me stop this application
from executing we've just updated the
port number now let's go to the routes
and we'll create a new file in the
routes folder called test API dot JS
here we will say variable Express equal
to require Express and here we'll say
variable router equal to Express dot
router and here we will say
router.get we'll open this so that's the
default route root route is going to be
slash for which we'll add a callback
function which will take the request and
the response parameter and next pointer
in case there is another function to
call post that and here we will just
send a simple message saying API is
working okay a simple message sent out
for the root default route and we'll
have to export this so we'll say module
dot exports equal to router all right so
that's uh done let's go to the app.js
file and here let us import that so here
is where we will import this by saying
app.use we want to use the test API file
and that is test API router and this is
exactly the same variable name that we
will declare here which will be equal to
require and we are going to say routes
test API all right so let's try
launching this now we would say npm
start after adding this code let's go
out here and 3000 test API is going to
be the URL to hit it's not 3000 but 9000
now because we just updated the port so
9000 test API and there we have a
message which says that the API is
working properly so this is tested now
let's go to the client application in
the client application let's go to the
app.js file okay this is the file that
we would have to revamp a bit so let's
uh revamp this here we will declare a
class app which extends so that creates
a new module so it extends react dot
component and here we have Constructor
we will accept the props here I would
pass props to the superclass Constructor
and set the state to API response
currently it just has an empty value
next we light up a new function called
call Api which will generate a call to
that Epi URL which was HTTP localhost
9000 was the port and test API was the
URL once this is called we will then
call the then function declare response
generate a call to response dot text and
then we will again say this dot set
State API response is going to be equal
to the response that comes in from that
URL which is nothing but a string which
says API is working another function
called component will Mount so the
moment the component is initialized on
the screen and load it we will generate
a call to this function we created
called call Api then comes the render
function in the render function we would
go and return a div class name is app
this would be app header the standard
logo after which in the paragraph we
wouldn't need the link here right after
the header We'll add a paragraph where
we will print this dot State and the
variable we created called API response
and we will data bind to that so that
largely completes the return so we
simply create this application that's
the react application that will talk to
this API that is and this URL that is
hosted on node communicate with it get a
simple string as a response print that
string inside this react application so
once that's done we have the component
will Mount which is a life cycle method
here it's a new lifecycle event that
gets triggered the moment the component
loads and that's when we have actually
gone and executed the call Api custom
function let's go to the API application
we'll terminate the execution here
there's one more step that we'll have to
perform which is cross origin resource
sharing which means that to allow the
react application to communicate from
another hosted domain to this particular
domain servers we will actually have to
enable cross origin scripting and
sharing otherwise it will block the
request coming from another application
so for that we'll have to install
globally cross-origin module and dash
dash save indicates that it's going to
do a global install for all applications
that are on this particular system so
we've installed this and we clear the
screen let's go to the app.js
and right here is where we would want it
to go and use course so we will say
app.use course so that it uses this but
particular API and here is where we will
declare the course variable and go and
import the new Library read package that
we just installed which is course so
looks good and now let's uh fire up this
application with an npm start let's also
fire up client with an npm start and now
when I go and try looking for localhost
3000 which is the react application the
react application should go and talk to
the API that is hosted on node.js which
returns to me that string message so if
I go and ping that API separately which
is localhost 9000 test API you can see
this is a standard message so here I've
directly pinged the API that's hosted in
node.js now we are consuming it through
the react.js application and if you
scroll down you can see the message
returned from node.js into react saying
the API is working properly so the
Practical impact of this is to actually
host restful Services Etc on node as a
server and you can go and consume the
data that is written there could be in
string text or Json format directly into
the react.js acting as a client
application hello this is Matthew with
simply learn and today we're going to
cover react with Redux so with our
session today we're going to go through
is going to cover why you'd want to use
Redux when you're building a react
solution what Redux is what are the core
principles of redox and what are those
pillars that drive what you're doing
Redux and then finally what are the pros
and cons of redox and after we go
through the PowerPoint presentation here
what we're going to do is we're actually
going to go through and actually do a
demo of actually using Redux so you can
actually see how this would all look so
why would you use redirects well the
reason why you want to use Redux is that
Redux actually understands and helps
manage the state of an object 8. and
Redux was introduced to help address
some problems that you're having with
react so the state of an object stores
values and properties that belong to
components that could potentially change
over time so the state could be modified
by actions in your network they could be
changes to the re-render of the
component in the browser the object
could also then potentially store
multiple properties and then with Redux
it actually takes in and actually will
create a you know take a a large
application that you could create with
app with a react and breaks it down to
several components instead of having
this massive number of states you have
to manage and so every time that you you
know an application will then switch
from a current with a react you'd
actually be then changing the states and
this is a really big problem because
when you're like doing that switching
back and forth there is the potential
for applications to be re-randed with
which reduces the efficiency of your
application and so this is why Redux was
introduced
so you know what is redox so Redux is a
way to be able to have a predictable
State container for your JavaScript
applications and it'll allow you to run
your applications in multiple different
variants so whether it's a client
solution a service solution or a native
app solution and then more importantly
um or one of the key elements that I
like about Redux is that it's really
easy to test and so with Redux you're
able to manage the state of your tool
you can actually use it to work with any
JavaScript framework or library and you
can actually then store the um the
application and the components in a
state store which makes it easy to be
able to manage the state of your
application so in simple words Redux
stores all the state objects in a single
store and organizes it it provides
information about the current state of
the application any changes in the state
of the application can be described to
the store by the user and then it
notified is any modifications made to
the state of that application so let's
jump into the key principles of Redux
and there's three key areas I want to
focus in so the first one is that Redux
provides a single source of truth and
that's our source of Truth is being able
to store the state of your whole
application in an object Tree in a
single store and this makes it easier
for you to debug and inspect components
of your application also enables you to
be able to persist your app stage for
development and improve fastest
development Cycles the second principle
is that state is read only and that's
why you're able to describe more
effectively what's happening because it
is read-only and this ensures that no
events like Network callbacks would
create and any issues with the code and
the re-rendering of your application and
that object I've become then just plain
objects and then finally changes are
made with pure functions and so what do
we mean by this so we can actually take
actions and transform the state tree
with a pure reducers and we'll go into a
demo electron to show you this but a
reducer is essentially a function that
accepts an accumulation value and then
it takes back and returns that as a new
accumulation and this allows you to have
a single source of Truth value the user
can return the new state objects instead
of me taking to a previous state the
user can start with a single reducer as
the amp grows it can then split off into
a smaller reducers and then finally the
reduces just become functions so let's
talk about the pillars of redox
and so there are three key areas we have
the store the actions and then reducers
and then the store itself is the actual
main object that holds the application
tree state
um and there are four key States there's
get state which turns the currency to
the store and when we actually run the
demo later on you'll be able to see that
we'll be able to open up our terminal
window and be able to get the state
store from our terminal window the
second state is dispatch and this is a
an action it's the only way to update
the application State and here we have a
action on a button change to actually
change the state of the application and
then the final two are subscribe
unsubscribe and these are our ways in
which you can actually change the
listener to the state so an action is a
plain object that represents an
intention to change the state so with
actions you have payloads of information
that send data back and forth to your
application store so you can send any
kind of data and they can go back and
forth and that actions must also have
then a type field that indicates the
type of action that has been performed
and finally with reducers reducers are
specify how the application State
changes in response to actions sent to
the store and so actions only describe
what's happened but don't describe the
application State change they are
reducer is a function that accepts the
current state and an action and then
returns a new state with the action
performed and then finally you can use
combined reducers utility which can then
combine reducers in an app into a single
a index
so let's look at the pros and cons of
using Redux because nothing is perfect
so a pro for working with Redux is that
Redux provides a single source of Truth
which is the store so there's no
confusion over where you're getting your
values
um this then leads to having a
predictable and strict outcome Redux is
more stringent about how the code is
organized this makes it easier to
onboard developers because there is a
very structured way of writing Redux
code this makes it also then easier for
the initial render which allows you to
make the Your solution really optimized
as an experience and then finally
developers can track everything that's
going on inside the app in real time the
cons so one of the big cons is there's
no encapsulation so you're using Redux
to test out the code and the writing of
your code but the component cells can
access data and they there is potential
for security issues uh you do have to
use boilerplate code so this kind of
takes us back to the structured code
format it is
um strict and it's set up and it is very
intensive so with that let's go in and
look at a demo of using Redux to
reformat a react application
so in this demo we're going to use react
to show how Redux can work first thing
we want to do is go ahead and download
node.js we're going to go to nodejs.org
to get the latest download the downloads
are available in Windows Mac OS and a
Linux you can also download and
recompile the source code if you want I
encourage you to go with the latest LTS
versions the latest stable version now
there are other versions you can use but
that's one you would want to use I
already have it installed so I just want
to show you how that looks so I'm just
going to go in and put node dash dash
version it's going to give me the
version number so it shows it's
installed and we also use npm which is
node package manager because we'll be
using that validate that it's installed
by doing node mpm version so okay so
looking good and we're going to go ahead
and create a folder on our desktop
um normally you wouldn't put a project
folder on your desktop but you know this
is just for an experiment so we're going
to call this one Redux re the ACT is
going to be taking a react project and
we're going to show what it looks like
as a standard project and then what it
will look like as a project that's been
taken through Redux so let's just move
our cursor to the correct folder
and so we're going to go to CD Redux
react
and there we are we're in at the correct
folder using our command prompt
you use terminal on Mac OS
so let's just type in MPX that's for our
Redux and we're going to do create Dash
react Dash app so we're going to create
a default react app and then we'll also
install Redux Dash app
and these are the two components that we
need to be able to uh build out our
solution one is a react and it's
react.js and the second is Redux
we hit return
and this is going to go ahead and
download the latest versions of both of
these applications and install them into
the folder that we just created on our
desktop
and just give that a moment and so it's
installing the different packages react
react Dash Dom react Scripts
and there we are have everything
installed great
and these are just different commands
you can use
and it's recommending that we select npm
start
to get everything up and running so
we're going to use Visual Studio code to
do most of our work here vs code is open
source solution for scripting
and it's available on all the new
platforms it is from Microsoft but it is
open source and there's just a ton of
stuff here but we're going to go ahead
and we're going to open up the folder we
just created on our desktop
so here is Redux react app
and we're going to select that folder
and on the left hand side you'll see all
the files from that folder we're just
going to get rid of the welcome screen
we don't need that anymore you'll see
there's some commands we can use we do a
Control Plus
um I'm not sure what that's called again
anyway it gets us to the terminal window
um not an exclamation point so you'll
see that in our project folder we have
all of the files we need for our
solution we have both the node modules
and then the public files the Poke files
is just the application itself so we're
here on the index.html you see the index
file there and we're going to actually
show what this looks like inside of a uh
as it's broadcast from a web browser in
a moment now we're going to create a
very simple application here and the
application is going to look exactly the
same in both
um uh just standard react and Redux
react it's the optimization that's going
to be improved so we just did npm Dash
and start it's going to take us to
localhost colon 3000 give it a moment
and then we should get our
floating
logo showing that the applications up
and running there we are
we can go ahead and hit and edit app.js
to create our application
okay so let's go in and we're going to
go into fjs
and we are going to create an
application called newcomp
.js and we actually have some code that
we've already created that you can
download as part of this application so
but we're just going to type in here
import react
and then component from
react
so I'm going to pull in our react
Library
and we also import
connect
from
react
Redux
and that's the
package that we're working in
West terminate the bad job yes
and then I'll rerun
npm
install
dash dash save
react
Dash Redux
and there we go takes a moment just to
install that
so our goal here is to show how you can
optimize your solution with Redux for
the using the store and reduces in Redux
again the solution is going to look
exactly the same what's going to change
is the performance of the solution
and this is what Redux gives you all
right so we're going to go ahead and
we're going to go in I'm going to type
in class newcomp extend component
and then we're just going to select our
Constructor
props
and then we want to add in there
super props
and then this state
equals
I'm gonna have a message here
subscribe
to Simply learn
very simple little app don't forget to
save your work as you go along
and we're just going to play some styles
just make the
play some font style
okay italics
color
purple
and let's have a button that we're going
to press a
button change
equals
this set state
oh sorry get state
and we'll have a message that comes up
basically saying thank you for
subscribing
there we go we have our button we'll
change the state here in a moment
and very simple
little application
now we want to run them
on the screen
I'll just have some basic
HTML for where we're going to place
everything we use a div tag
for our app
again we're going to keep this really
simple
and we're going to call we'll reference
this styles for
this H3 tag
so our message is going to be subscribed
to Simply learn
and this will be created dynamically you
can use our style
I'm going to add in a button
click action
subscribe
and nope change too many s's
save that
and see now let's run a script
you're going to have Js
and we can actually import that into
app.js script
rid of this
and then
we'll extend
the new scope.js
component into here
in
thank you
font style here
and
render this correctly
and we'll pull in the text
and styles
again very simple little application
not playing from Musical
so we'll actually have a welcome screen
a welcome line and then pulling two
lines of code
all right let's run that
npm start
and here we go refreshes our page
so what we've just created is a basic
standard State object
and oh
see now oh yeah this is good now we
actually can show you that we didn't
actually write all our code correctly so
let's go back and fix that
is Newport and use
newscomp.js and we have to make sure
that we have a correct export feature
here so that the image about the
everything can be exported effectively
and import we also need to have an
export
foreign
that again
okay should take care of
uh problem hey there we are so welcome
and then we have the standard set object
of subscribed simply learn from here to
subscribe and we change the text to
thank you for subscribing okay so that's
kind of go in and modify this now so it
goes from being a standard State object
to one that uses store and reduces
so we're going to go ahead and terminate
our batch job and essentially reset
everything
and what we're going to do now is
install Redux
this is what's going to help us
it takes a moment to install Redux
all right so we have Redux installed
that's good
and now we want to
start
our package
and it looks the same but now we're
going to make some changes
so let's go to
our index file
index.js
and here's our react Dom
now we're going to add in
can't store
so this is going to be our react this is
going to be our Redux store so we're
going to create a new store
and it's going to be a reducer
and we're going to put in
strict mode
okay which is not to find go ahead and
Define that
so we're going to come over to our new
comp.js file
and what we want to do here is we're
going to take out the one class file
that we just created
and I'm just going to stripping it down
here
now let's go in and
let's map our state
to props
equals state
and we're going to do return
message
is state DOT message
and then
construct map dispatcher props
yeah
and this is going to be a dispatch
and we're going to type in return
and we have our button change
and for dispatch
and we'll type in what the message is
you can have message change
let's start from the button okay
so we pass the value over
all right
and now we're actually
connect
as part of our export and in our
connection
I'm going to do this map State props
and map
dispatch props
foreign
new comp
now we want to switch over
and we're going to just change some of
our linking variables here so instead of
to button change we're going to do props
dot button change otherwise we won't be
able to find in our code
this is some pathing
and
[Music]
you go ahead and create a new folder and
then this one is going to be our store
and again this is going to be our Redux
store
I'm going to call the store reducer.js
and const initial State equals
this is what the default state will be
for when the page loads which will be
subscribed to Simply learn
and then
the reducer
we're going to place to where the
reducer is
and constant new state
huh
and it's going to be
any of action
DOT type
I'm going to change the message
it's unused comp
so that's the action there we're gonna
pull that so it's identical
and then new state DOT message
equals
thank you for subscribing so we have the
default and now we have the new message
again this might seem like um extra work
but actually makes your whole
application much more efficient
and Export default
juicer
all right so make sure we saved all our
files which we have
and
now let's go ahead
so we have let's just inspect everything
it's all looking good
all right
now terminal window we're going to do
npm start let's see what happens
and our web browser should load up
we have an error that's good so now
we're learning stuff so this again this
is all part of you know standard coding
is just hunting down errors in your code
so let's go to index.js
and
pull in here
so we have reduce and this should
actually be
spelled correctly there we go
okay all right everything is now
as it should be
let's go back recompile
rerun a file
and do you want to move a file let's
just go ahead and move the store
I'm going to update all the links to the
store
and we're going to be trying main chart
provider store
is reference correctly
thank you
let's rerun our application
and there we are
so let's go back through
notifications running much faster now
we're able to manage our changes and
elements for our applications different
objects
we're able to change the messages after
you click
and able to then create the new message
again this is a very simple application
but you can see how for more complex
Solutions how this become useful and you
can start using the different components
you create
for your whole solution and that's our
demo
welcome to this session on react native
versus flutter in this session we would
look at identifying some of the
differences between the react native and
flutter Frameworks let's start with
understanding the core areas of
comparison as part of this session we
will be looking at Key aspects to
identify differences between both the
Frameworks predominantly on the language
front the UI aspect the performance the
documentation the popularity the
community support that is available for
both these Frameworks along with the
industry Trends in terms of the industry
adoption for both these platforms the
core objective of the session would be
that at the end you should be able to
decide and make an informed decision as
to which framework is the best among
those available let's start from a
language perspective now if you look at
react react is basically completely
written and built in JavaScript using
the react.js API on the other hand if
you look at flutter it is basically
written in a very new language called as
start and we do not have too many
developers that are skilled on Dart
however every browser and every platform
being shipped with an inbuilt JavaScript
execution environment that makes
JavaScript platform in a language of
choice for developers so every browser
today or every browser manufacturer
would have input support for executing
JavaScript programs similarly most
popular platforms Mobility platforms
like Android and iOS have default
support for executing JavaScript
programs and that's the reason when you
compare this with flutter flutter uses
Dart which is predominantly a newer
language and we really do not have too
many developers who are skilled on this
so that really is the selling point and
the USP of react native because when you
work with react native you really do not
have to relearn a lot you don't have a
sharp learning curve most of the
JavaScript developers who are working
with mean stack already working with
HTML CSS and dhtml can easily align to
this that is we have discussed uh is
pretty new in the industry and would not
have that much of penetration in the
developer Community from a UI
perspective when you talk about react
native it's based pretty much on Native
components for the Android and the iOS
platform and flutter on the other hand
uses a very proprietary uh set of
widgets and it has its own page
structure that needs to be set up so
it's a closed ecosystem as compared to
an open ecosystem in react native which
allows you to go and implement third
party widgets and UI Frameworks as well
now this is really what allows you to
pick and choose with react native
because you can go and decide whether
you want to use Kendo UI or a set of
delivery controls or any other
third-party UI framework can be
implemented but for flutter you have a
pretty closed ecosystem and that's the
reason the UI components that are
available out of the box and built into
the platform are all that you can use
from a performance perspective when you
talk about react native it basically is
built and uses JavaScript out of the box
and that's the reason when you want to
write any code in JavaScript that
connects and tries to access native
services on that specific platform it
uses a bridge to do that but when you're
using flutter on the other hand flutter
does not need any kind of bridge so
there's no concept of you write flatter
code and then it uses a bridge to go and
connect to the native set of components
to interact with and this is what really
impacts the speed and the performance
aspect of developing and executing
applications between both these
Frameworks because if you look at react
the speed of development is a little bit
slower when you compare that with
flutter and that's because it has an
intermediate bridge that it has to
communicate with and every layer of
additional communication and computation
that you put in between two tiers in a
application that you built obviously
would have a performance impact from a
documentation perspective if we were to
compare flutter typically has a very
well defined documentation repository
and it allows developers to go through
it in a very simple manner so it's all
structured it's all organized unlike
what you see on react native because it
react native it actually since react
native is an open ecosystem and allows
you to implement third party widgets and
you can do a lot of configuration and
plug and play and that's the reason the
documentation also is not very strong
well and impactful and that's the reason
most developers would find it a little
challenging to go through the react
native documentation when you compare
that to the documentation available in
terms of flutter popularity is always a
key when working with platforms and that
should be a crucial decision maker
because when it comes to open source
Technologies and you're stuck somewhere
you obviously go to the commit to the
community to go and find out how best
you can solution the problem now flutter
being relatively a new entrance into the
market it does not have a lot of
developer penetration and that's the
reason the popularity in the community
is not very strong react native being
there for a while now it's been around
for some time and that's the reason uh
it's pretty popular among developers
also since uh it uses JavaScript it's a
natural transition and a progression
path for those who are working with
HTML5 CSS and building web applications
or have been building hybrid mobile apps
find it very easy to migrate to this
because flutter requires you to learn a
new programming language which is start
and that is one more reason why the
popularity of this is much much better
on the react native front as compared to
flutter again if you look at Google
Trends uh you could actually look at
both of the lines here the red line
indicating flutter it started on a very
positive note and then there was a
plateau and then suddenly a spike react
native has been much more steady in
terms of its growth and ultimately if
you look at it now both of them seem to
be trending at par with each other so
the community support as we were
speaking about if you look at stack
Overflow which is one of the most
popular websites to go for any kind of
developer Trends and movements and for a
q a that most developers would have you
can actually look at the number of
questions here and also react native is
part of GitHub as it's open source it
was released in 2015 and it's because of
the huge Community Support that it
becomes easier to implement this you
have a lot of confidence as a developer
when you start building on this stack
because if you're stuck somewhere you
will have a lot of help available on the
way on the other hand if you compare
that with flutter you can look at the
question accounts here on stack Overflow
and this being a new entrant in the
market uh it has a smaller footprint on
the community aspect but of course that
keeps increasing every day again from a
react native perspective and you talk
about stability in terms of stable
releases there again you would see that
react native does a much better job as
compared to flutter so the industry
tense are something which all of us have
to be aware of specifically if we would
need to make a decision in terms of our
careers the technology that we are
learning what is the growth aspect what
is the industry adoption and how we
could really move ahead on our career
graphs in terms of the opportunities
Market the job market Etc so again
getting back to stack Overflow which is
the Benchmark for understanding
technology Trends in I.T Spear and
software development if you look at a
recent survey conducted in 2019 uh 62.5
percent of developers uh seem to have
shown interest in react native as
compared to a marginal rise of 65.4
percent where flutter seems to be doing
much better and of course that could be
due to the uh time frames that both
these technologies have been around
react has been around for quite a while
and hence the job prospects are much
better A lot of organizations
implementing this clutter's been a new
entry and hence uh a slightly fewer
opportunities as if the penetration
still needs to happen in the
opportunities job market and from a
developer skills perspective so these
are some of the big names that are using
react native even their implementations
right from Facebook to Pinterest to Wix
Sky Tesla insta Bloomberg you can
actually look at the implementation
across industry which is absolutely
crucial when you're learning something
new because when you want to join a
large logo obviously if there are a lot
of logos using this that enhances the
credibility of your learning puts a
justification to why you would want to
learn this technology flatter on the
other hand associated with big names
like Google Sonos Alibaba the largest
retailer out there from a conclusion
perspective if we were to conclude on
what we've discussed from a language
perspective obviously we said react is
much more popular since it is a natural
progression for developers to work on
JavaScript and then move to this as
compared to tart which is relatively a
new language from a UI perspective the
open source Plug and Play capability of
configuring and adopting seamlessly to
newer platforms of widgets and
third-party UI platforms are much better
as compared to flutter which is a closed
ecosystem and depends on inbuilt widgets
to implement the performance aspect we
discussed because of the bridge from the
code that you write to the native
component access exists in react and is
isolated and not any longer required in
flatter and hence the performance is
impacted because of the additional layer
in between the documentation much much
better in flutter because it's a closed
ecosystem and they can control what you
can use react native being open-ended it
really has a lot of third-party
integration you can do and hence the
documentation is not very well organized
the popularity perspective react native
much more popular among HTML5 css3 mod
mean stack developers since it's all
JavaScript flatter needs you to learn
new skills and you need to spend
additional time for that from a
community support react native has been
there for a longer time as compared to
flutter and hence as stronger Community
Support as compared to flutter and that
translates into better job prospects in
the industry for react native as
compared to flutter so if we were to
give it a score react scores much better
with a total score of 5 leaving flatter
with a total score of two so I hope we
were able to understand the differences
between the react native and flutter and
this will help you make better decisions
with planning your career and deciding
which technology you should latch on
so our demo is going to be about
creating a calculator using react and
node.js and so we have here just a basic
calculator nothing crazy but the whole
thing is going to be created with react
and so be using JavaScript to be
installing react and installing the
various components such as node.js and
the different npm solutions that we need
so as you can see when the calculator
works just fine and now let's go ahead
and
let's go and install the different tools
that we need so the first one is going
to be node.js and we do Google search on
node.js and we always start with Google
searches because it's the easiest way to
find things and so we go to the default
node.js site and you can go to downloads
and there are windows Mac OS and also
Linux installers you can also download
the original source code you can buy it
yourself if you want and you'll also
need a text editor I'm going to be using
visual studio code it's just my favorite
text editor it's free Works across all
platforms uh it comes with a ton of
extensions so you can get up and running
really quickly with it
um so we're just going to go ahead and
install the windows version I already
have installed so to download it again
you also want to make sure that you have
the latest version of node.js installed
with the node package manager so we're
just going to open up our terminal
window and validate which version that
we have running
and we can do that fairly easily we can
just put in node dash dash version and
it'll tell us which version which means
that it's installed and same thing with
npm node package manager we'll do npm
version and that will give us back the
version number again you have to have
them installed for them to be able to do
that and we're going to also now create
a react app so we're going to do install
and then it's going to be create Dash
react Dash app that's the command to
create a new react app
and we're going to install it right off
our desktop
so let's go in and we'll put MPX
create Dash react Dash app
and then the app is going to be called
calculator which will install a folder
on our desktop with all the appropriate
react code
and this will be just a template
application but it'll have everything
there that we need to get started with
hit return and that will take a few
minutes just to install everything
here we go
and so as we go through some of the
components that we're going to be
creating today we're going to be
creating an app component and they'll be
the main component that has all the
information that will then be displayed
on the screen then we have a layout
component and that will be the actual
look and feel the calculator and the
output component which will be the
results from the calculator and then the
output row and this will be all the
different tools that we will need and
here we have our new folder right there
on our desktop but we're actually going
to go in now into visual studio and if
you've seen any of the other
node.js videos that we've created you
know that I like to work with node.js
and visual studio code because I can run
terminal window right there so I'm going
to open up the folder that we just
created that's called calculator I want
to open up the whole folder and I'm not
a file but the whole folder and here's
our folder on the left hand side
we have all the different files there's
our Json package that has the
instructions for what the calculator
looks like
including which version of react and the
Dom
and here's our default
elements
and as you can see because we're using
react it's going to embed the code into
a HTML page and so we have a div with
the ID of root that's going to reference
some class files that we create and so
the app.js file as the application code
that we're going to be modifying in a
little bit and you'll see that it
actually then
references up to our
index.js file
and if an index.js file it has the ID
element root which ties back to the ID
element of root in our HTML file so
we're constantly referencing and
cross-referencing our application
and this is where we're going to be
doing most of our work
right so we're going to go ahead and
open up the terminal window
and the first thing we want to do is
start
npm
and
it's now going to have everything
running on let's go have logo host and
everything running on Port 3001
we'll give that a moment and this will
actually then bring up just the standard
default react boilerplate app
it's taking a moment to load
I should probably get a faster computer
up there there we are
just not patient so here we have our
basic boilerplate react.js application
nothing to create crazy here
so let's actually go in and start
working in some VAR code so uh see now
yep everything's running where we expect
it to run
all right so let's go into fjs
foreign
we can actually go ahead and if you want
to type control plus C and actually stop
the app or you can um in the terminal
window you can actually stop it
and you can also go up into the terminal
command to stop it as well
and if we do stop the app then we'll get
an error message there we go site can't
be reached
and you'd expect this
I'm going to go back in and
we're going to just restart our
application
and everything should now be working
just fine
we're going to refresh the page
and we'll see our default react app
coming up on Port 3001.
and there we are
looking good looking good
okay
so we're going to delete out what we
have there because we want to put in our
own content
and we're going to call this one class
app and we're going to go in there we're
going to be modifying that class here in
just a moment we'll put a default layout
I'm going to create a new folder
this folder is going to be called
components this is going to be for our
calculator
and put a new file in there
I'm going to call this one layouts.js
and this is where we're going to start
breaking down the structure of our
layout
and we're going to
select import
layout
and then we want to do the path to our
layout
components layout you initially we have
the dot because we have to go up one
folder that's the command for that so
dot up one folder components folder
layout
notice we don't have to type layout.js
it automatically knows
to add the JS extension
constantly making sure that we're saving
let's go over to layouts.js
and this is our layout
and do this using CSS
and we're going to import
react from
react
and then select import
and there we go link to layout CSS it's
going to be a CSS file that we're going
to create
so we're going to have to type that in
layout.css and notice we had to write
out explicitly that it's a CSS file
and so here we have
and then we're going to put in
the constructions for the layout
what our props look like
and then we'll export default layout so
it can
show up correctly
okay so we go to our web page now
yep that's good we're expecting to see
that so we need to change some of our
pathing here just correct quickly so
let's see now
foreign
we're going to move a file so it can be
accessed appropriately
we run this
you know what I think we didn't we have
to update
uh yep I know we have to go back to
layout and
we have to start adding in
some values here
so that
the application knows to lay content out
so we just put in a
little hello world there we are okay so
that shows us everything is pulling
through correctly
so we want to get rid of hello because
we're going to replace that with our own
application
I'm going to change this
div so that it actually starts pulling
in the application
I'm going to put in the class name for
calculator and this will be a CSS
reference
okay
so you need to have some image files
and what we're doing here is we're
essentially building up the different
elements that will need to be presented
on the screen
and then we'll have a CSS file that
we'll use to create these elements
and as you can imagine I've I've already
got this written so I'm cheating a
little bit because I know what I'm
putting here but as bottom line is that
the calculator really is a bunch of form
elements such as buttons on the screen
but we're going to use CSS to reformat
them so it looks more like a traditional
calculator
um that's one of the the things that you
get comfortable working with when you're
doing web applications is how to take
technologies that you're used to using
and then modifying them so that they
look different and so in this instance
we're used to using button elements
within an application so why not use the
the same button Elements which
consistently work from browser to
browser
and then just simply update the look and
feel of them with some CSS so that they
they look good
and here we are just doing a very simple
on click command
um this is some basic JavaScript
that will render inside of the browser
itself
okay so now we see boom there's a button
all right so and again you want to be
constantly testing and verifying that
the code you're writing is working
correctly
um
and we're gonna do another button and
this is going to be the delete button
so we've got we're going to start
building out our different buttons here
so let's add delete
now we have an unclick event for that
foreign
just doing some formatting here
okay so we just used
going through our code here make sure
everything looks good
and one of the things we can now do
because we've got a baseline that looks
correct we can just copy that and then
we want the percentage sign and then the
forward bracket so this
so it gives us a two buttons so we have
a
start a new row here
I'm just going to copy everything over
just make it a little bit easier on
ourselves
and then we're just going to type in the
numbers
seven eight
nine
and then
plus symbol
sorry the multiply symbol
and we'll be able to move these into
multiple rows here in just a moment
foreign
[Music]
making all the changes here so we
actually fill out all the different
elements
so as you can see most of this isn't
really complex it's just the
uh I'm going to use the word fiddly yeah
I guess again the the fiddly parts of
putting this content together
so we refresh our screen we start seeing
all the different elements
okay but again
we'll have to come back and make some
updates
to our CSS class names
and then we do our final three buttons
across the bottom
[Music]
foreign
styles to the content that we've created
let me do that in our layout.css file
so we already have some styles that we
created so we're just going to go ahead
and for the
for the sake of brevity we're just gonna
pull those over
um
we can if you want to and have us do a
more detailed video on how to create the
CSC CSS files and
um you know yeah we'll certainly do that
but I think most you probably know how
to do this already
all right so here's our CSS file and so
we have our calculator Keys our buttons
and the different types of button here
so we can just copy these all over and
so these these will have the background
color the Border color
et cetera Etc and so we'll do that here
we have our
buttons
for our app
easy way you know how
okay so we take out the CSS then we just
have basic buttons we have the CSS link
back in
we have
nice laid out application
so we've got a couple of areas that are
still missing we've got the results
screen and the
uh default logo so
let's go ahead and add that information
in
create a new folder called assets from
the assets we'll put
another folder called font
and that'll be where our fonts will be
and then we'll create another folder
we'll call this one images
now I've got images in there
so we have our logo image just simply
learn logo
and then for layout we can then
reference that you know image reference
so I'm going to import the logo
I'm going to input that from
assets folder
and under assets we go to IMG which we
have our image and then we'll do the
path for the logo dot PNG
so remove this
and then we'll do source
and we'll do the sources from
uh logo variable which is the as the
import of the image
so I'll put the width
and we happen to know it's 150 pixels
and the
there we go 750 pixels wide
and the style that we'll reference from
CSS
will be
block
so just some inline styling here
generally normally do this I normally
have all my styling and my CSS folder
um but in this instance because we're
just pulling up a solution I want you to
be able to see that you can actually do
this in line so there we are our simply
land logo
okay so now we need to have the results
screen make sure that looks correct
foreign
new folder and this is going to be
called our output
.js file and this is going to control
the output of that blue screen
I'm going to put our react objects
foreign
that
[Music]
we will put a new file called output row
dot Js
so we'll put our instructions
this is going to be our component the
users will put their results into
okay
and I put row
and
put our instructions here so we're going
to like export
default
output row
foreign
together the code that allows us to
construct our solution and we're going
to update the output row.js file
and we're going to
add in our return value
so we'll put a div
and this will be
input type
so essentially we have a text field that
will be read only at the top of our
calculator and here we see our text
field here and that will allow us to be
able to
put in our values
and we use the class screen that allows
to go formatting
and we're going to put
a file it's going to be output road.css
we're adding a specific CSS
for this output row
and as you can see we're just using all
of our standard HTML5 skill sets here
we'll pull in
prob starts text size
and then the default value
and so this is going to align with our
go over to our CSS file and we'll update
that
output dot Js
we'll make sure the results get returned
correctly
as we're tapping on the buttons
and so this will probably not output row
and the value will be
let me put that text size for output
flow here
and we're just going to put some
sample CSS styling here
nothing too crazy
and we have two
rows
save that
and our two rows will appear in a moment
going to have layout
let's add in our rows
so this is our output from your
pull in those values
and there we have our two values
and so we can apply some CSS styling to
this
so the top row will be the calculation
broken out as we've written it in the
bottom row will be the results
and let's go into our CSS file here
we're going to copy over some CSS
and you have some
font styling
we have our screen class name
there's our screen here
again this is nothing no rocket science
here and if you've done any CSS
editing you'll be familiar with what
we've done here
and you see they're referring to a font
asset we don't actually have the font in
there we have to pull that font over now
and it's just a ttf font true type font
uh you can use and any of the internet
fonts as well Google has a massive
library of fonts
and there we are
going to change the size of our
font so that's the second row the text
is a little bit bigger
a little bit small and we don't have
anything wired up yet we'll do that in a
moment that'll be the
easy part of this assignment
all right so let's go over and
now layout
okay so next
input
set input
and use state
that way we can default the initial
state
for the result
the U state
the initially state would be just blank
there we go
just what you'd expect to see
instead of the results
um I think and this is just when you run
the app for the very first time
okay so we're going through
foreign
and now we want to put in our actions so
we're going to have an event when we
click on any of the buttons
we want to take the value of the button
and
so it's
you're going to be
any of these actions here
and we're just going to put together a
script to do the calculations
so as you can see so far we've put most
of this application most of the hard
work has been setting up the base react
application putting together the
different files and folder structure
making sure we have the correct assets
such as images
fonts uh CSS files
laying out core structure in HTML form
elements and now
um the part that we're doing at the end
here
is putting together the script that will
actually write
they'll actually do our calculator
uh events and and honestly and this is
going to be
um uh we've got this running here it's
just JavaScript so there are lots of
JavaScript calculators uh on the
internet so you can actually take any of
those and use those as a base
for what we're doing here
there we have it if there's an error
we'll do math error result
we don't expect to see that
and we'll just keep putting together our
code here
so I'll have different results
so depending on
um which commands you use so for
instance
obviously the equal sign and
we'll have the results
so we're using the value to actually
then trigger
what we would actually be
seeing in which screen
okay that's looking good
so we'll catch our value and
this is all concatenate together
and
if there are any error messages
so if the value is C from the button so
if we say c
but we want to set the input to zero
which is to reset the screen
foreign
[Music]
and this will be delete
what we want to do is we want to
manipulate the string on the screen
which means we're going to
eliminate
the last character entered
and this is
manipulation here
and this is all reducing the length of
the string by one character at a time
again this is your standard JavaScript
control
so I'm going to hit delete
and that gets rid of a character another
character hit it again I'll get rid of
the third character
and
put if the string is
zero then put
five of the value
is allows us to test out our application
all looking good so far
okay
I want to make sure that we're then
calculating our values correctly
and here we have the
display and the input
it's all coming from here our output
class
put in our results
okay it looks like we're letting lining
everything up just always want to go
back and double check that you have all
your commands all your variables lining
up correctly
eliminate those
and I'll make sure we have the answer
and the user into that
and we have the answer in the user and
we'll change the font size
you say that
we'll go over this is now this is our
local application
and we test it we can start putting
together our construct and we'll see
that our calculator is working so Claire
gets rid of both values
everything's looking pretty good
and here we have our first application
and this is the sample application
this is the application we just wrote
here is the original application that we
were testing against and as you can see
everything lines up correctly and so
you've seen how in just 45 minutes you
can actually write out your own
uh react.js application with node.js
and so we terminate the application
so this is the one we just built
it's going to fail so let's
allows us to validate but we had
actually created we'll restart the
services
say yes
I'm running on another porch because we
already have an app running and another
Port that says it's going to run on 3001
refreshing the web page
and voila there we are there's our
application up and running
everything looks really good working
fine
it works absolutely identically
now if you want to you could actually
then take this application and make it a
native application as well
now right now we're just using it as a
web application
and we're just updating some of the CSS
making it a little bit tighter
everything's looking exactly the same
there we go that's your app
all up and running welcome to the
session on react.js interview questions
through this session we will explore the
most commonly posed interview questions
that you would face if you walk up to a
developer interview on react.js let's
start with going through and exploring
the general set of react.js interview
questions that would be commonly asked
in an interview the first question would
be what are the features of react.js now
right through this session we would
follow a common methodology where we
would explore the question and then look
at the best way in which you could have
answered that question if posed to you
during a react.js interview so starting
with the first question what are the
features of react so react has many
extensions for complete application
architecture support jsx is used with
react to describe what the user
interface should typically look like
react is broken into small components so
you look at the complete application you
want to build break it down into
individual components and a component is
typically a piece of user interface like
a function that would return a stream of
HTML characters Speedy performance is
one of the core features of react as
only the updated components need to be
re-rendered on the screen and not the
entire page the one-way data binding
feature on the other hand keeps
everything modular and fast the virtual
Dom is also a lightweight representation
of the real Dom which is again a feature
which helps Speed Up Performance and
avoids a full page refresh in a full Dom
tree Shake which really speeds up
performance so what is jsx how do you
answer this so jsx is typically the
extension used for react and it's
nothing but an extension to the
JavaScript programming language because
all that you can use inside your browser
for execution typically has to be
JavaScript because in HTML5 you cannot
have have any third-party plugins
installed in the browser and that's the
reason the browser would only Ship by
default with a JavaScript Dimension so
by using jsx you can write HTML
structures in the same file that would
contain your JavaScript code as well
making the updates to the code very
simple so it's simple to update and make
modifications to your code because the
code and the data and the business logic
is all composed in a single file so
because the code and the business logic
is in a single file it makes updating
and incorporating change request to the
code very simple and easy so it's
basically used with react to describe
what your user interface should look
like and it's what you typically would
term as the HTML template or the view
coming to the next question can GSX be
directly read by the web browser so web
browsers cannot read jsx directly now
why is that well the reason is simple
it's because they are only Built To Read
regular JavaScript objects and GSX is
not a regular JavaScript objects it's a
react component so for a web browser to
read a jsx file the file needs to be
transformed into a regular JavaScript
object and for this there is a
JavaScript API called people which is
internally used by react so what do you
understand by the virtual Dom that we've
been speaking about in react so react
keeps a very lightweight representation
of the real Dom the actual Dom structure
of the page so Tom is document object
model it is an API created by w3c and it
creates an in-memory representation of
the HTML elements as a tree inverted
tree structure a balanced restructure
which is the fastest search algorithm
when you want to search for HTML
elements and do a dynamic update on them
but again updating the basic Dom tree
structure of the page causes a full page
refresh and if you only want to update a
specific component you wouldn't need the
entire page to be refreshed and that is
where react comes in it uses a virtual
on which is a layer on top of the actual
term which ensures that only a certain
part of the page is refreshed and that
speeds up performance so when the state
of an object changes virtual Dom changes
only that object in the real term
instead of updating all the objects and
this is what makes things very fast so
why use react instead of other
Frameworks like angular first of all
it's very easy to create Dynamic web
pages dhtml where you can update the
view of the template at runtime the
components are reusable so you reuse
rather than reinvent the performance is
great since you're working with the
virtual Dom you don't need a full page
refresh the unidirectional data flow
makes data move one way there is no
two-way data binding by default and
that's the reason the page does not have
to do a lot of heavy lifting of
remembering whether the view is changing
whether the base JavaScript entity class
is changing and that saves a lot of
processing time again to debug react is
much more simpler and that's what makes
it more popular in terms of its
Simplicity and speed as compared to
other Frameworks like angular what is
the difference between es5 and es6
standard so these are scripting
standards okay that are defined by the
European computer manufacturers
Association or ekma and all of the
scripting languages are a subset of the
standard and are derived from these
standards to ensure that the code will
execute on all browsers and the code
that we are writing is standards based
so these are a few instances where es6
syntax has changed from es5 if you look
at the es5 syntax at the top we're
creating a simple react class component
add the render function just returns a
stream of HTML content in ex6 there's a
new keyword that comes in which is
extends so you are extending from the
base react component and creating a
custom component and then returning a
stream of characters also the function
keyword no longer needs to be used so
the exports versus export also changes
so you use exports to export out plus
from a module so that it can be accessed
from another module in es6 you simply
say export and the component require
versus import so you would require a
third-party component or an API into
your Javascript file to use it in es6
it's replaced with the import statement
very similar to the syntax that we use
in code Java so how do you go and create
and create a reactor first you install
node.js as a base platform which you can
download from the node.js website next
any text editor of your choice could be
atom Visual Studio code or Sublime Text
third you create a react app using a
command prompt terminal depending on the
OS you are using the command to give is
create hyphen react space my first app
okay so the command that you would give
to create a new react app is create
hyphen react hyphen app space and the
name of the application you would want
to create in this case it is my iPhone
first hyphen app and that could be a
custom name of your choice so what is an
event in react well on the web when you
talk about Dynamic HTML it's all about
interacting with the user so the user
performs some interaction event with the
web page which could be a click of a
button a mouse move and these events in
action can be triggered by a user or any
system or could be pressing a key or a
mouse click Etc and in response to that
event you would execute a block of code
which is called an event handler so here
we have class simple which is a custom
class that extends the base react
component the name of the function work
which triggers a simple alert message
box and a render function which returns
HTML when you click on the button we
would want to bind that to the event
handler this dot work and that's how you
connect a click event to an event
handler function what are synthetic
events in react well a synthetic event
is an object which acts as a cross
browser wrapper around the browser's
native event it combines the behavior of
different browsers native events into
one API which makes sure that the events
are consistent across different browsers
and this brings in the standard space
development to ensure in this digital
age the code that we are creating for
different browsers have consistency in
terms of its execution so here we see a
function Action Link we see a function
handle click which takes e as an event
parameter e dot prevent default ensures
that there is no error that the browser
is Raising in case the event function
call is not directly compatible with
that specific browser so prevent default
is used to suppress any browser-specific
errors or crashes and a simple
console.log which will lock into the
developer tools window which says you
just clicked a link and then we've got
the return where we are returning the
view to or the HTML template where on
click we connect to this event handler
called handle click so handle click is
basically a wrapper and the entire
Action Link is a wrapper object which is
a synthetic event we don't directly go
and bind to the on click and then
associate a function with it we actually
associate a synthetic object with it
which binds the base default event that
could be specific to a browser so some
browsers would probably understand a
non-click sun another browser would
understand a click and and to ensure
there is consistency of syntax and from
a development perspective the code that
we write will run on all browsers we
need to take care of using the synthetic
events which isolate the developer out
from the complexity of writing code
specific to different browsers so you
just write generic code which will work
on different browsers so how do lists
work in react so the list display data
in an ordered format the traversal of
lists is done using the map function so
here we see there is a function called
list of names which takes a variable
props as a parameter props.names will
allow us to get a reference to all of
the array of names that are passed
constant List names is another variable
created equal to names dot map and we
are using the arrow operator which is
now an ecmascript standard and again we
are using the opening tag of the LI HTML
element the key is equal to the name
attribute so the brace bracket will find
find that to the name attribute then we
just print the name itself and we close
the LI tag so that's the names dot map
function and finally we return in an
unordered list the list names themselves
so the map function will run through an
iterate over the list of names list them
in the Ally tag the Ally tag will get
injected into the unordered list and
will finally get returned out as a
stream of HTML elements in the next code
snippet below we create a constant
variable names we are associating it
with a set of five names and we simply
say render list of names names equal to
names the moment we do that we are using
list of names as a custom HTML element
which is not system defined it starts
looking for the function list of names
passes the names array to it I trades
over it using the map function which is
an inbuilt react function brings out all
of the lists it's very similar to a
forward Loop that you would write for
iteration in other programming languages
and then finally what you get returned
in the get element by ID app is nothing
but a list of simple names wrapped in a
li element that are printed on The View
so why is there a need of using keys in
lists so keys are very important in the
code snippet that we saw due to the
following reasons the first reason the
key is a unique identifier if you would
want to search for a name in the list it
is used to identify which items have
changed updated or deleted from the list
so if you want to perform thread
operations on the data you would want to
search for which element do you want to
update or delete or change it also helps
to determine which components need to be
re-rendered instead of re-rendering all
the components every time and it
increases performance as only the
changed components have to be
re-rendered and not all the components
on the page what are forms in react so
using forms users can interact with the
application and enter required
information whenever needed so forms can
contain certain elements such as text
Fields buttons checkboxes radio buttons
Etc and forms are also used for many
different tasks such as user
authentication searching filtering Etc
how do you create a form pretty simple
again create a custom component called
name from that will extend
react.component we create a state
variable this dot state is equal to
Value we handle the change by writing a
handle change event and we handle the
submit by writing a handle submit event
in the change event we just change the
state by saying set state of the value
to
event.target.value event being a system
defined keyword past is a parameter and
in the submit we simply alert that a
certain name was entered and we trap the
value that was entered into the form
prevent default to suppress the browser
from Raising any errors on the render
function we return a form on the sub
submit we connect to the handle submit
event and we bind the data submitted
from the form to the handle submit event
and we pass the this pointer which is a
reference to the current context of the
view itself we open a label specify the
name we then specified input boxes text
the value is set to this dot state DOT
value and on change we simply connect to
the handle change event and bind to it
and pass the context of the text box
itself so the moment we change the value
in the text box as we are typing the
handle change event will receive the
updated value and set the state and when
we click on the submit button the handle
submit event handler executes and we
alert out the current value printed in
the text box and that's it so how do you
write commence in react when you are a
developer if you want to comment out
some code or if you want to set commands
to enhance the maintainability of the
code a single line comment is as simple
as given in most other programming
languages backslash astric to open
asterisk slash to close multi-line
comments follow the same syntax and can
span multiple lines to add commands to
functions in terms of what the function
can do and what are the types that it
can return what is the arrow function
and how is it used so an arrow function
is a shorter way of writing a function
in react if you look at the snippet on
the top my input on change equal to we
are connecting to this dot handle change
dot bind and that's the longer version
of how you can connect it to an event
handler the shorter version is on change
equal to e Arrow operator this dot
handle or change so you don't need to
call the bind explicitly you can replace
that with the arrow operate and reduce
the amount of code that you typically
write how is react different from react
native so react and react native are
completely different react was released
in 2013. it's a web-based platform it is
HTML compliant it generates HTML views
it uses CSS for styling and it's based
on JavaScript HTML and CSS react native
on the other hand is targeted to
Mobility devices it's meant to create
installable apps on Android and iOS
released in 2015 not based on HTML and
CSS and it basically requires the
react.js API to create these installable
apps for these Mobility ecosystems how
is react different from angular and
other popular framework by Google so
angular created by Google completely
based on the model view controller
pattern works on the real term layer and
requires a full tree shake at the Tom
layer to update views and components
supports bi-directional data binding the
rendering is purely done on the client
side the performance comparatively slow
react.js on the other hand created by
Facebook it's the view layer of the
model view controller pattern it works
with the virtual Dom layer and it sends
faster it's unidirectional data binding
and not two-way and the rendering is
typically what is done at the server
side and what you get is a response on
the client is a stream of HTML
characters as an output let's talk about
and discuss some questions around react
components so what are components in
react so these are the building blocks
you can think of them as Lego blocks so
you break your problem down into small
parts each part identifying a certain
solution of the problem which is what we
Define as a component so they are
building blocks of a react application
in a single app usually consists of
multiple components so it splits the UI
into independent reusable pieces that
can be processed separately a component
is essentially a piece of the user
interface or the HTML view what is the
use of render method in react so it is
compulsory for each component to have a
random method if not there wouldn't be
any HTML for the component to render on
your view so the render function Returns
the HTML which is to be displayed within
a component like you see on the screen
there is a class app that extends the
react component and it returns a simple
H1 element called hello simply learn and
of course to do remember to export the
app out so that it can be accessed from
other components as well if you need to
render more than one element all the
elements must be inside a single parent
tag like a div or a form what is state
in react the state of a component is an
object that holds some data within it
the data would influence the output of
the component now how do you implement
state in react so State holds the data
that a component renders on the web
application for example here we've
created in the Constructor this dot
State equal to and this temporary
Anonymous object has two attributes car
and by when we return We simply return
this dot state DOT car and this dot
state DOT by now this is how you would
create stateful components and access
the State Properties within the view how
do you update the state of a component
by using the built-in set State method
you can go ahead and update the state of
the component so here we have a simple
render function that Returns the state
itself state DOT message and on the on
click connects to a button press
function the moment you click on the
button the button press function sets
the state to another message so the
initial message in the Constructor is
welcome to Simply learn the moment you
click on the button the set State
triggers and changes it to best place to
learn so the data on The View would be
updated what are props in react well
props is just a short form for
properties and that is what allows us to
pass arguments or data to a component
drops a pass to components in the way
similar to that of attributes that are
passed to an HTML element so how do you
pass props between two components so
let's say we have an app.js component on
the top and a main.js component at the
bottom at the top we are trying to
return this dot drops dot car and the
pipe so two Car and Bike attributes
associated with this props of the app
component in the main component when you
look at the render function we are
associating car prop equal to a value of
1600 CC and bike prop equal to value of
one five zero CC and to access it if you
look at the import statement we are
importing app from app.jsx and this is
how you can cross access properties from
one component within the other so what
is the difference between State and
props well State holds information about
the components they are mutable they can
be changed they cannot be accessed by
child components and they cannot have
state props allow to pass data from one
component to the other as an argument
they are immutable they are read only
and props can be accessed by the child
component and they can have props as
well what is a higher order component in
react so these act as a container for
other components which helps in keeping
components simple and induces the
reusability factor they are generally
used when a common logic has to be used
by multiple components that's when you
group together a set of components
within a higher order component in react
how can you embed two or more components
into one this code snippet demonstrates
the app component which returns a hello
text and it has a custom tag called
Simple the simple tag is defined in the
component below and it returns text
called simply learn and in the render of
the react Dom we simply go and render
the app component so hello simply
learned would be the final output and
that's how you can embed one component
into the other using this methodology
what are the differences between class
and functional components so stateful
components would extend react component
in this case and if you could look at
the render it simply renders this dot
props dot title the constant stateless
component would be equal to props the
div tag returns this dot props dot title
so you can look at the style very
different in terms of class and
functional components one using the
arrow operator one using the traditional
class and vendor method so the classical
component can hold or manage State
complex as compared to stateless
components can work all of the life
cycle methods of the component and it
can be reused the functional component
cannot hold a managed State they are
simple and easy to understand it does
not work with any lifecycle method and
it cannot be reused let's explain the
life cycle methods of components we've
got kenish initial state which is
executed before the creation of the
component component did Mount which is
executed when the component gets
rendered and placed on the Dom should
component update which is invoked when a
component decides any changes to the
term and returns true or false value
based on certain conditions component
did update it is invoked immediately
after the rendering takes place
component will unmount which is invoked
immediately before a component is
destroyed and unmounted permanently
let's move to the react Redux set of
questions so what is Redux it's an open
source JavaScript library used to manage
application State and react uses Redux
for building the user interface what are
components of Redux the first is the
store which holds the state of the
application store contains state which
defines the user interface which
triggers a set of actions which are then
sent to the reducer so store holds the
state action is the source information
for the store and reducer specifies how
the application State changes in
response to actions sent to the store
what is flux well flux is the
application architecture that Facebook
uses for building web applications and
it works in this way the action is
triggered which is sent to the
dispatcher the dispatcher sends it to
the store the store sends it to the view
and the view sends it back to the action
and that's exactly how the steps would
continue in sequence so when we trigger
an action the dispatcher will get
notified once the dispatcher has dealt
with an action the stores listening to
it will get triggered the view gets
updated when the state of the store
changes you user action at the view is
sent to the dispatcher to then be
processed how is Redux different from
flux Redux is an open source JavaScript
library used to manage applications
State the store state is immutable it
can only have a single store and it uses
the concept of reducer flux on the other
hand is an architecture and not a
framework or Library the store state is
mutable it can have multiple stores and
it uses the concept of dispatcher let's
look at some react router questions what
is a react router a react router is a
package which is used to create routing
in a react application react router is
used for developing single page web
applications it allows multiple views in
a single application by defining
multiple routes in that react
application how is react routing
different from conventional routing
react routing has a single HTML page it
uses all the end user rather would
navigate multiple views within the same
file called a single page app the page
does not refresh since it's a single
page file and there is improved
performance since you're not navigating
across multiple Pages conventional
routing each view is a separate HTML
file a user would navigate multiple
files for each view the page would
refresh every time the user navigates
which would hence result in slower
performance how do you implement react
routing you can Implement react routing
using a very simple method considering
the above components let's say you've
got a component called app about and
contact so here you can specify the
route path if the route path is just
slash the root defaults route it takes
you to the app component if the route is
slash about in the URL given by the end
user you automatically navigate and
activate and load the about component
and if the URL is slash contact fact it
would take you to the contact report
let's talk about react styling questions
style react components either you use
inline styling by using simple CSS by
simply saying color blue and that's
going to be the output of the H1 element
or I could use a JavaScript object by
specifying a constant simple style
object and specifying a keypad value of
color background color margin font
family and apply that object as the
style parameter which would result in
this styled output how do you style
react components using a CSS style sheet
so here's an external style sheet so
we've written all the styling rules in a
separate CSS file app.css we've imported
that at the top of the app.js react
class and lo and behold you have the
output simplified as generated on your
page let's explain the use of CSS
modules in react so a CSS module file is
created dot module dot CSS is the
extension the CSS inside a module file
is available only for the component that
is importing it so there are no naming
conflicts so dot button is the CSS
styling inside button Dot module.css and
that is what we've imported from in the
app.js file so when you view the button
Styles dot button is the styling picked
up from the button dot module.css file
so what exactly is node.js now consider
a scenario where a user interacts with
the web application the user only
interacts with the front end of the
application but there's a lot of work
that goes behind the scenes now in a web
application there's a front end a server
and a database the front end is
developed using JavaScript and
Frameworks like angular and react while
the server is built on Java PHP or
node.js and the backend database that
stores the data usually consists of
MySQL or mongodb so node.js is an open
source cross-platform JavaScript runtime
environment for running server-side
applications it is used to develop i o
intensive web applications like video
streaming sites single page applications
online chatting applications and other
web apps applications it is used by
large established companies and newly
minted startups node.js was developed by
Ryan Dal in 2009 and at the same time of
this session its latest version is V
13.3.0 now that we know what node.js is
let's go ahead and look at why it was so
prevalent in the field of web
development here are a few points first
up node.js is extremely fast being built
on Google Chrome's V8 JavaScript engine
its library is extremely fast in code
execution node package manager has
around 50 000 bundles for developers so
whatever functionality is required for
an application can be easily imported
from npm all apis of node.js Library are
asynchronous that is non-blocking it
means a node.js based server never waits
for an API to return data node.js
dramatically reduces the processing time
while uploading video and audio files it
is also an open source platform and is
easy for beginners for web development
the above reasons more than justify the
popularity of node.js platform and why
it is being adopted by large number of
organizations and businesses today so
now moving on let's familiarize
ourselves with the parts of node.js
node.js consists of several components
now let's look at them one by one first
up we have modules now modules are like
JavaScript libraries which are used in a
node.js application to include a set of
functions now we can use required
function with the parenthesis to include
a module in a node.js application
node.js application has many modules to
provide basic functionality needed for a
web application some of them could be
HTTP util FS URL query string stream and
zlib next up we have console the console
module provides a simple debugging
console that is similar to the
JavaScript console mechanism provided by
web browsers now the console can print
messages to STD out that print standard
output messages and SCD air to print the
error messages the next component is
cluster now node.js is built upon the
concept of single threading programming
a single instance of node.js runs in a
single thread to take advantage of
multi-core systems the user will
sometimes want to launch a cluster of
node.js processes to handle the load a
cluster can be added to an application
in this way here's a small code for you
the next component is global now global
objects in node.js are available in all
modules now these objects are functions
modules strings Etc some node.js Global
objects are mentioned in the table you
have dir name that is a directory name
file name exports module and require the
next component is error handling now
node.js applications experience four
types of Errors we have the standard
JavaScript errors system errors user
specific errors and assertion errors now
errors in node.js are handled through
exceptions now for example let's handle
an error that would occur when we divide
a number by zero now this error would
crash the node.js application and so we
should handle this error here's a small
code for you next up we have streaming a
stream is an abstract interface for
working with streaming data in node.js
streams are objects that let you read
data or write data continuously there
are four types of streams first one is a
readable these are these types of
streams from which data can be read
writeable these are the types of streams
to which data can be written duplex
these are both readable and writable
streams lastly we have transformed these
streams can manipulate the data while it
is being read or written moving on to
the next component buffer the JavaScript
language has no mechanism for reading or
manipulating streams of binary data
buffer is a module that allows handling
streams that contain only binary data an
empty buffer of length 10 can be created
by this method next up we have domain
domains provide a way to handle
different i o operations as a single
group domain module intercepts errors
that remain unhandled there are two
types of methods that are used for
intercepting these errors firstly we
have enter internal binding in this case
the error emitter executes its code
inside the arrow method next up is the
external binding now here the error
emitter is explicitly added to a domain
via its add method the next component is
the DNS the DNS module enables name
resolution for example it is used to
look up the IP addresses of host names
DNS module is used to connect to a DNS
server and perform neem resolution by
using the method dns.resolve the DNS
module is also used for performing name
resolution without a network
communication by using the method
dns.lookup the next component is a
debugger node.js includes an out of
process debugging utility accessible via
a V8 inspector and built-in debugging
client this node.js debugger is not
feature packed but supports simple
inspection of code it can be used in the
terminal by using the inspect keyword
before the name of the Javascript file
in order to inspect a file say
myscript.js you can use the following
method now that we are familiar with all
the major parts of node.js let's go
ahead and learn about the node.js
Express framework Express is a flexible
node.js web application framework that
provides a wide set of features to
develop both web and mobile applications
you can assume Express as a layer built
on top of the node.js that helps manage
the server and The Roots now let's have
a quick look at some of the core
features of Express framework it is used
to design single page multi-page and
hybrid web applications it allows
setting up of middleware to respond to
http requests it defines a routing table
that is used to perform different
actions based on the HTTP method and URL
it also allows Dynamic rendering of HTML
Pages based on passing arguments to
templates now moving on let's take a
quick example of a simple hello world
program now this is developed using
Express framework to gain a better
understanding alright first up we have
the WHERE Express now this is used to
import Express framework into our
node.js application now the app.get
method is a callback function with
parameters request and response the
request object represents the HTTP
request and has properties for the
request query string parameters body
HTTP headers Etc the response object
represents the HTTP response that an
Express app sends when it gets an HTTP
request now the application will listen
to the defined Port which in this case
is 8081 and variables host and Port will
contain the address and the port
respectively lastly we have the
console.log which is used to show the
address and port in the command prompt
so this is what the command prompt would
look like and finally the output is
displayed on the web browser Having
learned about the Express framework now
let's move on and look at the node.js
use cases now it is no doubt that node
stands out for its speed and intensive
data exchange so top industry leaders
like NASA PayPal Netflix among others
incorporate node.js first up we have
Netflix the world's leading internet
television network with over 117 million
users is one of the top companies that
trusted their server services to node.js
the reasons why the company chose to use
node.js for application scalability and
data intensive application now you must
be wondering what application
scalability is with basically the
potential of an application to grow in
time being able to efficiently handle
more and more requests per minute and
data intensive application allows
millions of people to stream Netflix
simultaneously next up is Walmart now
Walmart is the world's largest company
by Revenue with around 514 billion US
Dollars according to the fortune Global
500 list in 2019. again the reasons why
the company chose node.js were
asynchronous IO and efficient handling
of concurrent requests now asynchronous
IO which is a form of input output
processing allows other processing to
continue before the transmission has
finished node.js is able to efficiently
handle concurrent requests with the use
of thread pool and event cues Uber Uber
is an American multinational ride
hailing company offering services that
include peer-to-peer ride sharing right
service healing and food delivery the
reasons why the company chose node.js
were asynchronous i o quick iterations
and active open source Community as
mentioned earlier asynchronous IO
permits other processing to continue
before the transmission has finished now
quick iterations now node.js is
continually being updated and added new
features that help in further
Improvement in the performance of web
servers and finally active open source
Community resolves many problems that an
organization May face in a particular
scenario next up we have NASA now NASA
as an independent agency of the United
States federal government responsible
for the civilian space program as well
as Aeronautics and Aerospace research
the reasons why the company chose
node.js were reduced access times
handling of data intensive tasks and the
fact that the servers are active 24 7.
now NASA has lots and lots of data and
using node.js has really helped them in
reducing the access times it is also
continuously handling and working with
large streams of data node.js is highly
stable which helps in keeping the server
active 24 7. next up we have PayPal now
PayPal is an American company operating
a worldwide online payment system that
supports online money transfers as
opposed to traditional methods like
checks and money orders the reasons why
the company chose to use node.js were
the fact that node.js has extremely fast
build times it allows tasks to be
carried out with fewer lines of code
when compared to other server
Technologies like Java and PHP and
node.js being data intensive efficiently
handles a large amount of data next up
is medium medium is a popular online
publishing platform developed by Evan
Williams and launched in August 2012.
the main reasons why the company chose
to use node.js were a data driven
applications now these applications are
ideal for being interfaced with node.js
servers B to run a b tests now A B
testing is essentially an experiment
where two or more variants of a page are
shown to users at random and statistical
analysis is used to determine which
variation performs better lastly node.js
server maintenance is simpler than its
counterparts moving on to the last topic
of this session industry Trends now
node.js developers are in demand across
the globe since many companies are
adopting JavaScript libraries according
to Forbes it is one of the top 10 most
in-demand jobs according to node Source
the total number of node.js downloads
increase by 40 in the last one year the
use of node.js in production has
increased dramatically since its release
in 2010. with early adopters such as
LinkedIn PayPal and Netflix among others
node.js has seen an exponential increase
in its use in web development the
popularity of node.js is also accounted
to JavaScript now since JavaScript is
the most popular language as evident
from a survey conducted by stack
Overflow in 2019 many developers can
start working on node.js library with
not much of a learning curve node.js
developers are being offered better
salary options than another web
technology developers according to pay
scale the average salary of a node.js
developer in India is around 6 lakhs 13
000 rupees per year the average salary
of a node.js developer across the United
States is around 105 000 US dollars per
year in this video we'll help you
install node.js on your Windows system
so without further Ado let's begin the
first thing you need to do is download
node.js from their official website so
go ahead and type download node.js
navigate to their official website and
here
you can see the 64-bit version so go
ahead and download that once the
download is done go ahead and run the
downloaded node.js installer
accept the license agreement keep the
default settings as it is
and then say install
so with that we finish the installation
process
once node has been successfully
installed the next crucial step is
verification now this process ensures
that node has been properly installed to
do so we first open the command prompt
and then type in a few commands to
verify the successful installation we
type in this command
node hyphen V now this command Returns
the version and if it Returns the
version it means it has been
successfully installed
so here we go it Returns the latest
version
now the final step is to update the node
package manager now this npm is bundled
with node.js which consists of all the
repositories and packages required for
development purposes so to do that type
in the command npm
install npm
hyphen hyphen Global now that we're done
with the installation of node let's go
ahead and Implement a small program for
that we make use of a text editor in our
case we've installed vs code so go ahead
and download vs code once you're done
with the installation this is what vs
code looks like so go ahead and click on
file and create a new file it's going to
be a simple program where you're going
to print a hello world message on the
web browser to do that we make use of
HTTP modules so node comes with built-in
HTTP modules to transfer data across it
so for that we make use of a require
method we create a variable first say
where
HTTP equals require
and just say HTTP within single quotes
now the HTTP module can create an HTTP
server that listens to the server ports
and gives a response back to the client
to do that we make use of the create
server method so let's go ahead and type
the code
say http
dot create
server and in turn Elite consists of a
function now the parameters of this
function are request and response now
the response is basically used to write
to the client so we say response dot
write and here we type in the message
say hello world
welcome
to this tutorial
once you're done with that you end the
response
so the server listens to a port number
to display the message by default it
listens to the port number 8080 so we
keep that as it is and we end it save
your file
say demo.js maybe demo1.js and JC now to
run the program you have to open the
command prompt so open your command
prompt
and mention the path to your file so in
our case it's our desktop saved on the
desktop so CD
desktop and now to run it say node
demo one dot JS now we navigate to your
browser
and say localhost 8080 and here we go
our message is successfully displayed so
let's talk about the node.js
architecture and understand why it's so
good
so to begin with uh node.js has what's
called a single threaded event Loop
architecture and this allows you to be
able to handle many many and current
clients at the same time it's just a
very flexible way of being able to scale
up your support for many clients
and then in addition to that we have the
JavaScript event based model along with
the JavaScript callback mechanism that
allows you to have this standard
approach to being able to connect with
and talk and discuss interactions
between the client and the server it's
good to have these kind of Standards
where you're not using something that's
unique to a specific framework or a
specific technology and this just makes
it so it's a more accessible for
everybody
so if we look at the actual node.js
server itself everything centers around
the the concept of the event Loop and
the event Loop has a a an event queue an
operation completed um fire request
threaded pull and then it'll actually do
the actual computation or the file
system interaction
all of this interconnects in a nice
seamless Loop the great thing again with
node.js is that it's not new technology
it's been around for almost a decade
it's very very well tried out many of
the largest websites out there are runny
node.js
so let's now dig into each of the parts
of the node.js architecture so let's
talk about requests
so the way that the request works is
that you have your framework uh such as
angular on the client and that will then
send a request to the web server there's
many ways that those requests can happen
through web workers through forms and
through other interactions but at some
point a request is sent to the server
and so these requests can be for data it
can be for deleting data they can be for
updating data they can be for
interacting with Services as mentioned
before but the goal is to have some kind
of request now once that request
actually hits the server and then we
start actually getting into the queuing
and threading process that centers
around the event Loop and this is where
node.js really excels because it's able
to use that single threaded model to be
able to manage from just even a few
requests to tens of millions of requests
so it receives the actual request and
starts the event here and this is where
that single threading process starts is
by queuing everything up appropriately
and then it then maintains the thread
within a pool so you have the queuing
process as one action and then you have
a threaded pull which manages those
threads as well
and then we have an event Loop which you
know goes through and actually receives
and processes those requests
and then finally what we're doing is
we're actually then going to be
interacting with a system and they could
be a database it could be a cloud system
it could be an API file system but we're
interacting with something that's
outside of the node.js server so the
node.js server itself is doing some
actions on the server but then it's also
interact with things outside of its own
server environment
and so this talk a little bit about that
workflow so requests come in they go
into the event queue and they get
spiraled through the event Loop and then
we have a non-blocking operators which
are going to be doing the input output
polling such as KQ e-poll and other
services and from there we're also going
to be then interacting with a threaded
pool and we're using the blocking
operations to manage that threaded pull
and that threaded pull is going to now
then go outside of the server and
interact with something beyond the
server so whether that is a database or
file system or API or microservice these
are things that can be interacted with
so let's go through what npm is so npm
itself stands for the node package
manager no great shakes there as the
name says it's responsible for all the
packages and modules that are bundled
Within node.js
so the notepad manager itself really has
two key functionalities now the first is
that reply it is a central repository
for all packages and modules which you
can then search through um online you
can go to
search.nodejs.org and you can find all
of the package of modules that are out
there the second is that it's also a
command line or terminal line utility
that allows you to install those
packages so you can actually go through
and you can see the version management
and dependencies that within those
packages and you can actually can
control the packages themselves
so why would you use npm
so npm is really useful for being able
to extend the project you're working on
so when you're building out a project
one of the concepts I like to use is the
concept of Lego bricks
um big fan of Lego and uh what's great
about Lego bricks is that they're all
individually by themselves very small
very specific functionality but if you
actually get a whole collection of Lego
bricks together you can build like crazy
cool things so think of when you're
working with the node package manager
itself is that each of those individual
pieces that you're working with each of
those individual packages are their own
Lego bricks and by themselves you can
then edit and update and maintain that
piece separately from the whole
environment as long as your inputs and
outputs they have really the piece where
you snap the Lego in or when you connect
the Lego to something else are
interacted and open and well documented
then you can actually then use those
modules effectively throughout your
project
um so you can actually then be able to
do that you can do Version Control on
your codes and dependencies you can do
testing very easily
and then once you actually get to the
point where you go yes I want to release
um a new module you can do that
effectively using npm and it will
actually go through and do the actual
deployment for you
so let's go through the npm installation
so the actual package manager itself is
included with the installation of
node.js so if you've installed and
you're running node.js locally then
you've already installed the package
manager but you can also access it
through command line or terminal window
on your data server or in your server or
via the cloud
uh if you haven't now downloaded node.js
uh here's the website where you can go
down to install it and there's Windows
and Mac versions of that code as well
with the installers which allow you to
get up and going very quickly
you want to be able to run the installer
and accept all the default settings uh
just uh you know to begin with you want
to kind of have the standard setup so
that you are most familiar with the
normal settings before you start getting
to the point where you're a master and
you're tweaking things
um there is a way that you can open up
the command window or The Terminal
window and once you've actually
installed node.js to verify that it's
actually installed you can write the
command node dash dash version and
they'll actually then pull out the
version of node.js that you have
installed and then you'll be able to see
that you've got it actually up and
running
and then you can also do the same thing
for npm where you can do npm version and
it actually will then show you which
version of the node package manager you
have running so you can actually take it
full advantage of that program and
verify that it's actually up and running
so let's actually look inside of a
package so packages themselves are
actually just Json files if you're new
to this space Json file is a structured
file format that's based on JavaScript
it's a very XML like format for being
able to write instructions for the
actual package itself and so the Json
file forms that you know really kind of
the the heart of each package you create
um it has all of the metadata that you'd
have about a particular object and then
it provides a route directory to any of
the applications or modules that the
package may be referencing
um in addition
um it has any other additional um
information about the project that adds
such as dependencies and other files
that need to be included so here we have
is an example of a package and that
would be created using npm json's um
script
and you can actually take this package
file as it is right here and use the
command npm in it and it'll actually run
this package and so you would actually
then have a demo application up and
running really quickly
uh you can then go ahead if you want so
you can edit any of these parameters so
like for instance if you wanted to
change the description or the version uh
or what is the the main index script
that would be written you know these are
all things that you can edit very
quickly and easily you can just use text
editor to make any of these edits
and so we have the different metadata
that can be updated
and so this is where we go in and do a
full demo of working with npm
so what we're going to do now is we're
actually going to go ahead and actually
run a demo of using npm and to do that
I've got three windows in front of me
right now so I have this window here
which is my terminal window where I'll
be doing all of my instructions uh then
I also have a folder which shows where
I'll be putting all of the files and
then finally I'll actually have a text
editor in this case I'm using vs code
because it's free but you can use any
text edit you like to be able to go in
and show what the code that has been
created by npm in the Json file so you
can actually see what it looks like and
then we'll modify it a little bit so
first thing we want to do is we want to
go ahead and create a new project folder
so I'm going to go in I'm just going to
move into let's do
change directory I'm going to the
project folder and we'll see down here
that we have an empty project folder but
for this one I'm actually going to go
ahead and create a new directory in this
one and I'm going to call this one
simply learn
and there we are we've created a new
simply lamb folder
and we are going to move into the
sympathy lab folder
and so we're now in the simply land
folder uh there's nothing in there right
now um so the first thing we want to do
is we want to take uh go ahead and
initialize this folder as a project
folder for working with npm now to do
this you will have to have already
installed npm if you have node.js npm
comes with it and if you want to see
whether or not you have npm installed so
you can just do npm
Dash version
and that will actually tell you what the
version of npm you have installed is it
also verifies that npm is installed so
I've gone ahead and I've been able to
validate that I have npm installed so
what I'm now going to go ahead and do is
I'm going to initialize this folder so
to do that just do npm init and you'll
see that the path is that we're already
in the simply learn folder and then when
you do that
it's going to ask you some questions so
what is the package name we're going to
go with the defaults for right now and
then I can show you how we can edit
those in a little bit uh we're going to
go with just say yes to all of these
just by hitting return
and you'll see here that we're going to
create a new folder called a
package.json folder this is the
instructions that we have in the folder
do you want to go ahead and create this
we want to and it's going to go ahead
and do that and we can see now in our
folder here that we actually have
package.json so if I go ahead and open
this up with
vs code here we are we can actually see
what all the information is we can go
ahead and we can actually go and update
uh this metadata if we want to I'm going
to leave it as is for right now because
I want to show you a couple of other
things so a lot of times when you're
actually working with npm and the reason
why you're using npm is that you want to
take advantage of packages that are
freely available in the open source
community that are supported by node.js
and one of those is a package called
Express and express is a lightweight
framework for building out web
applications similar concept to angular
or react.js I like using it and it's
also a great way to be able to show how
we can install this using npm so to
install this you just start with the
command npm and then you type in store
and then we type the name of the package
and we hit
enter and it goes ahead and what you'll
actually see
is a couple of things one is we have a
dependency in our package above we also
have so this is in our Json package that
it's now dependency it's written in
there we can also go in and under our
node modules we actually see that we
have let me scroll down we should see
Express
there it is Express
now if we decide that we don't want to
use um Express we can actually just come
in and we can write command npm
uninstall
I can type
Sprites
Oops I did a typo there so let's try
that again npm
uninstall
Express
and couple things can happen one is in
our Json file the dependency for the
express file has now been removed
and we can also see that under um node
modules there are no extensions there
so this is kind of cool this allows us
to be able to see that we can easily add
and remove packages so let's just go
ahead and I'm going to install Express
again sir install Express
oops npm install Express
all right so let's go ahead and it's
installed Express
now one of the things that'll often
happen is that when you're working with
a package the actual Json package so
you'll receive this file and you want to
be able to go ahead and install of the
sub modules that come with it so and you
can go through and you can manually
install them like this or you can
actually run and install command so you
can actually install all of them at once
I can just show you what that looks like
because we're going to actually go ahead
and simulate as if we're going to
install bootstrap
which is another
popular framework
straight and we're actually going to go
with
and then we'll save that
and what we'll see is under the packages
that bootstrap isn't listed in there we
do have Express there it is right there
so we now come over to our new commands
we can actually write the command
npm install
and now
site typo let's try that again
let's do npm
install
okay it does help to save your file so
let's go ahead and let's run npm install
and when you do that what we'll now
actually have is not just
Express but we'll also see that
bootstrap has also been added
now I don't recommend that you use the
star symbol which will install the
latest version of bootstrap because you
obviously haven't tested your
application against that but it gives
you an idea of and of what's happened
here now if we want to we can actually
go in here and we can see on in
install
bootstrap
and it will actually remove that from
your Json package so there we are that's
how you work with using npm from getting
started with a setup for a base
initialization of your package going
through to creating the first package
being able to set up and control the
naming convention for each of the items
within the metadata that provides the
instruction for the package how you can
then put in dependencies such as Express
and bootstrap how you can install them
and remove them and actually use do all
of this through command line if you have
any questions please let us know
so this kind of jump into the express.js
framework
so express.js is a really flexible
node.js and web application framework it
is just something you can spin up very
quickly and build both web and mobile
applications just a really great tool um
you know I use it all the time for
building up my own applications
the thing that's so great about it is
it's really simple and so and it's not
going to be as have all the the
functionality that you'd have in maybe a
larger scale HTTP service but with that
said it does come with a lot of
functionality that allows you to not
only create websites but you can also do
apis and other routing calls very very
nice
so let's go through some of the features
that expressjs have
so as I mentioned before it allows you
to build simple web applications and
they can be either a single page
application or a multi-page application
it also allows you to do middleware
requests and responses so for instance
if you want to do an API and have that
be part of your middleware you can
actually set that up real quickly in
fact in the demo that we'll do later on
we'll actually be building out four
different API calls that you'll be able
to do and you'll be able to see how you
can use express.js for that and that in
then turns allows you to be able to see
how express.js can help manage some of
the routing of the different HTTP
methods and that you'd be using via URL
and then finally it's just a great way
of being able to dynamically test the
work that you are developing so you can
actually build out a solution and test
it right away and express.js have it in
a single packet and then once you get to
a certain point you can then check in
the whole packet and even have it as
part of your container and then check
that into your main project and then if
somebody else wants to then take on the
work they can then just pull that in so
let's kind of go step through a you know
a basic example so here we actually have
a full script for creating a simple
hello world and this includes installing
express.js defining the ports it's going
to run on as well as a basic piece of
code so the first thing you want to do
is actually go ahead and Define how you
want to install express.js and this is
called the very first variable which is
requiring that Express be installed as
part of node packet manager npm will
then pull in the latest version of
Express if you need to define a specific
version of course you can do that in
this example we're just going to pull
the latest one and then we'll go ahead
and with the second line which will then
install Express and when you do it once
you'll see how quickly it stores onto
your local development machine
the next parameters are actually a
callback function so if something
actually happens when you go to the
website where we're going to run our web
application you want something to pop up
and in this instance we'll say hello
world will pop up
the third block is all about where you
would actually go ahead and host your
code and so in this one you'll see that
the server is going to listen and listen
to Port 8081 so that's what that
function actually there defines
and then you can either put in uh the
specific host address in the demo you'll
actually see how we Define that for
localhost but you can actually then
point this to a production host
environment if you want
and then the final line here is a
command that actually sent a script to
your terminal window telling you that
which port and which host that you are
listening to so let's see what that
would look like so here we can see have
our terminal window and we're actually
able to then run the hello world JS
script that we just wrote and then once
we do that it'll actually then post that
we have an example app listening ads and
here we don't have a web domain address
and we do have the the port 8081
and in our browse window it says hello
world
so that's a quick breakdown of
express.js now let's jump over and do a
demo
so the first thing we want to do to get
Express up and running on our system is
we have to have node.json sword so we're
just going to do a Google search to let
you know where you can find node.js it's
actually at
nodejs.org so we select that link that
will take us to nodejs.org and there are
two types of downloads one is the
current download which has the latest
features and then there's a more stable
version that if you are new to node.js
I'd recommend you to download next we
want to find a text editor and we're
going to go with Visual Studio code or
vs code AS known it's an open source
solution from Microsoft that runs across
all the leading platforms so this will
default to our Windows platform but you
can run it on Mac OS and Linux as well I
really like it it's a great code it
comes a lot of extensions and it's open
source
and next thing you want to do is because
we're going to be developing apis we
want a way to be able to visualize those
apis quickly and a great tool is a
product called Postman again open source
and so you can go out and go to
postman.com top right hand corner you'll
see a bright orange download button
where you can actually go and head and
download and install Postman and that
will allow you to be able to access all
of your apis that we're going to be
creating in Express
you can actually use other tools such as
apigee as well for visualizing your apis
but this one's just great to get you
started so let's go ahead and open up vs
code and we want to go ahead and open a
new folder where we're going to have our
project we're going to just for our
demonstration here we're going to put
this on the desktop you wouldn't
normally do this but it will work fine
here we're going to create a folder
we're going to title the file the node
Express and we'll select that folder and
that now becomes the root folder for our
project in Visual Studio we don't really
need the the welcome screen anymore so
we're going to get rid of that
and one of the things that is great
about working with vs code is you can
actually have the terminal window up and
running as well so let's go ahead and
open that so it's running at the bottom
of our screen and this gives us a little
bit of space
and the first thing we want to do is
actually turn convert the folder we're
in actually into a project running
node.js so we're going to use npm in it
and they'll actually initialize the
project we have another video that
explains how to use npm or node package
manager and you can go ahead and find
that um in our library here but as we go
ahead and we do that you'll actually see
that it will create the default package
Json file which has the name of the
folder is the default name of the
package but you can actually go in and
edit any of these documents
we want to create a default file as
called index.js This is where we're
going to write most of our scripts that
allow us to work with node.js
and the first is writing a script that
allows us to install Express and we'll
use the node packet manager to actually
pull and install Express and you can
fault to specific versions of Express if
you want and we're just going to go with
the latest one so we're just going to
put in Express and then we'll go down
into terminal window and say npm install
dash dash save Express and this will
install Express so we can actually test
out the code we're working on
and this is like just a moment to
install
great thing we're working with node
package manager is that once we've
finished with our package here we can
actually wrap it all up and send it over
to any other developer that we're
working with and they can actually run
the the package and actually have
exactly the same code installed
and there we are we have everything
installed and ready to go
we can see we actually have all of the
modules installed you'll see that we
actually have Express installed as well
and we also want to then make this an
app
and then we'll do app listen
to Ports 3000 so this is by default
we're going to be running from our Local
Host which is uh HTTP server running on
this test machine and we're going to
have Express for this project run on
Port 3000.
and in the once we actually run the
script we'll actually post into the
console
um window a piece of text saying server
started on Port 3000.
so we're going to go ahead and save this
file
a little control s to save these files
so let's go into localhost in our web
browser so localhost colon sorry uh yeah
it's localhost column 3000 and you'll
see nothing has been reached that's
because we actually haven't done
anything to initialize the script so we
want to come in and we're going to go
node index.js and hit return and as you
can see now we have a message in our
console window that means that yep there
we go we actually have everything up and
running so we can actually see that the
service is running not a very pleasant
message so let's go ahead and change
that
so let's change that to
app get
and
acquire res
and so I've used the get message that's
change what we'll print
and we'll type hello there
exclamation mark
and we save that
and we refresh the screen
oh nothing happened again because we
didn't run the script so let's go back
in and we'll run the script node
index.js
and now what you'll see is if we refresh
there we are we have our new hello there
message
all right well let's actually start
building some apis in this environment
so to be able to build the apis we want
to be able to pull content so we can
actually create a new file called
users.js and we're going to create
I'm going to go ahead and create a a
user's Json packet and a Json packet is
essentially
a an array and as you consider it like a
small database and in this array we're
going to have four objects each object
is going to have three pieces of
metadata we have an ID name and email
and there'll be ID 1 2 and 3 and then
you'll see that the names will be John
Smith and we'll make up a couple of
others I'm just kind of giving them
arbitrary email addresses
it's just for our demo here
let me grab this copy it and kind of
speed up
the script writing time
there we go
and let's just change what we need and
one of the things that's nice with
working with the visual studio code vs
code is there's lots of plugins and so
one of the default features is that if
you select a variable it'll actually
look for the same variable in the script
so you can if you need to you can
actually change them all in once
but we don't need to worry about that
right now we're just creating a Json
packet so we have four items
ID one two three and four for John Smith
and Jack and Chris
all right so that's our
erased string and we're going to then
make sure that we can export that as
users so we can actually now whenever we
select the term users in our scripts
you'll actually pull in this packet
all right looking good
now let's go over to our main index.js
file and we're actually going to go
ahead and we want to like Store where
the the API is going to be so we're
going to create a photocore route and
then a subfolder called API
and then we'll call a file in there
called users.js so as we're updating our
scripts we know where to
pull the data from
it's just a standard way of being able
to pull out the values so in here we're
going to say in this instance Express is
required
for our Scripts
and we're going to also say that from
router
within Express router
correct naming convention
and the script is case sensitive we'll
also want to create a value later on
that will have a unique ID so we're
actually going to pull in a uuid
package that will actually then allow us
to install unique identifiers so we use
node package manager to install uuid
again this is a great example of how you
can go from nothing to something very
quickly with Express
node.js because we've installed Express
we installed uuid and we're off to races
so that's have users require the path
for where our API is going to be located
all right so let's do a basic get which
will be to pull the record so we're
going to have it pull all the records so
router.get and we're going to require it
to pull all of the records in the Json
packet that we created
so there should be four items to come
back
save that
looks good
make sure that users is consistent
there's our Json packet
and yep everything's looking pretty good
all right let's go back to index
and we're going to switch out this
function here from just a generic get
with a generic statement to actually
being able to pull in the users so let's
go app
use express.json
dot use
URL encoded extended
false
NP dot use
API users so
we're going to be pulling them off in
the same location
require
and where we have our API
scrapes
okay
and then let's go ahead and open up
Postman because we can actually use
Postman to actually show us what the
results look like because right now the
results won't show up appropriately
um in our browser window
so placement again is just a API
management tool if you used apogee or
other similar tools that are on the
market mulesoft
you'll see it's very consistent again
this is open source and what you want to
be able to do is you can actually go and
actually go to the path where the API is
stored and then you can use all the
different types of commands within your
environment to be able to you know test
out the scripts so let's go ahead and
create a new project new request and
we're going to go with the default get
but there's actually quite a lot of
different commands we can use
and these are just HTTP commands
and we're going to type in the request
and in this instance
it's going to be
let's run our script first
script we would go
let's make sure we're exporting the data
correctly
okay so we want to run our script so
let's do a node index.js and that will
run the changes that we just created so
we can now come over to get we select
API um localhost colon 3000
slash API uses when we do that brings
back the Json package with that for
entry points
there there's all four of them
so that's your
first action
now let's kind of get this a little bit
tinier let's actually go in and see if
we can filter by ID
so we're going to go in and we're going
to modify our script so it's going to be
a round and then we're going to put in
the filter and in this instance it's
going to be ID
which would allow us to be able to just
put a backslash against the end of the
URL string we just had and put in a
number or a unique identifier and then
that will actually then allow us to pull
in that unique record
foreign
Community
as the data
okay so it found
I'm going to
take the Json and
printed
so we're going to filter here against
user ID
and then publish the results
else if it doesn't work I might just
have a generic error message
we shouldn't see this though in the
demos we're creating this is just good
practice
to save that
and let's go ahead and rerun our node
index file against that folder
and now we can actually come in here and
we do backslash one and that will give
us just one record and we could change
that to 2 or 100 in this instance and if
it's 100
we'll just get a bad request error
message
there's two
all right
so that's get so we'll be able to pull
all of the records we know to filter
against one specific record against a
specific parameter in this instance it
was ID so let's go ahead and create a
new user so that what we're going to do
for this is we're going to use the post
command from HTTP to actually push and
post data into the data source the data
source is our Json packet which means
that we'll have to then push a new
record into the Json package using our
array statements
because Jason's just essentially in an
array
and so we're going to post and when we
do this we have to create a unique ID so
this is where we have to reference the
euid
I'm going to do a V4 unique ID
which will be
four groups of four so these 16
characters
and then
we'll have
name
and email will post
okay looks good
Okay so
if
new user
and then put dot name
and
user dot email
and I want to return
the
results
okay
okay and so he uses Dot
push so we posted which is a HTTP
statement and then pushing into the
the Json packet array
okay
okay that's looking good
all right so I think we're good
let's go ahead and rerun our script
node index.js
now allows us to do that so let's go
over to postman so we can actually
connect to the URL I'm going to change
the HTTP statement to post
and get rid of that we'll go back to
users now if we just do this nothing's
gonna happen so we actually have to go
in and we have to update the body this
would be the content that would be
passed through and we're going to go
through with a raw statement here and we
do Json is B
that's the packet we're sending so let's
go ahead and the records we want to
update we only have to update two which
is one is name and the second is email
we don't have to do an ID because we're
using uuid to generate an automatic one
for us
and we're going to create records for
Steph and and her email address is Steph
gmail.com
yep looking good
okay so let's go ahead and send that we
sent it
and if we look at the bottom we can
actually now see that we have five
records so a new one's been added we
have our unique ID at the top and then
we have name and email which are the
ones that we just created for Steph and
staff at gmail.com
all right
so that's posting now the next thing we
want to do is to update a record so that
means we need to select an ID and then
be able to update the content and for
that we're going to use the HTTP put
command
so we'll use ID as a way to be able to
filter
and then we'll be able to update against
that filter
so construct found
equals users
and then
we'll have it going into
user's ID so we know how to get the
correct record and then pass the record
back
onto the screen so we know what we're
editing
so if
so I found
I want to update the user
and I'm going to go ahead and pull
information from the body for what will
be updated
and for each
diffuser ID
and pass the integer
okay
so this is our values to Ponce against
the ID
and in this instance we'll make sure
that we're obtaining the values of
username
so if we are updating user
and we're just updating the username we
want to
make sure that that's the value that
gets updated
and then we also want to do user email
we don't want to update the ID because
it's going to remain unique and
consistent
okay then we're going to make sure that
everything is pushed to the Json package
and then we'll also have a message
saying that
the field has been updated in the Json
package
okay
all right so run that script again
and looks good so let's go to our folder
let's change the HTTP post let's put it
as get just so we can see that we have
uh all of their values in the array from
the Json packet
and now we want to say put which allows
us to update just one record
so let's go ahead and select one record
we'll save it1 so you have one record we
can go ahead and for name we can change
this
so let's go ahead and change these
so now you see that the email has
changed so we have staff
as the new account
all right our final API that we're going
to create is to delete an account and in
many ways it's actually a very basic API
because all we're doing is we're
grabbing the ID and then we're saying
that all the associated records with
that ID
within that row as it were in the table
just to delete the whole row
and so we want to use again our ID as
the unique value that we
pulling against
so we're going to if he uses are found
and we're going to
filter those users
I'm going to do that filter against user
ID
pass that
and
and they go and
post a message to our Json packet saying
user deleted
now the generic message of things fail
okay save that and we'll
so we go ahead and we're using we're
just deleting the record now
we're going to do it by filtering
against the unique ID
and then you will then just eliminate
that record
and we'll pass the message that has been
the your account has been deleted
okay let's save that let's go run our
script
node index.js
be good okay let's come over here and
we're going to
show that we can put any of the accounts
so let's just take one of them
one I think that's good
so let's go ahead and we're going to
change
the HTTP command to delete
and we actually have to
select an account so we just do one when
we do that it'll actually delete that
record and here we are um it says that
the user has been deleted and we now
only have three records in the Json
packet
and we can pull all the records
and you'll see that there's only three
so being able to pull all the records
from a Json package we've been able to
create a record update a record and
delete a record
and we can just step through so here's
our Json package that we created
originally again this is just an array
it's just a different way of setting up
the array and then we have our index
files which um identifies what are the
apps that need to be installed and where
the API is going to be serviced out of
and that we're going to be doing this on
uh the port 3000
um again these are additional tools that
we need to make sure that we have up and
running um in our script and so the
first script was to get all the the
records the seconds to filter against a
user ID for just a specific record and
then for creating a record we actually
went in and we used the uid tool to
create a unique identifier and then we
posted in the data for the new records
we did something similar with updating
the record we didn't have to update the
user ID we just had to update the values
in the two fields that we needed to be
updated
in this case name and email
and the final step was to go ahead and
delete a record so these are all apis
that you can now pull into your own
application so you can use them in web
applications or you can actually go
ahead and use them in other applications
such as mobile applications
local applications and other scripts and
this really allows your application to
become more scalable and more useful
hello and we're going to go through and
do our demo of building a restful API
with node.js so the first thing we want
to do is go ahead and install all the
correct pieces of software we're going
to start with node.js so let's do a
Google search on node.js and you'll find
that node.js is at
nodejs.org so we select that link
and that's going to take us to the
node.js website and there are two
versions of node.js you can download
There's the stable version and then
there's the latest version I'd go with
the stable version you'll find it
available in Windows Mac OS and Linux as
well
and if we go to the next piece of
software we want to go ahead and install
the text editor of your choice I'm going
to use Visual Studio code vs code it's
an open source solution it works on all
leading platforms uh works really well I
like the larger Microsoft did a good job
with this I also really like it that
it's open source but there's lots of
extensions you can get for vs code so
it's a great text editor and we'll also
need Postman Postman is a tool that
allows us to be able to view the apis
that we're going to create so let's go
ahead to postman.com and again it's
another solution you can download for
free and so we're going to go ahead and
select the download button and it will
automatically detect which OS you're on
so in this case it's going to be windows
but you can also get Mac and Linux as
well so we'll go ahead and download
those
and once we have everything installed
what we're going to do is we're going to
create a project in vs code and that's
actually really easy to do all you have
to do is create a folder
and we'll do this right off our desktop
and we're going to call the folder node
rest API and we're going to select that
folder
and you'll see on the left hand column
that we have the new folder that we
created we still have the vs code
welcome screen we can get rid of that we
don't need that anymore
so let's go ahead and one of the things
I like with vs code is you can actually
toggle the terminal window so let's go
ahead and open up the terminal window so
we can actually run that at the same
time and so we're going to move our
cursor to the folder we just created and
there we are you can see that
and what we can do now is we're going to
initialize this with no package manager
to make this a package
and I'm just going to go ahead I'm going
to ask for a name we're just going to go
with the default so we're just going to
say yes yes to a couple of these yep
enter enter enter
enter enter
and is this okay
yep enter
all right so now we have a new file and
this is our Json package it has all the
defaults in it we can go in and modify
these if we want to no need to for this
exercise but you may want to for the
solution that you're putting together
and we're going to create a new file
called index.js and this is going to be
the reference file that's in the Json
package for npm
and here we're going to put in our
solutions that we absolutely have to
have for this to run so we're going to
install Express and express is a web
service application but it's very
flexible and one of the things that
we're going to use it for today is build
apis
so in our terminal window we're going to
type npm install dash dash save Express
this will install Express locally on our
machine
and takes a few minutes but it's going
to go and download all the latest
features this is going to be the latest
version of Express you can if you want
to specify a specific version of
software for these examples there's no
need to do that
so you'll see that everything has been
installed we expanded the node module we
can scroll down and indeed yep there we
are we see Express has been installed
along with some other
um pieces that are useful
all right so that's our first piece and
the next
is we're going to Define our amp and our
app is going to use Express
and we want Express as a local host on
our local machine on Port 3000 so we've
identified Port 3000 as the default port
for our application
and
we are going to now create a an array
for some movies
I'm going to have ID title director and
release date
such a great movie
and director Christopher
[Music]
and that was released
in 2010 yes 10 years ago
okay so we're gonna do an a couple of
items here and just so that we have some
more than one entry in our array and
array is a JavaScript uh you can think
of it as a very simple uh table now it
allows us to have structured data you
can also do a Json file you can also
connect to a database mongodb or
something like that
2019
okay so we have two movies in our little
array
would be more than enough for right now
the key part is that we have a
consistent structure for the array of ID
title director and release date
and so we're going to create uh two apis
one's going to be a get API we'll get
the list of the items in our API and the
second will be a post where we'll be
actually pushing in a new item so let's
go ahead and start with the get and what
we want to do is we want to select get
slash movie and
we are going to
have this run as an API and so what
we'll do is we will test this in a
moment so we'll be running from our web
browser and actually we'll probably open
up Postman and run it through Postman so
okay
that pause all the movies
and we'll do a another
um getting a moment we'll filter by
movie ID but let's just get them all for
right now
and we are going to listen
on a server port in this instance it's
going to be important
and we already had to find the port as a
variable earlier and which so we're just
referencing the variable and the port
number is listed at the top in line four
it's just a text string that's going to
get put to the terminal window
and it is going to dynamically
grab the port the value from the
variable from 3000
and place it in our text string easy
and we want to save the file
and now we're going to go ahead and run
it so we're going to do node index touch
Js
that runs the script
and it tells us that we're listing on
Port 3000 that's great
that means now that we should be able to
go into Postman
and
grab the data from an API
so here's Postman if you've not used it
before it's a great tool for being able
to manage apis I strongly encourage you
to have a go with this so we're going to
get the get command and we've done any
applications web applications you
probably use get and post for the data
and that you're pulling and pushing from
forms online same principle so we want
to go ahead and we're going to go and
let me grab cat I'm going to type in
localhost
and it's going to be colon 3000 slash
movies because that's the the name of
the file and we're going to hit send and
what we get as a response
is the
data in our query
sorry in our array here we go so there's
our array and the data values have been
pulled back by Postman
that's great
so now we want to go ahead and add a
movie to our array
and we're going to do that we're going
to use the post
command and I get imposed our HTTP
commands
and so we're going to use movies
and in this instance we're going to push
the value
into
our list
so construction movie requires we need a
structure here and that structure is
going to be
the information that's in the the body
and then we're going to push to the log
our terminal window
and I'm going to push so here we're
using push and that's a term in for
arrays within JavaScript where we push
the data into the actual array itself
there are lots of ways of being able to
control data within an array and if
you're new to arrays with JavaScript and
I strongly encourage you to learn more
about them there's just an awful lot you
can do with them
and then we want to have a validation
message come up on the screen saying yes
movie has been added to the list so
we'll save what we've just created
and if you don't save it it won't show
up and then we're going to re-run
the node index.js file
you see this is what we've created here
already
a an API that allows us to pull and push
data
in and out of a variable
okay so let's go back and we're going to
change the header from being guest to
being push
so we're going to use sorry not push our
post so we're going to say post and then
what we want to do is the value inside
of the body and so let's go code huh
and we want to select a body
and we're playing text
and select Json so it's going to be
structured and so here we will
essentially copy the structure we have
here so let's go ahead and just
copy these elements
and we have to give it an ID because we
don't have an auto generated ID so we're
going to make this ID
three
and then
it's going to be a number three
and then you want to put in
title
new movie and we'll put in director
[Music]
and we'll have this as
I don't know new director
I'm very creative here today
and then
we need to put in a date
so release underscore dates
and let's just put in a date
today
um just so you know that we're not
formatting the date con as
so let's go ahead and we'll select send
and this will actually go and we can see
Hello boom movie's been added to our
list
and we can go back and let's go ahead
and validate that so we're going to
change from post to get
use the same
and now we go to below
oh looks like we put an arrow in
our formatting
so let's go
to
pass the Json
and we'll pause it using Express
and this will
clear up any formatting issues
so
app.use Express Json
Express
URL encoded
extended false
and they should help us pass
value
and then we'll rerun that script make
sure you save the previous file
otherwise it won't run the new script
all right click okay so let's go back
and
let's go back to our
localhost 3000 slash movies
and there's only two values here so what
we need to do now is change from get to
post
we'll go to body
and what we're going to do is we want to
have
raw Json and
what we want to do is capture the values
that we have below
and insert
this
file into this new
Json packet
into our array
we can actually just copy that
it's a little bit cheating but it's the
main same so let's go ahead and
get everything consistent
and I'm going to change the number to
three
and create a unique title patching sorry
new typo doesn't need to be unique just
the ID needs to be unique
so title is a new movie new director and
change it to New director
and we'll change the date
I'm not doing any formatting on the date
so it can be any any date any number
really
hit save
maybe it's been added to our list so
it's been added but now let's go back to
get and let's see if we can actually see
the third entry and scroll down and
there we are we've actually pushed that
Json package into our array
so we now have three items in and
they're hoping added by our API
okay
so
now let's go ahead and search our Movie
Database I guess we only have three
entries but you know we want to be able
to so we can do that by using the get
command and what we'll be doing is we'll
be validating against
a specific ID number so we have three
and we're going to
validate against just the ID number
um in this instance
um the way to do it is through the URL
so beforehand we had localhost colon
3000 slash movie now we're adding in uh
Slash movie slash and then whatever
number of that will actually filter
against the ID and
that's essentially what we're doing here
right now
so we're going to go into f movies
dot ID again we're using the ID menu to
actually pull from our arraylist
with my variables and arrays mixed up
here today
and then once we actually have the value
we'll actually post back as a Json
packet
and here we have any errors then what
we'll do is we'll throw up message
moving up found so there we are we're
going to plug in some ID
and we should be able to then pull that
up through Postman into our terminal
window
again the reason why we're using Postman
is that this is actually just showing
the values going back and forth we're
not having to render a whole web page uh
it's extremely fast very efficient
all right
so we saved and rerun our script all
right let's go back and what we're going
to do is we're going to change the value
so we're going to hit send here we are
we see all of our movies using the get
command now what we're going to do is
we're going to use a look filtering just
id2 which is the Irishman so to Slash 2
and there we are we have just the
information on the Irishman
so now you can see how you can create a
simple search
all right
so the final action we want to do is to
delete a record
in our array and so we can go ahead and
do that
and we're going to use the uh Delete
commands to actually do that so we'd be
able to push
um in a record we've been able to view
records filtered guidance records now
we're going to go ahead and do delete
and so you can do app delete and then
we're going to filter by
specific ID number
and when we do this we'll actually then
we'll be put in the URL path which will
be localhost colon 3000 slash movie
slash and then the ID number so this is
inside that 102 but we use two that will
then delete from our array
the record for the Irishman
flowers
I do have a shortcut and a keyboard
shortcut of Control Plus s to save files
on Windows or command processing my Mac
thank you
and
once we've deleted a record we want to
send a message saying that the movie has
been deleted
all right so we want to go ahead
and let's just check our code looking
good save our file
and we want to re-run
the index.js file
yep
rerun okay let's go to postman
the gram
the delete
so again we're filtering against the
movie ID and then we'll delete that ID
okay so you want to hence the Ashman and
we hit send
and there it is now we're going to
change
the command to delete
so we hit
one will actually delete conception the
movie has been deleted it's great and
now let's go ahead and grab uh use get
to pull in all the movies that are
listed and it's not going to find movie
number with the id1 it's not there
anymore
and if we get all the movies
we see we only have one movie and that's
the Irishman and so our delete function
has what
there we are so we've installed Express
we're using Express to build all of our
applications we have our app running on
14
000 we are using Express to pass the
Json effectively back and forth we have
a simple array that array is then being
used to create an API to pull the
details then we're being able to add a
movie then search for a movie itself
ring against an ID
and then we can actually finally go
ahead and delete a movie
all this using express.js
today we're going to be covering node.js
authentication using JWT or Json web
tokens so let's get started so why are
we going to go down this path so let's
cover the key things that you need to be
asking yourself such as what is a Json
web token what is the value of using a
Json web token and then what is the
actual structure of the GWT look like
and then let's go through some use cases
of where you'd actually use jwts both in
the Enterprise and in the real world
and then finally we're actually going to
go through a demo on how you can
actually install a JWT and using Express
and node.js
so let's dive into what actually is a
Json web token
so a Json web token is actually based on
an open standard and it's one that you
can actually go ahead and research and
it allows a definition of a compact
self-contained way of being able to
securely transmit information between
parties using adjacent object an
adjacent object is a JavaScript array
and it's very compact it's a very a
tight way of being able to send data
back and forth
the thing that's great about using a
Json web token is that the information
itself is encrypted and it can only be
verified and trusted through a public
private key pair and we'll get into that
about how you can actually get to those
so you know why would you actually want
to go ahead and use a Json web token are
there other formats that you can use
well yes there are other formats you can
use but what's great about a JWT is that
it is a great way to be able to pass
data from a HTTP servers so if you're
building a web application and you have
a web vacation where you need to pass
authentication over using a jw2 is a
great way to be able to do that so for
instance you may have a number of
Enterprise applications that run across
your Cloud environments you may have
some Enterprise applications that run in
your data center and you want to have
people come in such as your employees or
your customers authenticate once and
then be able to have their ID transition
from one to the next and JWT is a great
way to do that the content is extremely
secure and we'll get more into that in a
moment but it is the highest level of
security you can have right now
and the final great thing about working
with JWT is that the actual tokens
themselves are very well documented and
so there's actually a lot of passes that
you can use so being able to add in JWT
into your application is very very easy
to do which makes it very easy for you
to actually Implement and a large scale
authentication and authorization and so
authorization is a key word there that's
something that you're probably coming
across a lot instead of just being able
to identify who you are we want to be
able to authorize what you have access
to
so let's have a look at the structure of
a JWT there are several key elements and
the first is the header and that's
actually going to break down what I kind
of token It Is by default is going to be
a GWT token and what is the signing
algorithm so sha512 is a very complex
and secure algorithm and certainly the
one that I would recommend that you use
you can even go higher than that but um
shaft 512 is a great place to start
and then you have the payload and the
payload is the information that's been
actually encrypted within the web token
so in this instance we have a name the
admin time type sub name
um just really you can put whatever kind
of information you want in there as long
as it's applicable to the uh service
that you're passing the data into
and then you have your signature which
is
um encoded header um and payload with
the algorithm that you've sent so in
this instance it's sha512 algorithm
so let's look at some of the use cases
that you'd have for JWT
so a couple of use cases would be
authorization so say for instance you
have a application and you want to be
able to authorize somebody to have
access to different parts of that
application and a JWT is a great way to
be able to encrypt that data and be able
to pass that data back and forth uh
examples would be jumping from different
parts Office 365 and being able to have
access to different features within the
system
and then another area would be if you're
doing information exchange so
information is being securely exchanged
from one person to another so a
blockchain scenario a multi- distributed
environment where you want to be able to
have a way to be able to securely
transmit data back and forth and know
that that data is being encrypted is
another good example
so with that let's take a pivot and
we'll go ahead and we'll look at
creating a demo using our standard stack
of node.js and we'll use express and
Postman and these are tools that you may
already be familiar with if you've seen
other videos that we've created in this
series and we'll go ahead and create a
JWT token
so let's go into our demo of how to
create a JWT Json web token there's
going to be some tools that we need to
get started with node.js is the first so
let's go ahead and find node.js at
nodejs.org and you can either download
Windows Mac or Linux code obviously
you'd install the one that would be for
your operating system and the next tool
that we want to install is a those
installed and up and running
so we're going to go ahead and let's
open up visual studio code
and we're going to start by creating our
project
so let's go full screen on this get rid
of the welcome screen
and that's going to open up a folder
where we'll actually have our project
I'm going to put this on our desktop for
right now let's go create a new folder
and we'll call this node JWT
[Music]
for Json web token select that folder
and we're going to want to go ahead and
use npm to initialize this folder for uh
for node and so let's get rid of the
welcome screen again and let's go ahead
and one of the things I love about vs
code is you can actually run the
terminal window right from in here so
let's go ahead and select npm init
Arenas to pull from the folder that
we're in and we're just going to select
yes here in a second for
um
yep let's go ahead and create that and
you'll see that the package has been
created and there is a Json packet with
just default information about the npm
package that we created for node and
we're going to go ahead and create an
index.js file that's what we'll be
pulling from the package and the
index.js files we're going to actually
write all of our code and what we want
to do right now is install Express
and express is going to be used to
create the apis that will be able to
test our JWT against and then we'll also
want to install
a JWT
um file so let's call this Json web
token
and from our terminal window we'll just
go ahead and install both of those and
do that by typing npm install
save and then we're going to put Express
and Json web token
Express and Json web token
and we'll just go ahead and let those
install
it only takes a moment for those to get
installed
all right we're up and running okay
so let's go ahead and start bringing in
some of our apps so we're going to
create an Express amp
and we're going to use the
get HTTP header to have everything go
from the we're going to actually have
everything running on our local host and
we're going to run everything off Port
3000 we'll do that in a moment here but
we'll have everything running off a sub
folder called apis where our web
applications can be running from
and we'll put in a message that hey
there to show that everything's up and
running
okay
and
save that
and say if you can do Control Plus s to
save your files and as you can with a
lot of Windows applications and I
encourage you to do that a lot so let's
go ahead and open up Postman we know we
go to our web browser on this one and
open up Postman
takes a moment to run the first time
and it comes
and Postman again is a tool for being
able to manage API calls
um so you don't have to write a script
so here we go
and we can go in here and we can
that's where we're going to write our
script but we have to do a couple things
first let's let's get everything running
so we want to listen on for Port 3000
that's we're going to run everything off
of
and in the console log we'll actually
throw in a message to confirm that we
are running on uh everything is up and
running we'll just say okay uh server
started on Port 3000 again we're going
to be running everything off localhost
so you'll be able to see this
um and this is as you imagine just a
test environment so let's go down into
our console we'll run this script node
index.js to run the script it runs
really fast not a whole lot going on
there and we're having everything
running off the API file so let's go and
we'll type in under our get localhost
colon 3000
API
and we hit the there's lots of different
HTTP headers um we can use we're going
to use get right now send that
and
hey there welcome to the API service
so typically this is just an API we're
creating right now this is not JWT we'll
get into that right now
all right
so we want to be able to post data
and post is actually pushing data in so
we're going to go into I'm going to
create a login screen it's again again
this is all API so it's not real but uh
okay you get the point
and then you can construct a user
and let's go ahead and what we're doing
here is we're creating a
an array of a random user and that they
can have a name of id1 that they have
users can have ID value which is one
um a username value which is going to be
John and an email value of John
gmail.com
and then we'll make this a
Json web token JWT signing and they'll
have to sign with their user
and this is going to use a secret key
which will be our hash
512 token
and
respond to the Json with the token
okay so let's see now okay and we're
going to
Hamp Dot and this will be our post
API
posts
thank you
and what we're going to be able to do is
we're going to jump from one app to
another app and you'll be able to see
how we can move the token over there
and the message will read
post
created
all right
so let's just run that script index.js
that was real quick okay
so if we come over here and we go to
posts
and hit send
and say message posts created
good
so let's go ahead and try that again
and we want to go to the
login
so again from one app to another app
select post
and here is the login
we should be able to request the token
this will be our GWT token
and we hit send we should get our token
and here you can see the the whole token
is encrypted
it's that huge long line
it's very unique
and
now we want to be able to go in and say
okay let's verify
the token so we've gone ahead and we've
created the token but now we need to as
we go from app to app we need to
actually verify the token so we're going
to get an error message if we don't
verify the token correctly
so put in a function to verify the token
and
we're going to create a bearer header
value
which will be
the headers and the authorization for
that
and if type of Bearer header
I'm gonna either have it if it's not
correct it'll be undefined
otherwise the spirit token
it will be split
and we're going to require the token
for a bearer token
else
send status
403 okay so Bearer token is what we're
going to be calling against to verify
our token I'll show you how that works
in just a moment
and this will be to authorize
and to authorize we'll need to actually
go ahead and
use the token so we can actually
put in here
all right so I think
everything's looking pretty good
oh and
if things if we get the error message
means that it's we'll see the message
forbidden if we don't put in the code
correctly so it's
double check everything is looking good
we'll be verifying that the token is
required
okay
so if it is then jwt.45
[Music]
and this will
connect our token appropriately
and you will be able to
put that in as a part of our secret key
and if it is successful
let me put it in
that message there
and we're also going to play in the
authorization data
yep looking good
as you can see a lot of the work is just
making sure that everything is aligned
up correctly
okay so let's run our code node index.js
there we go nice and fast
and
we go in and localhost
API posts
let me change this to post
so this one API which is the API posts
which is up here
I'm going to hit send
and you can see that we have the error
code forbidden has come up which is what
we're expecting because we haven't been
able to put in a secret key
and put in the comment there forbidden
so it's as we're stepping through the
code
but now what we can actually do is we
can go back and we can grab the token
and here is our token below and we just
want the token itself we don't need the
wrappers
and copy that
come over here
and if we write again it's going to say
forbidden but if we go into author into
our headers we can put in authorization
and then the value
we do Bearer and then the key
and once we do this
we now get all of the data that we were
asking for pulled back
which is exactly what we wanted
so you can see here how we can actually
securely use a JWT to pass values back
and forth across the application
okay
and we hit authorization we select that
and prove it yep we keep authorizing so
if you don't authorize and you don't get
the data
okay so we have everything against the
API and then we have one application
which we call Api post we have another
application called API of login and
we're able to move the data back and
forth using our secret key in our JWT
token
and we have everything running on Port
3000 of our Local Host server
and that's our demo
so first of all let's cover why you'd
want to go through this tutorial so
we're going to cover what my sequel is
we're also going to tell you how we're
going to connect with node.js and why
you'd want to do that with my SQL and
then finally we're going to do a demo
taking you through all the steps on how
you can actually do that kind of
connection
so what is my SQL well basically MySQL
is probably the world's most popular
relational database so if you think of
relational databases that are table
driven MySQL is arguably the most
popular database out there for rdbs
systems it is by far the most popular
open source relational database
the entire database is written in C and
C plus plus it's been around for a
really long time and again it's open
source which is great which means that
there are no licenses or costs for
actually using MySQL and you'll find
that companies of all sizes from small
mom and pop shops all the way up to
massive Enterprise Global Enterprises
are all using MySQL so you know why
would you want to then take that next
step of connecting node.js with my SQL
what fundamentally comes down to the
basics of the differences between the
two products MySQL is a database and
node.js is a architecture framework for
building out web applications again with
mySQL it's open source it's free to use
you don't have to pay anything there are
no licenses which if you compare it with
other Solutions out there is a big deal
my sequel even though it is open source
it's incredibly powerful it's one of the
more mature open source programs out
there I think Apache is probably
arguably more perpetually a web server
is probably more mature but uh my sequel
is very close behind it so it has had a
huge amount of investment this is not a
solution that's only a couple years old
we're talking about a solution that's
more than 15 years old very very
structured very powerful and you can do
a lot of really good things with it
um you can actually then build Solutions
with it and using PHP Java really any
kind of database even other systems and
other Frameworks will allow you to
interact with mySQL and it just allows
you to work with just huge amounts of
data very very quickly
so let's go through a demo of how you'd
actually use node.js and MySQL
so I'm going to go ahead and we're going
to get started by putting our road
environment together so let's start by
setting node.js and downloading it so
we'll get to knowjs.org
and there you have your options for
Windows Mac or if you want to go for the
source code you can go ahead and
download and install that
the next is to install Zam and so we're
going to go to zap installers for a
quick search and that's on our Apache
friends.org site and here we have
example available for Windows Linux and
Mac OS 10.
and then finally we want to go ahead
and install visual studio so visual
studio is going to be our idea
integrated development environment in
this instance we're going to use Visual
Studio code if you're not used to just
do code it's a great free open source
solution for being able to build
applications I'm a big fan of it so I
encourage you to use it
and go ahead and download install that
and we have visual studio
um code up and running so go ahead and
we're going to open up a new folder and
let's go ahead and create a new folder
and just put it straightfire desktop
here and it's just for uh kicks and
Giggles so we're going to type in node
MySQL for our source code and open up
that folder and select that
and so we now have this folder selected
in our Visual Studio code editor and
what we want to do is we want to get rid
of the welcome page and we don't really
need that anymore and we're going to
terminal window so we can actually see
the script that we're writing we're
going to be using terminal quite a bit
um in this so for instance we're just
going to test that we have npm installed
we did so that's great
and we're going to go npm init and
that's actually going to set up our own
node package module and we can actually
see that the Json file for the package
has been created so we go in there we
can see that all the defaults selected
now you'll see that index.js is the
default file that would be created so
we're actually going to go ahead and
we're going to create our own index.js
file and we're going to add in some
instructions into that file to actually
install the correct software from the
npn package
and the first thing we want to do is
install Express
which is a package that's great for
building a lightweight web applications
not mobile applications I suppose if
you're doing a responsive design
mobile but in this it's really it's a
web application environment so we're
going to put in the requirements for
that and then we're going to also go and
require that MySQL gets installed
and you'll see that for both of them
we're just going to use npms default
commands for creating it and we'll go
down to the tunnel window and we'll do
npm install and it's going to install
the express and MySQL environment
an asset installs you actually see on
the left hand side under the folder you
actually see
the files starting to be installed so
for instance we have the node modules
and underneath that will be all the
subsequent files that we need
and there we are everything is installed
all right so let's go ahead and validate
some of these commands to make sure
everything is installed so we're going
to open up xampp which allows us to go
in and
View and see that everything is
installed so we have my sequencer we
have a patch installed we can start and
stop and the services
with Zam go ahead and do that you can do
this through terminal window as well but
the UI interface is really nice so let's
go into
my SQL interface and you'll see that we
don't have any databases
these are all just the the standard test
databases and so we have to go ahead and
create one
and so that's
get our
SQL database can actually created
so we're going to write this const DB
equals MySQL
create connection
and we want to create and connect to the
localhost in this instance
and users just going to be a root user
account
which is the standard user account that
comes from MySQL there is no password
for the root user when you're running it
locally or I encourage you to change
that as quickly as you can because you
don't really want to have a
password-free environment
and now we want to be able to then
connect to the MySQL
environment
so do royalright DB dot connect
parentheses error and we wanted to throw
an error message if the connection isn't
good so if we do error
foreign
message to the log window
and if we don't
write my super connected
all right
and then we want to connect that to our
Express app
the next step we want to do after we
meet our connection is to go ahead and
create a database so we're going to do
both steps are the same one so we'll run
the script right now and then we'll run
the commands in the terminal window so
we can actually create a database
and so we're going to go ahead and we
want to create
a database
and that's right that's SQL equals
create
database
I'm going to call the database node
MySQL you could call it whatever you
want
um but this is just a no I know my SQL
script
the DP
query
SQL
error
through error message
rest of sand
database created
so we'll throw a message saying that
database has been created I'm just going
to save that
to demonstrate that we've connected and
we've created database so let's go ahead
and we'll do node index.js
let's run it and we'll connect it to my
SQL that's great
first step and then we'll go to the
window
I will go to localhost
3000 which is
the default
connection but what you'll see is that
we've actually created the name of the
databases and changed to node by SQL so
we've got an error message which we
expected and so what we're going to do
is we're actually going to go ahead and
we're going to say we want to listen
and if the Met error message if comes up
to three thousand
then
in the console window we want to
put a message of server started on
quarters 2000.
so let's try that again
go to index.js
yep and server has signed in 40 000.
Let me refresh that
I'm still getting an error message
and what we want to see is let's go
ahead and see how database hasn't been
created
so let's go and connect to
database
and database let's go ahead and say
create DB on Port 3000 all right so by
doing that we write that command and
that function and that goes and creates
our database and we'll actually seeing
that we have now node MySQL has been
created
great first start
now we have to go in and create some
tables because we have no tables in
there
all right so let's go down let's go
ahead and create a table
so what you're seeing right now is that
we're using
the index.js environment within a
package on node.js to actually create
and control everything that we want to
see in our windows so all of the work
that we're doing for creating a table
for creating the database
for initializing the core files it's all
being done through Js and so here we are
going to create a new table we call it
create import it's going to be called
the employee table and so once we run
the command create employee it's going
to create a table has the employee
fields which is going to have an ID
which will be an integer there or into a
auto increment it'll have a name field
and we'll also put in a designation
field
and
uh we'll have a primary key as well
keep it very simple for right now
and let's just
put a DB connection so that everything
connects effectively
okay so everything goes correctly then
we'll have the message employee table
created
so let's test this out
and there's index.js
make sure that the data we have now
actually a database field that we can
connect to so we've got node my SQL so
we're connecting to the correct database
obviously we get an error
and then we'll try that again
thanks to the database so database has
the name
and of course but load my SQL there's no
fields in there yet so let's go ahead
and
put in create employees or fields and
let's run the punches which creates a
new table
and then
voila we have a new table and so the
next action we want to do is actually
populate the table with a record
so this starts becoming familiar so
we're not going to
put in a single record we'll call it
employee one right now and
we'll write the
the function in our employee one and
when we run that function
uh it'll actually go ahead and
create the it'll actually insert the
record into my SQL
and then the name will be Jake Smith
and the designation will be
a chief executive officer
certainly encourage you to put your own
self name your own name into this make
yourself your own CEO because why not
and we're going to make this as an
insert record
remains it into the employee table
I'm just using some basic SQL Square
and what you'll see actually with Visual
Studio code is that it's actually
providing a lot of prompts to make it
easier to write real code
Microsoft is looking to actually add
some AI
to visual studio code to actually start
Auto completing script which will make
it even easier
to write your code
all right so let's go run node index.js
received everything connected and we'll
grab the function employee one and let's
go over to our Express site
let's just go and we'll insert the
command employee E1
an employee has been added and we will
just validate this by going back to my
SQL and we'll refresh it and you'll see
if we click on the employee table which
we should now have an employee in there
yep there we did Jake Smith
put on Jake first record
all right so we want to be able to now
is select the employee
so let's go ahead and do that
and we want to be able to easily get the
employee list
and so let's use our SQL command and we
want to do select star which is
everything from the employee table so
we're actually playing everything from
the employee table
I'm going to query the database
let's throw a message to confirm that
the query is successful
we'll put everything in the console log
results
all right let's give this a well
okay so let's go and run a command
or localhost 3000
you know but get employee
and it says employee details fetch now
we go over to the console we do in
digital Studio yeah there we go we have
now all the packet information including
the ID about Jake Smith
okay so let's go ahead and see if we can
actually update the employee information
so as you can see now we're starting to
run into just our standard SQL commands
and so we want to be able to update the
employee from a browser
and as you can tell we're not using any
forms or any other types of Records but
just simply interacting
um with between the the uh the browser
the server and the database
and the new name will be updated name
look information
and we'll make sure that we're matching
against 181
all right so that's wrong
and
I think Jake Smith is there
now go and select
Ed
colon same slash one we've now gone
ahead and updated
the object and objects with information
so let's click on complete table
and we now see he says date again I know
not very clearly but it allows you to
see a change
and finally we go ahead and delete the
record as well
so it's going to be similar to update
but you can delete it instead
I'm going to delete
the record from the employee table
where the theme equals the ID equals
sorry
and
okay
and then we want to be able to
show that the record has been deleted
[Music]
I'll just set the detail plane
looks like deleted and we go to uh
database you can actually see
in the employee table
but there are no entries
the 100 record that was there has been
deleted
and so this shows you how you can very
easily control everything
from
using your connection into MySQL right
from node package manager
you can create table
you can select your records
you can then update any record that you
selected
and finally you can delete any
recordings
you want to be able to delete
so what we're going to do is so what's
in it for you so in this presentation
we're going to go through three key
things you know what is mongodb how do
you connect to mongodb with node.js and
mongodb is part of the merge stack so
we're going to cover what the merge
stack is and how it applies to node.js
so what is mongodb so mongodb is a it's
a probably the most popular nosql
database out there it's cross-platform
and very easy to scale it's available on
all Cloud systems you can also run it
locally which is what we'll be doing
later on in our demo but it's just a
very flexible database environment for
modern applications
it works on the concept of collection
and documents
um what you'll find is uh mongodb was
originally written in C plus plus and it
is what's referred to as a nosql
database so this is different to a
relational database which is built up of
tables with rows and columns this is a
nosql database as simply a lot faster
and more powerful for the work that
you're doing
and you're able to use mongodb very easy
you can actually go ahead and download
it we'll actually do that as part of our
demo so you know why connect node.js
with mongodb
well the reason why you want to do this
is that mongodb is a modern database
it's not restricted by the the
challenges of scalability the audit
relational databases have
um it's really designed for building
mobile applications of websites that
scale into the millions and millions of
users
so mongodb probably the most important
feature is scalability the performance
of the database is phenomenal
and it is extremely highly available for
the solutions that you'll be creating so
when you push it out your solution to
the cloud you can almost guarantee it's
always going to be running
you also have the ability to be able to
scale to very large complex
multi-site Solutions in fact one of the
very first mongodb applications I built
was a multi-tenant environment and it
just worked really well
and you'll be able to easily deploy your
surgeons across Microsoft Azure AWS
Google Cloud
Etc so yeah why do you want to keep
connecting to mongodb um I think
probably one of the other areas that's
probably is often forgotten with manga
it's just the concept around big data
and you can I mean when you talk about
big data and you're talking about
absolutely massive massive databases and
mongodb is front and center for all of
that
you can do your effective content
management and delivery
um it has an effective mobile and social
infrastructure so
um by that it allows you to be able to
build out solutions that can go to all
modern day types of applications and the
data is actually very easy to manage
through your central data hub
and then finally being able to connect
to mongodb is very easy particularly as
there's a client called Mongoose that
makes the connection extremely easy so
you know fun really um let's kind of
look into how [ __ ] DB is part of the
Moon Stag
so monstag is a JavaScript stack and
it's of JavaScript solutions that are
built for modern single page
applications and there are four key
Solutions in the merge stack there's
mongodb which is your database Express
which is your server side HTTP
environment react which is the solution
for being able to create your Solutions
on the client and the node.js which
actually manages the whole environment
it's really an environment that's
designed to make it very easy to be able
to build out modern day Solutions so
mongodb is the am in Moon Express is the
E react is the r and node js is the n so
again as you start working with some of
our other videos that we have here
you'll be able to see how all of these
tools really complement each other so
we've done an introduction on [ __ ] DB
really the best thing now is to get you
out you know your hands dirty by
actually doing a demo so we're going to
go through a demo what I would strongly
encourage you however though is that
this demo really does build on a lot of
the other videos that we've done in this
series so you really do want to spend
some time on the node.js video the
node.js for Express video the node.js
for apis video really all of those
videos help complement the work that
you'll be doing with this video here
you'll see some real strong correlations
plus a lot of new content as well so
with that we're going to jump into the
demo
so let's give our demonstration on how
to use mongodb with node.js first thing
we want to do is go ahead and install
node.js so you're going to go and do
Google Search node.js and that should
bring up a result of going to nodejs.org
and here you can download node.js for
multiple platforms so Windows Linux Mac
OS they're all supported you can also
get the original source code and
recompile your version of node.js if you
want to
now we're just going to install the
windows version
and the next thing you want to do is
install your favorite uh text editor I'm
going to install Visual Studio code vs
code it runs on all leading platforms
Mac OS windows and Linux it is open
source you can edit it and I like it
because you can do an awful lot with it
just a lot of extensions it's just a
great tool all around
so that's the next thing you want to
install
and then we want to go ahead and we want
to go to
mongodb.com so we can install the
mongodb database
so you want to go to Software
Community server
and you want to then select
the
mongodb community server
uh which platform you want
and where it's going to connect with
and you want to select the download to
install that
and that'll take a moment or two for you
to download and get that up and running
once you've done that we want to go
ahead and we're going to open up vs code
so we can start editing and the code
that we need for our new solution
so let's go ahead and create a folder of
our desktop that we'll use for mongodb
so I already have a photo created called
demo I'm just going to select that and
then inside there I'm going to put in a
node mongodb
and select that folder
and that's going to open up vs code it's
going to have our folder in here so
we're going to get rid of the welcome
screen we don't need that
um we do want to however open up our
terminal window so we're going to run
that this is one of the things that I
really like about vs code is you can
actually have your terminal window or
command line window actually inside the
development environment you're working
in so you don't have to be jumping from
one solution to another and then we're
going to initialize our package so npm
in it for the folder that we're in it's
going to create our node package manager
it's going to create our default package
and we're going to hit return that's
going to go ahead and start the process
and we're just going to go with the
default
um uh settings
that npm is going to give so just hit
return return a few times and that will
get up and running for you
and our entry point for the application
is going to be index.js
oh yeah that's uh
JS package and there we have everything
this is just the uh the the Json package
that provides the instructions that npm
would use to pass the the program now
you notice that we have index.js as our
leading file so we actually have to add
a new file here and we're just going to
Tool this one index.js so we actually
have a file that can be referenced
and now we're going to go ahead and
we're going to actually put in our
default application so Express is going
to be required so we're going to make
sure that that is included in our first
line of our instructions
and then we're also going to
have a path that's required
and
we're going to require handlebars
cool
and these are all part of our Express
environment
and don't forget to save your file as
you're going along
and we're also going to have
Express phbs
and this is going to be our Express
handlebars
and we're all going to
allow
insecure
prototype
you would normally do this but because
we're running everything locally it just
makes it easier for you to actually get
all the code in
and then we're also going to add in
uh body parser
and these are all the required solutions
that we need to be installed when you're
running this
package
and so let's save the file and then
let's go ahead and run it so we're going
to do npn install
and we do dash dash save and this will
install Express
and we're also going to have an install
path
uh handlebars
Express handlebars
and
and this is where we'll install
prototyping
and we'll also have the body parser
installed and we're just going to run
that
this will just take a moment or two to
install
all right there we go
so we have everything installed which
allows us to now start working with our
Scripts
so we're going to create an app in
Express
and we're going to listen on Port 3000
and
we're going to have a message then go to
our console log
and we have everything running of our
local port on localhost on Port 3000 so
let's go and we're going to select node
index.js and shows us everything's
running
which is good you can actually test this
in our web browser if we wanted to
okay so let's start working on our app
so our app is going to
use body parsa
and we're going to encode
uh request
and the goal here is we're going to
create a file that's going to go back
and forth
to mongos among uh to mongodb
so body parts is going to use Json to
encrypt
the content
and we're going to do a get command to
get our results
and if we worked if you've seen the API
video then we did that here in fact it's
probably a good idea to actually sit
down and look through some of the other
videos that we've created such as the
Json sorry the node.js node.js for
Express node.js for apis and node.js for
authentication before doing this video
uh we're going to create a default page
and it's going to say welcome to the
students database
the principles that we're putting down
here you'll be able to apply to any
solution that you're creating with
mongodb
and so we want to have a simple action
that we're going to
put on here which is going to be
click to gain access
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
all right so here is our basic web page
that we're creating
nothing fancy
but it's going to take you to a place
where you can actually get all the
content now what we're going to do is
we're actually going to go and pull the
content from manga
so run this and we can upload web
browser you'll see what it looks like
let's just go to localhost
close out these other tabs don't need
them localhost 3000
and there we see welcome to the student
database click on the database and you
click on if we click on it now nothing
will happen so yeah nothing there
so let's make something happen
okay
all right so
again extending our app so what we're
going to do is we want to
set
the views
and I'm going to do a join
a directory name
and app
engine
so let's go for our views we don't have
engine yet but let's go ahead and create
a new folder
we can call that one views and let's
expand that
should be okay
HPS
Express handlebars
and we're gonna allow prototype access
for our Express Enterprise
so with Express handlebars if this is
new to you it allows you to separate
your content from your layout
which if you have developed with swift
for a mobile application on the Mac
using xcode is the same principle there
but for a web application
so we're just putting out here
some of our
default environment settings
I'm going to set our view engine
for handlebars
and
through our code it's looking good
okay so that provides
that so let's create a new folder under
our views and this one we're going to
call layouts so again this is where we
are splitting our layouts
and we're going to have a photo called
models at the root of our application
and under models we're going to put in
db.js so the dbjs file is going to be
where we put our instructions for our
database and so here we're going to go
ahead and we're going to require to
import Mongoose and Mongoose is a tool
in node.js that allows you to connect to
mongodb
so we're going to require the use of
mongoose and so we're going to do npm
install Dash say save mongoose
and that's going to run and install on
our local machine so we can actually
test this out
and once we've got this installed what
we're going to do is we're going to
start connecting to a database that
we're going to call student DB
okay we're already already installed so
let's go Mongoose dot connect
and
we're going to call it mongodb
and
we're going to run this off our Local
Host
so we installed the community version
that I was just trying to file logo host
and it's going to run from the port
27017 I'm going to call this one student
DB
so again with our application we're
splitting out all the functionality so
if you want to reuse elements you can
so we're going to have a new user URL
parser
and we'll make sure to capture
everything correctly
okay so if Arrow then we'll send a
message to the console log
and we have either connection is
successful or if things go wrong
error in connection
and then if there is an error then what
we'll do is we'll have the error message
posted
okay
and then we're going to do require
[Music]
student
dot model so this will actually call the
model we're going to create
and so what we're going to do now is
creating
under models we're going to create
student of model
.js
and this is where we're going to do
our instructions for our student model
so first thing you want to do is we want
to import
Mongoose Express and the student model
so we've got X make sure we have
everything and capture that
so let's go over to
our student model
all right so let's make sure that we
have everything so we want to have
mongoose
and
we'll create a new variable called
student schema this will allow us to
structure what our model will look like
this will be a
a new
new schema
in using mongoose
and our new schema it's going to be full
name
now we're going to break down
our
Jason's package so we're going to put in
the instructions for what
scheme it would look like so
we have the type we have no required
this field is required
and
second value is going to be email
type string
this field is required
there's the message error message you
want to send if
the field isn't filled out
mobile phone number this will be just a
number
and we're going to have City
and a subtype will be
let's just make this a string we're just
going to try and keep this simple for
right now
and then the field is required
all right so here's our schema
looking pretty good
right Mongoose dot model
and connect this to our
student model
so we want to go ahead and save that
you can
create a new folder and this new folder
is going to be called controllers
and we have a new file under controllers
and that new file is going to be called
student controller
.js
let's go in
see what we're going to add here
so we want to import uh make sure we're
running Express
so Express is required for our
controller
we also want to set up a variable for
router
so rather express.rowder
and we want to make sure we're also
connecting with mongoose
so we have our connection to our mongodb
and we also want to make sure that we
have
connection to our student model
so Mungus Mongoose dot model
shoot model
and this allows us to make sure that we
have
this student model
pulled over effectively for our
controller for our student controller
okay so let's go to router
get
I'm gonna render this
and student slash add or edit
we'll come into that in just a moment
so we want to be able to
View Title and support in
the insert
student
I'm going to use under our views
we're going to create a new folder
and this one's going to be called
student
and we're going to create a new file and
this one will be add or edit
.js oh HPS sorry for our handlebar
so you notice we don't have to put the
file extension
node.js manages all that for us
so router touch post
so this will be
our we're going to get our content and
then we're also going to post content so
the post will go back and it's part of
our body and there'll be an ID
so we want to then insert insert the
record that we'll be creating
all right
so again if you've been if you've worked
through the node.js API video then
you'll start seeing if there's some
commonalities here of being able to
insert or update a record
and we actually cover that using just a
sample Json package this really takes it
to that next level
okay
okay so we want to put in a new student
record and so be student
and we're going to have that full name
it's going to come from our body
now we're going to also capture the
email
essentially we're going to follow the
model that we created
and I'll play Buffet
finally with a student City
and then we want to save the record that
we create
okay
oh
all right so we're going to manage our
error message
[Music]
similar messages that we've put in
before
so we want to redirect to our student
list
and we're going to go ahead and create
that in a moment
so let's create a new file student
list.hbs
so list.hbs
and here
so what we do is with student list
that's actually going to manage then the
uh controls for being able to display
the records in the database
and then we'll put
um message if there's an error then you
know we'll put an error message there
and ask it to report the error message
I'm going to try and not do that
all right so
now the next step we need to go through
is we want to call a function to update
the record
and let's go in ahead and we're going to
update our records and we do the
student.find1 and update command
okay
okay so we will redirect to our student
list as needed if not we'll throw an
error message to our console log
yeah looking good
and again this is just an example but
something that you'll be able to do
yourself
uh whether your own solution
and
then we want to like go back to our list
to then render
the records
and here we want to put student and then
how we're going to find the record
else
we'll throw a error message to our
console log
so as you can see we always throw an
error message to the console log
error messages are really useful
okay all right looks good
save that
okay let's do another router and this is
two
we're gonna do the router against ID
this will allow us to get the content
so I'll be able to give information by
ID of the student
what you can see is there's a lot of the
work we're doing here
is very repetitive
um and
you'll find as you create more modular
code that it makes it easier for you to
write your code and update and manage
your code
okay so we're going to
get out
View Title we're going to put into our
document
okay
all right so our next router
is
we want to be able to delete our record
by ID
and so we're going to do is we're going
to find our records stream record and we
just find it by ID
and then we'll just find by find ID and
remove
okay
so we're gonna
to once we've removed your record we're
going to redirect to our list so we can
show our student list
will send an error message to our
console log
okay
so I think we have what we need
maybe just maybe there's one more thing
I think we need to do
I think this is good
okay so let's go to our layouts add a
new file there we're going to call this
one main layout
dot HBS
and here we're going to put the skeleton
of our web page together
it's
write this out so we've been HTML
code
and
we're just going to keep this real
simple
and I hit a
we want a title
and this is going to be students
database
we just got students
so
we now go to
try and find out bootstrap four we're
going to just grab that
and we're going to use
bootstrap to get started and there are a
couple components there's a CSS
component and then there's the
JavaScript component so let's just go
copy the CSS component
and then we're going to just link that
into the header section of us
web page
so and then here's an example of
different components you can create
if you're not used if you haven't used
bootstrap before it's an open source
framework that origin developed by
Twitter great tool so in a header we
want to
put in the link to the CSS
there's that
and
now I need to also
in our own styles
so we've got here some styles that we
created earlier on for
the work that we're doing you can just
paste those in
so we have a box style that we want to
use that will extend the Box style that
you get
with bootstrap
all right so we're going to start
working on our body content
class BG info so this is actually BG
info is
a CSS class file from bootstrap that you
can use
and you know the ID of box
and again we're going to do
another class
which allows us for our table structure
so a little bit of knowledge of
bootstrap is great here
so what we're going to do now is going
to put in
the content which we're going to call
Body missile show up on the screen
so again for pulling from records within
bootstrap dig through bootstraps lots of
content there for you to be able to take
advantage of
okay
so now we want to be able to add or edit
our record
View Title
and the
um
the the uh the the French brackets allow
you to be able to pull records and
content directly from the code that
we're writing
so playing title from insert record on
this part of our router
command
and then we'll put in our form
which will be student post
I'm just going to do a basic form here
nothing fancy
we will put in the first
record will be a hidden field this will
be for ID
so we want to want to generate the ID we
don't want to assembly put that in and
then we will put in
r
form elements
so we'll have first will be the label
that'll be full name
and be an input field
so be text in the input field
and
again we're using form Dash control
which is from
bootstrap CSS and then we'll have
the full name
and placeholder before name so if where
we have name there will actually match
up with
the value that we're putting in our
model
so here we have student for name
so we're matching everything up to the
model that we created
okay so let's do this for our remaining
form elements
and again as you see we can put this
together really quickly
so I'm going to put in full as well
would be email
and then we'll do mobile
and City
and
here we keep going
put in form group
foreign
[Music]
type of
tool for putting in Mobile
foreign
so as you can see because we're using
just standard HTML here you can actually
reference external libraries such as
JavaScript libraries for formatting the
field that you're in regular Expressions
things like that
and let's put in a final value
which will be for City
and normally when I'd be writing this by
hand I would actually be copy and
pasting and sections of code and just
changing the values as necessary
just to make it easier on myself but
here I'm just typing out everything for
you so you can see the
the whole process
okay
all right so there are our values
of course remember save your files as
you're going along
thank you
everything looks good
and we're matching up our values
with uh
records
and we want to have a button that allows
you to submit
we also want to have a button to select
view or if you want to be able to view
all the records okay
looking good
okay let's go back over to list now we
want to be able to pull our records so
this will display
the
list of students
in a table
and
right
let's go ahead and format that table
so we're going to put together our
format here but then we're also going to
add buttons at the bottom so we can
actually add a record to the database or
if we want to add or delete a particular
record from the database
I'm going to call this one
create a new student record for our
student list
I'm just going to type all this in for
you
and you'll see how we put placeholders
for the values as we put them in
these are our table headers
okay
body content
and what we're going to do here is we're
going to add in
an element that allows you to create a
row for each item listed
so if you have two or more items they'll
appear as an individual row
on here
and again what we're doing is we're
pulling in the values to be able to
pull it from the model that we created
earlier on so this being the data that's
been submitted so we have it pull in the
value for the email full name
and mobile and City
we're not going to show ID
so it's pulling out all of this data
that we created earlier on
so we have everything posted into our
list
as documents
so let's go into a HPS file
and it's our list
let's put another
file entry here
this will be for City
then
this is just a placeholder
at the end
of the list
oh yeah you know what we're going to do
is we can add in
reference for the ID
so we want to edit the document we can
and then we want to do the same thing if
we want to delete the document
so href because
student
and then
just delete
now delete based on the ID
there we go
passing that instruction over
so click
to
[Music]
simple
I'm gonna ask him are you sure you want
to
delete that somebody clicks on the
record they hit cancel then it won't get
deleted over here it's okay then it will
get deleted
this is why you can actually write
JS inline
okay
and then we want to close out where the
row will end so I have each opens and
closes the record
just tying up some of the HTML there
save that
okay looking good
back to our root index file
so let's see now
we want to also require
our model
and then
we'll have a
student controller
also be
a require
of where it's going to pull the student
controller from
okay
and this is just the instructions on
where we can actually find
content
okay it looks good so let's do node xjs
everything's saved we're going to rerun
everything
and we got an error let's go check out
where our error came from
so let's go and to our files
this is one that we created
so
error is in
the controller see where's the error
oh we need to
have how much we need to export our
module to our router
all right let's go open up [ __ ]
database
and we can just start
seeing where the records are
it's just installing release updates
here
so we need to go ahead and in our
connection strings with some localhost
and that's the port
let's just double check now make sure
we're
completely aligned so here's our
database connection
and
there's a report and student database
and we did this with mongod Mongoose for
connecting to manga
so I'm going to connect
and here are where our records are being
stored
so we're going to create a database and
we're going to call this database
it's going to be called student DB
student DB has to be case sensitive
and the picture name is students
let's go ahead and create a database so
there we are there's our database
and
let's go we run our index.js file
and everything was successful
this is good
all right
so everything should have passed
successfully good good
database connection is good
so let's go to localhost
and here we are so we can start actually
navigating through our application
so we see we have our setup we have no
records
so let's go ahead and create one
and we go through you can actually start
stepping through the different layouts
that you've created so here's our layers
a separate to our code so there's some
spacing we probably need to add there so
let's go ahead and just add that
and let's rerun our code
this is the fun bits where you know
everything is
just tidying up okay so you know it puts
in one one space because we didn't put
in the actual HTML code between multiple
spaces
so we're going to go in and select
insert so let's put in
uh Smith and we'll do Smith at gmail.com
[Music]
and let's just put in I know random
phone number
there we are we don't have any
formatting so we could put anything in
there and the city uh right now where am
I
um this I'm in Delhi so split that hit
submit and it takes us to a list and
voila
we actually have a list with a record in
now if we go back to our database we can
actually refresh it and now we actually
start seeing our records being created
and we see the ID is automatically
created and there's our records
okay let's go back
and now we can select edit we can edit
the record
so let's change our city to
Bangalore hit submit
all right city is now Bangalore
and if we want to we can
edit again
and so this is pulling in
you know if we do a delete It's Gonna
ask us do we want to delete
okay
a little bit of formatting apply there
and the records are all good so we had
to make that Smith change
but because we need to hit submit
wouldn't update record
so we hit submit I've changed the record
we hit delete it's going to say are you
sure we say yes we are
and ah
it has
couldn't grab that record okay so let's
go back into my code
and
because we have everything separated and
actually now just go to our student
controller
and we'll find out Delete and you guys
delete now we had a
now we had a couple of minor errors
there this is where it's good to test
out your code
okay let's run that again
and refresh everything
so go to our database we're gonna go
create a new entry
let's call this one with some John John
gmail.com
we will put in the phone number
you see that the formatting is just
playing from
um
our bootstrap so there we have there's
John do we want to delete this say yes
easy there we go also
and we hit refresh the record should be
gone yep it is
and so we've created an application
where we can update applications
we can create an application we can list
all the items and we did all of this
using just open source Solutions through
node.js and that was with using express
some of the components come with Express
mongodb for our database and then
Mongoose to connect to our database
so let's get started with typescript
with node.js but before we begin make
sure you have subscribed to our YouTube
channel and click on the Bell icon so
you never miss an update from Simply
learn
so we'll first look at what is
typescript
foreign
typescript is an object oriented and
strongly typed programming language
which is a superset of JavaScript
typescript was designed by Anders
hijelsberg at Microsoft
the limitations of JavaScript for
developing large-scale applications at
Microsoft and among its external
customers led to the creation of
typescript
due to the difficulty of working with
complicated JavaScript code there was a
demand for custom tooling to make
development of JavaScript components
easier
typescript code is converted to
JavaScript which can be executed
anywhere JavaScript is supported in a
browser on node.js or any other
application
typescript is a JavaScript with some
additional features to support a more
robust interaction with your editor
typescript adds additional syntax to
JavaScript
typescript is a scripting language that
understands JavaScript and uses type
inference to provide powerful
capabilities with additional code
cool
what is node.js
node.js is an open source server-side
execution platform for JavaScript code
node.js is a JavaScript runtime based on
the version 8 JavaScript engine from
chrome
node is an asynchronous event driven
JavaScript runtime for building scalable
Network applications
although node.js is excellent for
developing server side apps it lacks
several current features such as type
checking it can also be difficult to
manage a node.js code base
node is commonly used for real-time
applications like chat news feeds and
web push notifications because it allows
for a persistent connection from the
browser to the server
the current coding methods such as
static typing and type checking are
supported by typescript
it's designed to create complex and high
level applications that's why having
typescript as a primary language for
supporting node.js capabilities would be
idle
this also allows us to develop
server-side apps with rigorous type
checking avoiding run type errors and
other typescript benefits while
maximizing node.js capabilities
now let us see how to set up the
development environment for typescript
with node.js
the prerequisites are we need to have
typescript installed in our device and
node.js
to install node.js go to the official
website
go to nodejs.org and go to downloads so
here you can see
we have node.js for different browsers
for Windows Mac OS and source code
so go to Windows if you have Windows PC
and click on install
click on Windows and here you can see it
is getting installed since I have
already installed in my device I'll
cancel it
so once you have installed go to the
command prompt
and just enter
node.v to check if node is installed
properly
so here you can see the node is
installed in my system
to install typescript just run the
command npm
node package manager
install
globally
typescript
run this command and typescript will be
installed since I have already installed
typescript in my device
to cancel this so once you have
installed typescript to check if
typescript is installed or not to see if
the compiler is installed just run the
command
typescript compiler space
version
here you can see it will show the
version of typescript compiler
so now that we have installed both
typescript and node.js let's see
example program for typescript with
node.js
so let's jump into Visual Studio code
one more prerequisite is we need to have
Visual Studio code installed
so create a new folder and create a new
project
so we'll run an example program we'll
create a function
will write a program to add two numbers
so sum
number one
comma number two
will return number one and number two
console.log
will call the function sum
and will provide the arguments
so we'll provide the value
9 comma
5.
so let's say if
and run this program
first we'll run
typescript.cmd type.ts command
foreign
then we'll run node and the file name
here you can see it's showing the value
showing the output as 49 plus 5 the sum
of 9 plus 5 is 40. so we'll delete this
and
write another program
to show a Hello message or a welcome
message
so we'll create a function
we'll name the function as welcome
message
and will return
that user
is equal to
simply learn
console log
will call the function
welcome
and pass
so here we go we'll save this and check
whether we have an error
foreign
welcome to Simply learn we're going to
be going through some of the simple
questions that you would be asked during
a node.js interview let's just get
started so the first question you're
probably going to be asked is you know
what is node.js you know do you know
what it's for and essentially node.js is
and one of the most popular if not the
most popular open source cross-platform
JavaScript programs and it allows you to
build out web applications that run on
the server it's extremely flexible it
allows you to implement a lot of
solutions outside of just the the core
programming runtime and it allows you to
build Solutions extremely quickly in an
open source mindset for devops
it is used essentially for creating
client-sized web applications we'll see
this later on and you may want to talk a
little bit about you know using
express.js and how you can build out
apis uh to work with node.js and
connecting to databases such as mongodb
and that is also really good for being
able to store a data intensive
applications that are asynchronous and
event driven in their model and this is
important when you're talking about
creating applications that can scale
rapidly
so you can then ask be asked you know
how does node.js work well node.js
itself is actually built on the V8
engine and the V8 JavaScript engine is
the same engine that runs JavaScript in
your Chrome web browser extremely fast
it allows for high output and
non-blocking uh through your i o input
outputs and is is single threaded event
Loop
so you're going to be a van asked you
know where can you use node.js and and
the reality is the applications for
node.js keep expanding but there are
some core applications that you can work
with node.js right now so such as web
applications distributed system and
network applications uh probably
referencing the web applications is a
really good starting point because here
you can actually talk about maybe some
examples that you've done where you're
building out some of these web
applications indeed one of the things
that you want to be consistently doing
and peppering your answers with is
examples of work that you have done now
it doesn't matter if those examples are
purely experimental or training examples
that you've done the fact that you've
actually worked with node.js and created
a distributed system or a web
application is really valuable because
it shows that the person that you're
meeting with that you have knowledge and
understanding and practical experience
of applying the theory of working with
new Js with the practice of working with
node.js
so we asked about you know your answer
essentially the io refers to the
transfer of data in and out of a system
and that's really it you know there's a
reason why Google calls that conference
IO it's the transfer of data in and out
of our brains at that conference the
application is same here it's about
moving data in and out of systems
through using node.js
and that every um event can be tracked
and whether it's on a physical device a
network or files within a system again
it's input and output
so let's go through and you know you're
going to be asked you know can you
explain the difference between front end
and back-end development and this is a
question that I can ask a lot when I'm
meeting with clients and you know people
get really confused about what is the
difference between front-end and
back-end development bottom line front
end is what gets resolved inside of your
web browser or the app on your mobile
device backend is what gets resolved
essentially what we call the the back
office or server-side applications but
that's becoming more and more synonymous
for what gets running the cloud
so web applications
um really get a lot of the functionality
of the web application gets run in the
front end and I think with CSS HTML5 uh
client-side JavaScript so we can get
right on the front end everything else
such as connecting to a database
um gets run behind the scenes in the
back end
and so you know anything that's going to
have like Graphics is going to be on the
front end uh apis are going to be run on
the back end and then just finally some
of the scripting languages are used on
the front end so HTML CSS JavaScript
those are all Common Core scripting
languages that you would use you can use
Frameworks such as angularjs and
react.js or View and those would be a
front-end Frameworks uh back-end
Frameworks will include Java PHP Python
and node.js are some of the back-end
Technologies you'd also throw in there
dot net as well and it's just that all
you know Litany of front-end and
back-end Technologies and Frameworks
that you can use and this is a actually
a good point to kind of explain the
experience you have outside of just
working with node.js but other
technologies that you've been working
with that potentially that the client is
also using
so another question you're going to be
asked when you're looking at node.js is
you know can you tell me about npm and
so when somebody asks you what is npm
the first thing you're going to respond
is do you mean node package manager and
the reason why you want to respond like
that is that you want to qualify that
question with understanding that you
know what they're talking about but you
want them to verify that and so node
packet manager is npm
and it's responsible for packaging all
of your modules that you're working with
in node.js and we have a whole series of
videos that we've done on node.js and
every single one of them includes
references to npm
so you're going to be asked you know so
okay you tell me um what it is you know
can you go into a little bit more um
details you know so you can provide two
main functionalities and so one of them
is being able to manage online
repositories of modules and packages
um so you can go to like search Dot
nodejs.org and you can find a packages
that you can install Into Your solution
such as express.js and it also provides
a command line utility that allows you
to manage your packages very quickly
through terminal window or command line
I use vs code a lot Visual Studio code
and it has a command line utility built
right into it that allows me to interact
with npm
so what are some of the modules in
node.js and so you know modules um in
node.js they're essentially like
JavaScript libraries so you can think of
some of the JavaScript libraries that
you may have used the functionality is
somewhat the same but they're designed
for node.js and to run on the server and
there are ways in which you can go ahead
and create some of those modules so for
instance if we're creating a web server
you can actually use the require
commands to be able to require that the
server be there so the example we have
on the right hand side shows that we
really do need to have HTTP which is a
web server and we require that to be
installed and so that if you're running
that npm package it will actually
install the HTTP server and then you can
actually write some code to actually
then listen on the localhost port 2000
for where you'll be running your app
education
and there are just you know there's a
whole bunch of modules that I come with
node.js now right out of the gate and
here are some of the modules that you
have and we also referenced that just
earlier one HTTP is a core module for
running a web server uh you have a
utility function that is useful for
developers to assess features within
your node.js project you have a URL
module for any URL passing you'd be
doing
and you also have a stream which allows
you to be able to stream data in and out
of your system and be able to manage how
that's been worked and then zlib which
allows you to compress and decompress
files so that you can keep your storage
of files
um to a minimum
so a question you're going to be asked
is you know why is node.js being
preferred over backend Technologies such
as Java and PHP and particularly with
gyro it's a very mature stable language
it's been around for more than 20 years
you know PHP
um runs some of them the most powerful
and largest websites out there such as
Facebook so why would you use node.js
well the first response is kind of a
gimme but it is really fast and if you
watched any of the videos that we've
done on node.js building out Solutions
and developing the solutions you'll see
just how fast it is the second is the
really kind of the secret sauce with
node.js is the node package manager and
no package manager allows you to install
additional functionality such as Express
or [ __ ] as a database into your
solution really quick Queen and there's
over 50 000 bundles available for node
package manager
if you're building out a real-time
application that's data intensive and
you need to have apis quickly developed
then node.js is another great it's
really the great solution for you it
allows you to build out these Solutions
really quickly
and there is a easy synchronization
between the server and the client due to
the code base
and then finally because the structure
of node.js is Javascript if you are
making the pivot from being a front-end
web developer to node.js it's just going
to make it a lot easier for you to pick
up node.js because you have that common
language of JavaScript and on top of
that JavaScript is the world's most
popular scripting language
so let's talk about some of the
differences between angular node.js and
so the reason why this question may come
up is the person interviewing you is
seeing whether or not you do know the
difference between a front-end framework
and a back-end framework and this is one
of those questions where you can go well
there are differences but the
differences are because they complement
each other so angular is a front-end
development framework whereas node.js is
a server side and framework other
differences though between the actual
Frameworks themselves is that angular is
written in typescript which is a
modification of JavaScript node.js is
written in C and C plus plus
anger is used for building out single
play client-side web applications and so
that's a keyword there is client-side
whereas node.js is about building out
fast and scalable server-side Network
applications uh so uh again the two
complement each other
uh angular splits web applications into
the MVC and model view control
components whereas node.js generates a
lot of database crazy it does more than
that as well but you can think of
node.js as that glued to your database
so let's talk a little bit about when
you're connecting to a database with
node.js and so
um you're going to probably asking what
is um the most popular database used
with node.js and there are a couple um
mongodb is largely the most popular
nosql cross-platform database MySQL is
also very popular and that's a more
traditional relational database
you would go with mongodb for really
more modern solutions when you're
looking at creating an application
that's going to really scale into just
managing masses and masses of data that
has to be created read updated and
deleted very very quickly
for some of the other popular libraries
that you use for node.js express.js is a
very popular one and I really like
working with express.js allows me to
build out web applications really
quickly more importantly it allows me to
build out apis very quickly and which
you know apis are essentially web
applications themselves but being able
to do that very quickly with a framework
like express.js is very useful uh
Mongoose is an application that makes
connecting to a [ __ ] database really
easy so here is an example of express.js
which is a in itself really a flexible
but a solution that you can do lots with
and Mongoose which is a more focused
solution which allows you know to you
make it easier to connect to your
databases
so you know what are the pros and cons
of working with node.js there's lots of
ways we explain this earlier one that
you can actually build out applications
that run on the cloud why would you you
know what's are the pros and cons so a
pro is that node.js is extremely faster
processing thing and event based model
uh it really is fast I can't is if you
have something that is a very heavy
computational task it's not so good at
that now I will caveat that this is that
node.js is getting better all the time
and so you might have to be provide an
example of what a very heavy
computational task is and that may be uh
calculating a risk on an insurance
application against many many variables
that maybe something that's seen as
computationally very heavy but what you
can do in that example is you can
offload the task to another a solution
that's designed for it and use apis to
pass the data back and forth
Pro JavaScript is used for building out
your applications with node.js great
lots of people know
JavaScript a restriction and again this
is evolving as JavaScript itself evolves
is that when you do a callback you may
end up doing lots of nested callbacks if
you're doing something that's very
complicated again another way around the
con and so this is one of the things
that I always look for is if you have a
blocker or a barrier how do you get
around that barrier and so for instance
when you're talking uh to your recruiter
you can say look the reason why I use
node.js is that it's fast it's event but
it's driven I can use JavaScript there
are some challenges and both what I do
to get around those challenges are and
that's where you can say that you know
you may run the conflict